[Music]
hi guys welcome to part three of the
digital marketing full course video by
simply learn in this video we'll be
covering everything you need to know
about digital marketing we'll do this
with the help of our instructor rob
sanders in this video we'll learn about
content marketing strategy how to get
traffic to your website email marketing
how you can work with mailchimp and
about affiliate marketing
finally i'll tell you how you can become
a digital marketer and rob will help you
learn about digital marketing career and
jobs he'll also be covering 50 important
interview questions that you might
encounter in your next interview
now let's get started content marketing
strategy
so buckle up and let's get right to it
and we're gonna get right into some of
the best practices some tips some
methodologies some things you should be
doing with content marketing so right
out of the gate let's start talking
about
knowing your audience okay so content is
all about
writing for a particular audience so
it's just like speaking except when
we're speaking to somebody we're
speaking directly to them content is
very similar and so we have to be able
to know our audience ahead of time so
what you can do is collect demographics
of your target audience based on
who's coming to your website so you can
get that data in google analytics under
audience email subscribers i mean
who is subscribing to your emails who do
you already have in your email database
and you can look at social media i mean
you look at facebook you can look at the
people who already connected to you okay
these are just some three three of many
examples you could be doing to
gather data on your audience okay you
have to know who your audience is before
you start writing you know for a
successful content marketing strategy
you really just need to know your
audience and basically you're going to
segment them based on their interests so
that content is going to be catered to
that audience okay so if it signs that
likes a specific you know product uh
that you offer or feature that's part of
that product that you offer then that's
the segment you're gonna be writing
about so you need to collect your data
on your audience ahead of time then
you're gonna segment that audience okay
so you're not gonna write content for
everyone because the shoe doesn't
necessarily fit for everyone okay the
shoe has to fit for specific foot and in
this case we're talking about an
audience we need to be able to segment
our audience out and you could certainly
segment them out by age by gender by
education level by income by interest i
mean these are just some of the examples
again it could be new returning or new
reusers versus returning users it could
be users who have purchased from you in
the past versus users who haven't
purchased from you in the past it could
certainly be an age range or it could be
even going further on interest level or
combination thereof okay so for example
you can get that demographic information
using google analytics just got to go
into analytics under audience under
demographics you're going to see age and
br it's age is broken out by age range
and they're going to see gender so
you're going to see a breakdown of
gender and use that to your advantage so
if you're going to
you know write some content and you know
99 of your traffic is female the age of
18 to 24 then you know that content's
been catered accordingly so we could
certainly go to facebook page insights
and get some really good demographic
data there because facebook is all about
demographics okay so
you could see exactly
you know how many fans you have broken
out by men versus women and then you can
see again same thing as google analytics
you could see an age range breakout you
could use twitter analytics i mean
twitter has share some really good
insights into education level so
you know if you're dealing with you know
highly sophisticated people who have
master's degrees or even higher or let's
just say even on linkedin you know that
a majority of the people you're trying
to target are c-level meaning
ceos or cfos or cmos you know chief
marketing officers or chief executive
officers then you're going to cater your
message a little bit different than say
mid-range managers or or you know even
high range managers or even vps so use
your audience information you collect on
these various platforms to your
advantage okay so let's jump into number
two we want to create high quality
content now i know this sounds like a
given but
and i say but heavily there's not a lot
of high quality content out there on the
internet so separate yourself first and
foremost always always always create
high quality content it's going to
result in a lot of things that are going
to benefit you you know one you're going
to come across as you know somebody who
knows what they're talking about and
that's going to help increase your brand
awareness okay when you increase your
brand awareness people know about you so
it's likely going to increase traffic to
your website or if you're on social
media you know if you produce good high
quality content people are going to
share that content okay so
from an seo perspective it can improve
website ranking meaning if you have good
quality content you know and it's really
focused in on a specific topic or a
certain set of core words keywords then
you're gonna rank improves website dwell
time meaning hey you get good content
people are gonna hang around to see what
else you have to offer okay so it's no
secret that you know good content you
usually leads to you know quality
engagement and then
certainly last but not least you can
gain a lot of leads here meaning hey
somebody likes what you have to say
whether it's a video or blog post or or
infographic you know people are going to
become more interested more engaged
spend more time and that's all going to
funnel through to somebody taking that
next step in the funnel and
becoming more interested in your service
or even purchasing one of your products
so creating high quality content
involves brainstorming topics and terms
you know you've got to do the upfront
work due diligence is at work here so
brainstorm some topics use a keyword
research tool to gather results so if
you have a topic you know one of the
benefits of quality content is rankings
go to google's keyword planner
understand how much quality
and and understand how much competition
each keyword has or understand how much
volume each keyword has that's what's
available in google's keyword planner or
any really any keyword planning tool
you always want to create original
content okay so you don't want to
plagiarize or take somebody else's
content and then you want to support
that content with compelling headlines
so if you have a piece of content you
got to get somebody's attention
write a nice headline that's going to
grab their attention okay so give
valuable content to readers and add
resources from well-known sites so if
you you do borrow say
a data point from another source then
you know cite that source you also want
to create engaging and thought-provoking
content get somebody to think i mean
people are going to rage your content
because they not they don't know the
subject matter their interests in the
subject matter and they want to be able
to spend the time taking something away
from that content follow a logical
structure and use relevant images i
can't stress this one enough you know
just throw things on a web page you know
put some structure to it maybe you have
to break it out if you feel like you
have too much content there's no harm in
breaking it into part one versus part
two get people uh tease them a bit get
them to come back and read part two okay
use different content forms in case
somebody's interested maybe you want to
capture some data you know prefer short
paragraphs to make the content readable
remember if you're talking to c-level
folks you know maybe you don't have to
dummy down the content so to speak but
if you're dealing with you know folks or
people that are right out of high school
or still in high school then adjust your
content and format and paragraphs
accordingly and then update the content
as well just because you publish it
doesn't mean that it's done i mean when
we're talking about a webpage we're
talking about something that is actively
changing or can change the medium that
is dynamic okay so if a data points
change go back in and update that data
point and then let people know about it
because they may want to come back and
and you know check in to see how much
that data points changed so these are
all
you know good takeaways for creating
high quality content there's some other
things that you should be aware of you
know grammatical mistakes you know you
need to avoid those there's no reason
for grammatical mistakes today's
technology doesn't allow for it and
hey listen we all have friends we have
colleagues my desk is sitting next to a
colleague who's more than happy to read
something before it gets published so
take advantage of the resources you have
available no reason for it because if
you have a grammatical mistake you just
lost a lot of credibility you know don't
be afraid to add a clear call to action
at the end of your content if somebody's
interested in reading it they're
probably going to be interested in
taking the next step whatever that next
step is okay so creating content that
fulfills viewers requirements meaning if
somebody's searching for something and
your content shows up in the search
results then they're actively looking
for you what are you offering them is it
fulfilling their requirements you know
don't be afraid to use examples
throughout your content in fact work in
or integrate some case studies in there
show clear examples to stress your
points
and then just don't put words on a web
page you know so break up that content
with an image that's going to be
visually appealing okay and you can add
images from public domain sites meaning
stock imagery if that's what's going to
help create visually appealing content
and then give more information to your
audience and we say prefer to give more
information meaning hey going back to
the content i was saying about breaking
it up organizing it if you have more
information you don't withhold it have
them come back and read a secondary blog
post or secondary piece that supports
the original now we want to move from
high quality content to running a b test
baby test so important why because with
a b split testing you can increase your
conversion rates okay so four elements
to test and your content marketing
strategy so if you have content say a
blog and you're testing that blog you
know test out the images test out the
forms do you have a long form or short
form you know test out the content
length you can have a variation that is
a lot shorter than the original does
that increase or decrease bounce rates
play around with call to actions your
call to actions do matter you know do
you want to use a softer call to action
a softer tone or do you want to use
something very direct and strong you
know test call to actions to see what's
going to get people to move closer
through the closer to purchasing and
through that funnel so a b testing to me
is something that should be naturally
done with google optimize it's free so
with images you know you could test a
lot of different variations of images
anything from people
to
you know outlandish image rage is just
something very stock and neutral but
just make sure that those images are
relevant to the post you know test the
length of that content you know again if
you know that your average time on page
is very low
you know don't write something very long
write something that you think is going
to stick with that time on page but on
your a b test create something maybe a
little longer if it's engaging enough
maybe somebody's going to stay a little
bit longer on the page so you know
create a variation it's going to play
with that length okay so use analytics
to your advantage to figure out
as a baseline what amount of content is
getting people to stay on the page then
see if you could push the envelope one
way or the other okay improving the page
with sign up forms really what you want
to do is create a user friendly
experience so when you have sign up
forms and don't make them non-intuitive
don't make them difficult you know link
maybe up to facebook or google so
if they're creating an account they can
create an account via google or facebook
or you know don't put too many forms on
the page and then on those ctas as i
mentioned play around with the tone you
can also play around the color i mean i
test color all the time believe it or
not color does matter don't use red use
green people react to different colors
but again you have cultural variances as
well so you got to take that into
account if you're in the middle east or
the far east asia you know color schemes
and what you say
matters and it changes versus say you
know europe or the west okay so keep
that in mind when you're making changes
on color or tone or placement and things
of that nature so you want to conduct a
competitor analysis so we're talking
about creating high quality content
testing that content you know
brainstorming some topics you know
looking at your audience you're doing
all this work you might as well take the
next step and figure out what it is your
competitors are doing so you can opt for
competitive analysis by identifying your
competitor's top performing content for
specific topics okay and so
really what we're trying to do here is
improve our conversion rates so what are
your competitors doing what are their
baselines we can maybe up that annie i
mean that data is also available in
google analytics so you can look at
benchmarking reports in google analytics
to get some form or fashion you can also
go to facebook and look at your
competitors facebook pages and see
what's performing in terms of engagement
but what you want to do is find out your
strongest competitors by using search
engines or check which websites are
competing with you and again that could
include facebook as well or maybe even
linkedin so you go with the search
engine route you can always type in that
coveted keyword that you want to be
found for see who's ranking ahead of you
and you can see the metadata meaning the
title tag in the meta description you
can actually see hey what are these guys
writing that's getting them recognized
in the search engine rankings so you can
certainly if you go to search engine
route you could certainly leverage an
seo platform like search uh sem rush or
moz or something like that that's going
to allow you to get some good insight on
competitor information so keep in mind
there are seo platforms that will give
you information on your competitors and
that's what these seo platforms are good
for so number five moving on choose a
suitable content format so
now we've done all this homework we know
what we want to say we know who we want
to say it to we're ready to do some
testing but we need to find a format
because it's not always about a web page
per se meaning content on a web page
there's not always about a blog post
with content in that blog post okay we
need to decide the type of content
that's going to fit what we're trying to
say so again you can go the traditional
route with just posting a blog post and
there's nothing wrong with that because
with a blog post you can incorporate
video and imagery you could also go a
more harder route when i say harder more
i say official route with an e-book or
case study something that
a user is going to be able to take away
with maybe download okay something more
official um something more in-depth
something with a harder stamp on it so
that that shows individuals that you've
taken the time you've done this homework
you've done this research you've done
some really in-depth analysis and now
the proper format for that is not a blog
post it's an e-book now if you're into
talking like i am then you can certainly
do a podcast and podcasts are always
popular depending on the topic so you
got to be aware of the topic now videos
are always always a good option you got
the likes of video
and video and youtube and some other you
know video platforms out there that
allow you the ability to get found very
quickly especially with the likes of
youtube you know people use youtube
before they go on to purchasing a
product so think about that so if you're
trying to get somebody if you're trying
to sway an audience to
move from being a brand awareness and a
loyal you know customer to taking the
next step okay to purchasing more or
purchasing for the first time and so
videos kind of help convey that now if
you're trying to convey a lot of
different points then an infographic
might be your best option instead of
having to write out all those points try
using an infographic to convey those
points visually now again with blog
posts it should have valuable content
that can be shared by your website
visitors on social so that's the key
make sure you have those shareable
social icons now with ebooks it should
have longer in-depth content so
and it shouldn't be published frequently
so maybe if this is something you're
doing annually then ebook could be the
format with a case study what you should
have a customer story that succeeded in
and you solving that customer's problem
so the case study is always there for
you know somebody to get an idea of what
you're all about infographic is just
visualizing data in a more organized way
in a more visual way so somebody
understands what you're trying to convey
now with that podcast again suppose your
audience doesn't have an interest in
reading again it could be a certain age
certain gender a certain culture hey
everybody absorbs information
differently so think about it ask
yourself is a podcast the best way to
communicate to my target audience and
then videos are highly engaging they're
also shareable on blog posts and pretty
much most if not all social media
platforms so once you've done that once
you choose the proper format you want to
choose a content management system
that's going to work for you so you want
to be able to choose something where you
can plan appropriately produce
manage publish and measure results all
in one place there are plenty of content
management systems out there that will
help you do all of those things okay so
some examples are wordpress hubspot
binder i mean we can list hundreds if
you're into blogging you know wordpress
is the way to go if you're into building
out landing pages that you want to you
know share you know hotspot could be the
way to go okay there are lots of
available options out there so moving on
number seven target your audience using
emails okay so what are we talking about
well we all know what emails are emails
help us to communicate directly with our
target audience and convert them to
leads so email is a good way to follow
up with your audience so if you've done
a podcast follow up with an email you
maybe get them to you know fill out a
survey via email based on that podcast
or if you create a podcast about some
data that you talked about in that
podcast follow up that with with them
via email with an infographic perhaps
okay built into the email okay there's
lots of ways that all these formats can
complement themselves via email okay you
could certainly take a blog post and
package it into an email and have a link
pointing back to the blog post maybe as
a teaser or if you're doing a series a
series of blog posts you know you could
tease that in an email so an email is a
good way to you know follow up with your
target audience indirectly or directly
when we say indirectly
you know you can collect emails and send
out those emails with you know certain
information or
what you should be doing is targeting
and segmenting your emails just like you
are your content so if you're producing
content for a certain audience then make
sure that particular audience gets that
same email now some of the email content
that you could share with your target
audience are newsletters okay seasonal
emails promotional emails automated
messaging and what we mean by automated
messaging hey if somebody just purchased
from you send them a thank you email
maybe follow up a couple days later with
another email with a survey or
what you could do is if you know who
your loyal customers are you target them
with a promotional email so there's lots
of ways to slice and dice content via
email okay just make sure you know your
target audience is there's lots of
things you can do in email again you can
complement lots of different formats
within email as i mentioned before with
a podcast or a blog post so keep all
that in mind email's a good way to
communicate with your audience okay the
last point we want to make here is use
native ads okay so we talk about native
ads it's one of the smartest ways to
connect your audience with your brand so
for example this is a native ad on
buzzfeed okay it's about 15 bands that
probably won't exist without led
zeppelin okay so for you folks out there
that don't know who led zeppelin is a
rock group from the 70s late 60s 70s
okay disbanded in 80 81 82 early 80s
okay but you know people grew up like
myself listening to led zeppelin okay so
you can see the headline here 15 bands
that probably won't exist with the
outlet zeppelin you know i'm interested
in who those bands might be even if you
don't know who led zeppelin is okay you
might be inquisitive to say okay
who is this led zeppelin group and what
are these 15 bands the key here is not
to say the headline or led zeppelin per
se but it's a native ad and it's sitting
next to
content talking about music okay so
according to forbes online audiences are
25 percent more likely to look at a
native ad than at a banner and so that
native ad in this case we're talking
about music needs to be sitting or
accompanied alongside content talking
about in this case music you know would
help if it was rock music just music in
general might get enough to get peak
people's interest okay so if you're
going to create content you know align
that content with something that's you
know naturally going to fit and that's
why we call them native ads because
they're native to the content that
they're associated with so finally after
all that's said and done when all you've
done is create good content follow up
via emails targeting your audience and
associating that content with you know
content natively then you can always
measure your content performance so
my favorite part of it all you going
analytics going on facebook insights you
know you want to go in and check out how
that content is performing and you want
to do that because you want to be able
to see what's performing what's not
performing the key here is associating
the content with kpis that's really the
key so measuring the right metrics can
help you understand whether your content
is engaging or not so again measuring
the right metrics okay so when we're
talking about a video you're not
necessarily going to look at page views
you're going to look at video views so
you know some of these basic metrics of
users and sessions and pages bounce rate
you know dwell time that's all great but
you just need to make sure that
you're aligning the right metric with
the right asset so for example if you
have a case study or ebook you want to
make sure that
you're measuring how many downloads the
ebook or the
case study received again with the video
you want to measure video views now if
you're packaging up emails and sending
them out to your target audience you
want to make sure you look at open rates
and click rates okay so a lot of things
you can be looking at so make sure you
choose the right metrics because there's
hundreds and hundreds of metrics to
choose from so just be aware all the
different metrics that are available
you know if you're in it for search okay
how much traffic getting from search
where are you ranking so there are a lot
of things you need to think about so
think about the content that you're
producing and think about how you want
to be able to measure that content so
let's go back over our checklist here
so what you could do is create an
editorial calendar in fact i would
highly suggest you create an editorial
calendar in order to keep track of all
the content you've done over a period of
time are you making your content worth
reading that means are you
checking the results of that content
what we just went over measuring the
content is it worth reading have a
column set up in that editorial calendar
you know performing or not performing if
it's not performing don't do it again
okay curate your content okay you always
want to you know make sure you're
reusing or using or adding to the
content that you've created guest post
on influential blogger websites you want
to add statistics numbers and quotes to
your content make it engaging make it
look like you've done your homework you
could share all your content not just on
social media but you know platforms like
slideshare now you can share it on all
social media platforms i'd highly
recommend it and again you can even
repurpose it as a blog post so if it's a
podcast
then you know you can recite that
podcast in the form of a blog okay so
get some testimonials that support some
of your content again create a podcast
you can send out an email with a survey
or trying to solicit some testimonials
or if you post something on facebook you
know leverage the feedback you get from
facebook in the form of a testimonial
okay and then you want to promote your
blog post for maximum success and a lot
of that means seo so make sure you do
your due diligence and get the right
keywords in that blog post okay so you
can create personas for different user
audiences okay so remember it's all
about tone okay so if you're going to
create a blog post make sure your tone
is aligned with that right audience
whether that be young middle aged or
older
are you choosing the right type of
content okay you'll know based on the
results okay you want to add h1 and h2
tags on your web pages why because when
we're talking about content we're
talking about organizing the content and
h1 and h2s help you organize the content
appropriately customize the metadata
metadata metadatas title tag and meta
tag descriptions and even all tags okay
all of that is for search so you want
your content to show up in search
whether that's video infographic or blog
post all of it can be shown in search
results so make sure you write a good
title and make sure you write a good
meta description because that's what
people are going to see when they search
okay so you want to create a detailed
summary and title and again that goes
along with the title tag a meta
description and then you want to make it
easy for the audience to ask questions
and comment on your blog so don't be
afraid like i'm gonna do right now in
this video is if i'm missing anything
from this checklist feel free to comment
hey i've written my fair share content
but i could be talking to an audience
that is just as qualified as i am and
they may have some tips so feel free to
comment underneath this video now don't
be afraid to ask just like i just did
people are always willing to provide
constructive feedback so don't be afraid
to ask for it and make it easy so to me
every blog post needs to have some form
of a comment box because blog posts are
out there to solicit engagement now
let's recap everything we talked about
because we'd certainly covered a lot and
there's a lot to cover when it comes to
content marketing so one know your
audience again you can lean on google
analytics
you know demographic data whether it be
age or gender you could do the same with
facebook and twitter and linkedin you
know every platform has some data you
could take away create high quality
content when i mean high quality content
brainstorm some topics has it already
been written to death about or is this
unique you know don't write something
your competitors are writing okay don't
copy what your competitors have written
organize your content support it with
good imagery all of these are tips to
creating high quality content okay when
you create that content think about
running to maybe test you know run some
variations
and switch out the image
switch out the call to action see what's
going to get people to react and engage
with the content conduct competitor
analysis so lean on the facebooks of the
world to see what your competitors are
posting see what's engaging for them
okay you can also lean on these seo
platforms like sem rush and moz all you
got to do is plug in a domain and
they're going to give you some
information about where a particular
competitor ranks for keyword or how many
backlinks and what websites are linking
to them so all that's available in these
seo platforms okay so you want to choose
a suitable content format we listed a
few from ebooks to case studies to
podcasts to infographics to blog posts
to videos it's up to you what you think
is best for your audience just keep in
mind you need to be able to measure it
and so that's the important thing if it
doesn't work the first time out then you
might want to consider changing out the
content format choose a content
management system you know plenty out
there wordpress is a good one if you're
going to be a blogger okay blogging
allows you to you know post optimize
that blog post you know you could have
the ability to share that blog post
across social platforms and you can also
have that blog post show up in search
engine results so you can't do any of
that without a good content management
system so you want to target your
audience using emails okay so email is a
good way to again further communicate
with that particular segmented audience
and again you could use it to send out
promotional emails to loyal followers or
you can use systematic emails to send an
email a thank you email somebody
purchases and then another follow-up
email and again you can repurpose
some of the content you've done in
another format in the form of an email
so
you know if you created a video you know
put that video in the form of an email
and send it out to your audience to make
sure they're not missing out on that
video you just created so lots of ways
to use email take advantage of email
it's your ally here okay use native ads
okay don't be afraid to put that content
and pair it with some other content on
another website it's been proven people
are going to engage in an ad that they
see based on the content they're
currently reading because the ad if it's
native it's going to be similar in
nature to the content they're currently
engaged in and then measure your content
performance i can't say this enough make
sure you're leveraging google analytics
okay with google analytics or facebook
insights or twitter or linkedin or any
other platform you're running on they're
going to have data on what you've posted
so take advantage of it
align your kpis so if it's an e-book or
case study
don't measure just traffic measure how
many people are actually downloading
them okay if it's a video you know how
many people like the video how many
people are commenting how many people
are sharing the video how many people
subscribing to your playlist based on
that video content okay so these are all
things you can measure okay so every
platform from wordpress to youtube
to reddit has some form of analytics
associated with it today we're going to
talk about how to get traffic to your
website so thank you for joining and
let's get started so
let's imagine you're setting up your own
website okay you're clicking away you're
developing using some good tools you're
developing you're designing you're doing
some qa
you're testing you're sharing with
friends in an alpha version and then
finally
your website is all set up
congratulations well when you hit enter
and your website is finally published
what's going to happen well a few days
later you're checking your website and
you're looking at analytics and you
notice your traffic's very low okay well
you're scratching your head because
you've done all this work
with your website but you're not getting
any traffic so the reason is
you
spent all your time developing designing
the website to make it look good but you
didn't do anything
or any planning
or any strategy around bringing users to
your website so the two go hand in hand
you just can't build a website without
thinking about how to drive users to the
website and so before i tell you how to
bring traffic to your website let me
tell you why this is so important okay
why do we want to bring users to our
website i mean it has to be on equal
ground as web development and design is
somebody who goes to your site and then
does something when they get to your
site so you have users and when those
users get to your site they're
generating page views and traffic and
you want to turn that traffic into
engagement okay so each page's traffic
is configured independently of all their
pages so when you go when somebody goes
to your website they look at a page
that's a page view in certain pages on
your website you want to turn that page
view into a conversion okay whether that
be you know looking at a video or
purchasing something so think of these
pages on your website as salespeople
they're trying to convert visitors who
come to your website but first we need
to get the visitors to your website so
when you get visitors to your website
again you can generate sales which means
revenue or
you can increase brand awareness or you
can earn revenue through sponsored posts
and advertisements so if you have for
example a lot of content on your website
you can turn that in to
revenue by hosting ads on your website
so when somebody clicks on that ad
you're going to earn a percentage of
that click okay what that click is worth
so having a website means
a lot of good things for you but first
you got to get the traffic there and so
what we're going to do is we're going to
tell you how to drive traffic to your
website so there's lots of different
ways in which you can bring traffic to
your website well the first is paid
advertising so paying to advertise your
products services with ads is one of the
easiest ways to drive traffic to your
website so some of the options available
are
search ads social media ads or display
ads so search ads are ads that are
displayed in the search engine results
so when a user types in a keyword query
you want your ad to show up based on
that keyword query okay so an example is
digital marketing course somebody types
in digital marketing course and simply
learn is the first app that shows up how
do we know it's an ad because you can
see the word ad next to the domain so
when somebody clicks on that link simply
learn is going to pay google so that's
how search advertising works okay the
next is social so social media marketing
involves increasing traffic or
engagement or brand awareness lots of
different strategies but you're instead
of doing this on search you're doing it
on a social media platform okay so
for example
you can advertise on any particular
platform and the way you advertise could
be with an image it could be with a
video so in this case you could see
cobreo
is doing a sponsored ad here how to
succeed with google ads and then another
form of advertising is display so
display means creating ads that are
placed on specific websites so with
display
unlike search you have a choice in the
ad format with search you only have text
ads but with display you have text edge
image ads rich media ads video ads so
you have lots of different options in
which you can advertise on other
websites so the idea here is to get your
ad in front of the right audience when
they could see your display banner your
banner ad
then it's going to be more visual
more appealing generate some brand
interest and hopefully you can get
somebody to click on that ad and over to
your website so that's paid advertising
again through search through social
through display but you can also promote
your site on social media so once your
content has gone live you could take
advantage of different social media
platforms i mean it really depends on
what you're trying to promote because
what you're trying to promote needs to
align with the appropriate social media
platform so
facebook is best suited for industries
like food and beverages and news and
media and if you're selling a product so
you fall into one of those categories
and facebook could be the right platform
for you if you're involved in again
beauty or food and beverage or
e-commerce then you can also leverage
instagram which is part of facebook's
ecosystem so if you advertise on
facebook you can also advertise on
instagram and or instagram so it doesn't
have to be and facebook and instagram it
could be facebook or instagram you also
have linkedin as a platform linkedin is
great for b2b so
if you're trying to promote industry
news or or tips and best practices or
job postings then linkedin is the place
for you it's a b2b platform it's great
for
targeting specific industries targeting
specific job levels or job descriptions
okay so linkedin is great if you're into
b2b focusing on the business side of it
so you also have youtube now youtube is
part of google's ecosystem youtube is a
video platform okay so it's great if
you're trying to promote gaming or
entertainment if you're a vlogger okay
so youtube's a great way to promote your
site uh by getting your product out
there in the form of a video and then
you have twitter twitter to me
encompasses a lot of different
industries beauty and fitness news and
media entertainment okay you have
limited number of characters but a lot
of people are active on twitter and it's
a great way to generate some awareness
and get some clicks over to your website
so these are just some of the most
popular social media platforms of course
there are plenty more out there the
third way in which you can drive traffic
to your site is guest post blogging so
most of you already know what blogging's
all about well if you're blogging for
your own site you can jump on somebody
else's site and blog
on their behalf so having the
opportunity to guest post on another
website can be very helpful because one
that other blog could have lots of
traffic and have a a well-known brand so
if you're blogging on another blog it's
going to build your brand awareness and
potentially increase traffic to your
blog or website so it exposes to you to
targeted traffic so if you're going to
guest blog guest blog on a site that's
very relevant to your business or
industry that way you're targeting the
right audience okay you can expand your
personal network so getting yourself out
there getting your brand out there in
front of a different audience and then
obviously for serves because it
generates backlinks so serps search
engine ranking pages means that hey if
you want to rank organically you're
going to have to generate some backlinks
so guest blogging is a way to generate
some backlinks to your site and in
effect that's going to help you get your
pages ranked higher because google is
going to recognize the relationship from
one blog to your blog and build up your
relevancy so some other benefits here to
guest blogging is you can grow your
social media following because you can
then promote that on social media that
you're guest blogging okay again you can
improve your online authority okay
because when you're guest blogging and
you have recognition on that guest blog
if it's a popular blog then it's going
to help your domain and page authority
for seo and then the end result is going
to improve your backlink score so a lot
of benefits to guest blogging to me at
the end of the day it's just about
reaching out to your audience using
another platform to do that in the form
of a blog and the results of that is
going to mean more brand awareness for
you and turning that traffic from that
other blog into qualified leads so you
can also interview industry thought
leaders so that's another way an
interesting way to generate traffic to
your site so reaching out to thought
leaders for interviews okay could
generate some credibility for you and
the other person so it's reciprocal so
it means that you're active in the
industry that you're in and it allows
you to engage with other
leaders in the industry and the indirect
net result of that could be increased
traffic because if you do the interview
and you record it or if it's via video
then you can obviously post it on other
platforms and that could in turn drive
traffic to your website obviously just
like guest blogging it's going to
increase your reach so getting yourself
out there if nobody knows who your brand
is and they know who the thought leaders
are and they say you're interviewing the
thought leaders then that's going to put
you in front of these people and so it's
going to increase your reach another way
to drive traffic to your website is just
to make sure your website's responsive
and what do we mean by response of well
we mean does it work on multiple devices
specifically mobile so depending on the
device your website hides shows shrinks
enlarges or moves content so that it
conforms to the browser that that
person's looking at on your web for your
website so if somebody's looking on
mobile at your website you want to make
sure that your website adjusts
accordingly so you want to be able to
you know test to make sure it's
responsive and so is content arranged
based on importance okay does it work
across different browsers on different
devices and do the images text and
everything else align just like it does
on desktop so there are plenty of tools
out there on the web all you need to do
is just do a search for you know check
my website for responsiveness you know
so you you can use plenty of tools to
check to see if your website is
responsive towards multiple devices why
is that important because if somebody
goes to your website via mobile and your
site doesn't align properly or the
content's all stretched out and somebody
has to maneuver their browser just to
see your website then chances are
they're not going to come back chances
are they're not going to convert okay so
you want to be able to revise your
device browser combinations you want to
make sure that everything works
accordingly you want to be able to test
those fonts make sure they look good and
then you also want to make sure that
people can navigate so if they're on
mobile are they going to navigate just
as easy as they can on desktop and if
you have any pop-ups you want to
probably make sure they're removed so
that way when somebody's looking at your
website they're not getting interfered
with on mobile and then of course you
want to make sure that these pages load
okay so they load just as quick on
desktop as they should on mobile and
vice versa so they should not take a
long time to load so moving on from
responsiveness on mobile to building a
brand community so brand community
refers to a group of people who identify
your brand and use your brand as a
platform to exchange ideas and
contribute content some advantages of
having a brand community are promoting
brand evangelism and loyalty it can be a
source of feedback loyalty and ideas so
build a community build a brand
community who you know identify with you
okay so continue to
you know treat these people as loyal
customers okay maybe give them a
promotion uh to use specifically just
for them that they can use on your
website or talk directly to them because
you know that they're followers they're
repeat customers they purchase for you
multiple times so talk to them
differently as well you know who these
people are and that's what building a
brand is all about it's about
identifying your brand with other people
okay and identify people who identify
with your brand and messaging and
talking to them as if they're part of
your own community your own family so
you can use user generated content that
provides future marketing strategies so
the feedback you get from your own
community could be in turn used to
promote or used in future marketing
strategies i.e advertising i.e post on
social okay it can also provide pr
opportunities so it's a chance for you
to you know put out press releases based
on the community that you built so any
brand regardless of who it is should be
able to identify with your audience
their target audience and that target
audience eventually going to become part
of a community these are group of people
who identify with you what you're trying
to sell what your cause is what your
mission statement is what your services
they identify with you so leverage them
and reciprocate identify them talk to
them separately
give them the
what they deserve the respect and
loyalty that they deserve as well
because they're communicating and
they're following you as a brand so the
next thing you could do to drive traffic
is be active in the comments section so
engage in relevant and thought-provoking
conversations on other blogs and sites
it doesn't necessarily have to be
another blog per se it could be other
sites like reddit or quora or media
sites that have a lot of content that
are broken out by industry that allow
you to engage in conversation allow you
to either upvote or share or respond
okay so be active because when you're
active people are going to see that hey
you're a leader in the industry you know
what you're talking about you have some
some brand equity you have some thought
and some knowledge on the specific topic
and subject so it just puts you in a
better light when you can respond and be
active on these different platforms okay
let's turn our attention to
search engine optimization also known as
seo or organic search so in order to
drive traffic to your site you're going
to have to implement an seo strategy why
do you want to implement an seo strategy
because it can help you improve your
overall search ability and visibility on
search engines and obviously that comes
with advantages one of those advantages
is obviously more traffic to the site
search is still king in terms of volumes
of people using search on a daily basis
so you have a great opportunity to be
found it also builds trust and
credibility because still a majority of
the people who do a search click on an
organic search listing and so if you're
found organically
and you're ranked number one then
chances are somebody's going to click on
your listing and it provides increased
engagement and traffic and so what that
means is more traffic more engagement an
engagement is something you define it
could be again a download of a document
or the clicking on the play button of a
video or or submitting a form or signing
up for a newsletter or calling these are
all forms of engagement so
the amount of traffic you drive from
organic search to your website is only
going to improve engagement okay so you
can also provide an improved user
experience and what do we mean by that
well if you're getting lots of traffic
from organic search you have a really
good opportunity to do a b testing and
when you do a b testing you can improve
user experience meaning you're showing
one variation against the other from
people coming from organic search and so
this is helpful
and that you know if you're running an a
b test the variation has a chance to
improve or outperform the original and
if it outperforms the original you're
improving user experience and then it
helps target quality traffic so seo to
me or all search is the only medium in
which you're meeting somebody halfway
you're you're addressing what they're
looking for so if somebody's looking for
a pair of red women's nike shoes the
2019 model and you have that particular
product to offer well you have a chance
of showing up via organic search
somebody types in new women's red nike
shoes size whatever at the year 2019
model then of course they're gonna
probably likely click on your listing
because you have what they're looking
for and and that goes with any keyword
any industry any business any segment
any type of product you're selling so
again you have a chance to really be
visible for what people are looking for
and so that's the beauty of search
engine optimization you have a really
good opportunity here to meet people
halfway to drive quality traffic
to get them to enjoy a good user
experience all the while generating
engagement and along with seo we want to
be able to build backlinks so
seo is a two-pronged approach meaning
you have two strategies in one on page
and off page and so
off page involves backlinking so
backlinks are just links that direct
users from
other websites to your own website so
with that inherently it's going to drive
traffic qualified traffic to your
website because if somebody's on a
relevant website that's linking to yours
and they click on that link and go to
your website it's likely going to be
qualified meaning they're going to be
relevant and so
back linking because it's an off-page
strategy why is it an off-page seo
strategy because if google crawls that
other site that has a link to you
then that's going to give you credit
because google say hey this site's
getting some links from some relevant
sites we must think they're relevant and
therefore we're going to trust this site
so
by google
trusting your site it's going to improve
your organic ranking and with the
organic rankings being improved meaning
it's going to mean faster indexing so
what does that mean so you want to be
indexed by the search engines and so the
quicker google can find your pages even
if it's on somebody else's site then
that means they're gonna follow that
link go to that page on your site and
take that page back to their servers to
be indexed okay so the quicker you can
get index the quicker you get found and
then it helps with referral traffic so
again we noticed that our efforts are on
seo organic search but if you're getting
traffic from another website hey that
still counts that's referral traffic
okay so that's a side advantage to
having backlinks is good traffic from
other sites okay so those those are
inherently the some of the reasons to do
backlinking okay never hurts i mean
there's brand awareness reasons to being
on other sites as well there's industry
leadership meaning if you you post
content on reddit okay you're coming
across as an industry leader but yet
generating a backlink which helps with
seo and referral traffic so there's a
lot of benefits to building backlinks
and the opposite of backlinks are
internal links so you want to do
internal linking and that just means
connecting one page on your site to
another and why is that beneficial
because it can help direct visitors to
other pages they wouldn't normally
otherwise find via your navigation so if
you're active on a blog don't be afraid
to include multiple internal links you
want to move people through your site
you want the flow of traffic to go from
one page to another to another and so
when you do internal linking just like
with backlinks it's going to improve the
indexing of your website google is going
to follow those links and index those
pages and google does give credits from
an seo perspective from an internal
linking perspective so if one page is
linked to another and that page has
really good relevance in the eyes of
google then the other page is probably
going to benefit from that the other
reason we want to do internal linking
again you want to move people from your
one page of your site to the other and
when you do that it's going to reduce
bounce rates so bounce rate is simply
the rate at which people land on a page
and then leave so if i have 100 people
land on my home page and only one person
went to another page and the other 99
left the site then that's a 99 bounce
rate so by putting internal links in
place you're helping people move from
one page to the other and thus
reducing the bounce rate and that's what
you want you want to keep people on your
site you want to be greedy it also
drives traffic to older posts so again
when we say older posts we're really
referring to blog posts so if you have a
relevant blog post and you're writing a
new blog post then link the two together
if it's relevant link it i don't you
know regardless of how old it is you
know you want to show google that these
older blog posts just because they were
written a year ago doesn't mean they're
outdated and old-fashioned okay or
useless you want to keep them alive by
linking to them so to me that's a good
strategy for internal linking link to
older blog posts you know show people
you're an industry expert you've been
doing this for a while and then you have
lots of content to share okay so the
longer you can keep somebody on your
website the more likely it is they're
going to engage and convert and some
other inherent benefits improves page
rank so what we mean by pagerank is
simply just a rank that google gives
pages so the more internal linking you
have the better off you are and then it
helps spread link juice across websites
and we'll maybe buy link juice again
just like backlinking it builds
relevancy so just keep all these
inherent benefits in mind to internal
linking the end result is keeping the
flow of traffic on your site and all
these other benefits will fall into
place okay so another way in which you
can really hone in on traffic to your
website is long tail keywords and long
tail keywords to me are more than just
one or two keyword phrases okay so
they're usually three or longer keywords
in a phrase okay so long tail keywords
really nowadays account for most web
searches people
really take the time to even post
questions as a search query say likely
somebody it's unlikely somebody's going
to go into search and just type in the
word choose they might type in red shoes
but that's unlikely what they're
probably going to type in is you know
red
nike running shoes 2019 or some
variation of that okay that's a long
tail keyword and some of the advantages
of using long-tail keywords to be found
for are less competition so if you're
using broad keywords like red shoes then
who doesn't want to be found for red
shoes well you don't necessarily you
don't want to be found for red shoes
because it's too broad you don't know
what type of shoes somebody's looking
for you just know they're looking for
red shoes it could be running shoes it
could be work shoes it could be you know
boots it could be
slippers okay it's too bright so long
tail keywords help narrow it in and the
more narrow and focused the keyword is
the less competition it's gonna have and
when something's not competitive in the
form of a keyword then that means your
chances of ranking for that keyword are
gonna be greater and the chance of you
ranking faster are gonna be greater and
then of course if somebody's looking for
exactly what you have to offer then you
have a higher chance to convert that
person so if you have exactly those 2019
red nike women's running shoes and
somebody does a search for that and
that's a long tail keyword and they
click on your organic listing if you
have the right price then they're
probably going to convert so you have a
really good chance of converting
somebody using long tail keywords so my
point here is if you're looking for
keywords to use focus on longer tail
don't focus on one or two keyword
phrases what it also does is it brings
targeted traffic so even if somebody
doesn't convert hey they could be back
because it's exactly what they're
looking for and if you're focusing on
longer tail keywords like i just
mentioned stay away from the shorter
ones it's just easier to optimize your
page for seo so remember seo is a two
pronged approach on-page and off-page we
talked about off-page with internal
linking and backlinks on-page is all
about making sure those keywords you
choose are integrated in with the page
you want to be found for and so if
you're using a long tail keyword
it's just easy to work that keyword in
so it enables easier on-page
optimization okay let's switch away from
seo to email marketing so
let's focus on email marketing as a form
or method of driving traffic to your
website so email marketing has been
around a long time in terms of digital
marketing why because it provides an
effective way to convert leads into
sales why because you can send
personalized emails to a target audience
so when you send an email to somebody on
a regular basis
you know who that person is so what are
you doing in the email you're writing a
specific message to that person well
email marketing is the same thing except
you're just sending an email to a larger
group of people and when you send an
email to a larger group of people you're
still going to personalize the message
right you're not going to send a generic
email to 1 000 people okay nobody's
going to do that so make sure your email
is targeted if it's targeted it can be
cost effective why because sending large
amounts of emails or let's just say an
email to a large amount of people or a
large group of people is going to be
cost effective it's not cost per click
you know it's not cost per open
okay so email usually depending on the
the email provider you're using really
is a flat fee so just really depends on
how many emails you're sending or how
how many people you're sending the email
to as well so but email generally tends
to be more cost effective than other
forms of marketing so look at the email
content provider you're using and just
get a sense of what they charge but if
you look at it and do a comparison email
generally is cheaper than say doing
pay-per-click because with pay-per-click
you're paying for each click okay so
that could be expensive depending on the
keywords so email marketing is also time
saving okay meaning it's a one-time
thing and done so once you send the
email it's just a matter of you know
watching and looking at the metrics and
learning what's going on so you don't
make the same mistakes again but it is
time conducive meaning you send out one
email and that's it with pay-per-click
you're constantly measuring and managing
the campaigns and it provides real-time
marketing so when you do send the email
more than likely a majority of the
people
on day one or the day you send the email
are gonna be able to view it open it
click on some of the links and convert
so
that's normally what happens an email
majority of the people open it on day
one and it kind of tails off from there
so think about it as real time so when
you send that email and if you have a
thousand people on your email recipient
list break it up send the first 500
first with a different subject line and
then you can see the data come in and if
you don't see the good results from the
subject line or the body of the email or
you know the page you're going to then
make adjustments before you send the
other email to the next 500. so that's a
great thing about emails you can break
up the email into two groups the first
group and then the second group with
different subject lines and you can
probably send them a little bit of time
apart that way you can learn from the
first email because with email you are
generally going to get results right
away okay within the first 24 hours so
that's a great thing about email okay so
the other thing about email it's less
intrusive so normally people who are
going to get the email
are the ones who sign up for the email
so they're almost expecting your email
so when they get your email again as
long as you're not sending an email on a
daily basis normally most companies send
it monthly or bi-weekly it's not going
to be as intrusive okay and then it also
helps build credibility increased
visibility and brand awareness meaning
you're going to build your brand in that
email you're going to put content in
that email that's going to show off your
credibility
meaning you could put some testimonials
in the email you could put some good
affiliations you can put a good article
to an industry article you just wrote so
email is going to inherently continue to
build brand awareness for you okay and
it's an easy way to track roi so if your
e-commerce it's pretty clear you send
the email somebody opens it clicks on it
checks out and purchases something it's
easily trackable because you could track
it right from that email so one thing i
want to say there is just if you do send
an email make sure you're tracking that
campaign and you want to be able to use
an analytics program like google
analytics if you use google analytics
you're going to be able to track when
you send the email who clicks on it and
who converts so you want to be able to
measure an roi for these emails and you
can and that's the beauty of email
marketing okay let's move away from
email marketing to webinars so webinars
great method for effective social media
promotion it's a great way to bring
traffic to your website so why do we
recommend webinars well because it
provides direct content contact within
your target group what do we mean by
contact with your target group well
you're going to host a webinar and
you're going to invite this targeted
group of people who are interested in
your product or service so if you have a
facebook community you could do a
facebook live event or you could do a
youtube or
you know you can even set up a webinar
on another platform but promote it on
social media and if you're pronouncing
something on social media you're
probably promoting it to people who are
already following you or like you and so
that's what we mean by direct contact
with your target group so you're going
to be able to create a webinar and talk
directly to that group and that's going
to help build brand awareness and
credibility and the great thing about
webinars is you don't need some fancy
software i mean i'm talking to you on a
webinar right now and so webinars are
free all you need is a video camera and
a recorder that's all and that's all
built in with software so there's plenty
of software out there that allows you
just to do a webinar really quick and
easy there's lots of opportunities in
software so and a lot of them are very
cost effective so if you want to build
uh create a webinar you can do that by
spending very little money and webinars
again allow you to talk to your targeted
group your community maybe prospective
clients it helps build credibility and
in effect drive traffic to your website
and when somebody does attend a webinar
they're likely going to be highly
engaged because you're inviting them
they're going to opt into the webinar
and the great thing about webinars is
even if they don't attend the webinar
the day you have it it's going to be
recorded so they can always go back and
watch it so whoever watches the webinar
is going to be engaged because it's
going to be a topic they're interested
in and then users are likely to become
prospective customers so having a
webinar talking about something
inherently interesting to maybe a larger
group of people you can promote that on
social media and potentially get
prospective customers to
sign up and watch the webinar and if you
do they're going to be engaged and then
take the next step oh i like what this
guy this person has to say they seem to
be credible i like their personality i
like their brand i like their product
i'm gonna go check their web out their
website okay so webinars allow you to
kind of pull in more people as well as
just your community because you can
promote the webinar and you can promote
it in advance and you can leverage
social media for that okay so something
related to webinars incorporating video
content so videos have been proven to be
a really good way to attract new
visitors and it just it makes your
website very engaging when you have
videos on your website as well so if you
create video you have an opportunity to
post it on various video platforms like
youtube or vimeo okay there's plenty of
video platforms out there or just
embedded in a blog post or embedded in a
facebook post or a tweet okay so you can
do a lot with video and having video on
your site is going to increase
engagement okay when you increase
engagement good things happen that's
going to lead to increased conversions
in sales or roi or just like we
mentioned the webinar can help build
trust with your audience even that
webinar you could post on your website
so you want people to engage by watching
this video they watch the video they're
going to gain trust in you because
you're talking directly to that person
that user that audience that visitor to
your website and when you get build
trust it's going to increase engagement
and that's the beauty of video unlike
text or imagery
videos really do engage with the
audience and so the more video you could
do the better off you are because again
you can leverage social to draw
attention to your brand and product and
service and then you can have that video
on your website to increase engagement
which in turn increases conversions and
sales and improves roi so always think
video there's plenty of video software
out there that you can leverage and the
great thing about video 2 is hey most
people are using mobile phones these
days smartphones and so video works just
as well on mobile as it does on desktop
so keep that in mind you know video is
going to be engaging regardless of what
device somebody uses and then of course
if they're watching the video on
facebook or youtube then chances are
they're going to
share
that particular video which is going to
bode well for your brand and traffic
okay so video if somebody likes a video
it's very easy to share video especially
from a mobile phone so youtube just
makes it so easy to share or like or
subscribe to a channel it just it
becomes that much easier things can go
viral and chances of them going viral
video are going to be greater okay so
other ways to drive traffic to your
website is submit your content to
content aggregators so what's a content
aggregator well content aggregators like
reddit that provides a great platform
for you to post your content so that's
what a content aggregator is really a
site like reddit or medium or quora
where you could post content to a large
number of people okay so with reddit
people are either going to upvote it or
downvote it so the more upvotes you get
or thumbs up or likes or people who
encourage that content the more of a
chance it has to be found and so first
thing out of the gate if you do provide
content to a content aggregator like
reddit make sure it's good quality
content that's interesting and that
should be a case the case across the
board whether it's a social post or blog
post make sure the contents unique
professional and interesting and then if
you do say put something on medium or
you do put something on quora and it is
professional and interesting and
thought-provoking then people are going
to react to it and then that again could
lead to traffic but even if it doesn't
lead to traffic it helps build brand
awareness so if you have content just
like videos leverage it put the content
out there okay and when you put content
out there it's only gonna especially if
it's good content put it's going to put
you in a good light so don't be afraid
to share your content on the likes of
reddit or medium or core or some of
these other content aggregator websites
because good things are only going to
happen and again referral traffic seo
brand awareness conversions so all these
are inherent benefits of just sharing
your content okay and then finally we
want to learn from analytics okay so
what do i mean learning from analytics
so there are plenty of analytics
platforms out there one of the most
popular is google analytics so you want
to make sure you're tracking traffic on
your site with google analytics so i
have to do is just go to google
analytics via search sign up add the
analytics code to your website and voila
they're doing all the heavy lifting
they're going to track traffic coming
your website and not only they're going
to track traffic but they're going to
tell you how that traffic engaged and so
the benefits of it google analytics is
hey you could figure out where users are
coming from are they coming from that
email campaign that i sent out to a
thousand people are they coming from
youtube based on that video i posted or
they coming from reddit based on the
content i just posted there or they
coming from organic search
so google analytics can help us
understand how much traffic we're
getting from organic search so to help
us measure our seo efforts and then with
google analytics you could segment so we
could segment by mobile we can segment
by desktop returning user new user by
campaign by page by language by city by
region i mean there's so many ways in
which to segment your audience and
segmenting simply is breaking up the
entire group of people who come to your
website into different segments based on
what you want to see so
if you want to look at you know females
between the ages of 18 to 24 who come
from mobile via organic search
that's a segment and you can look at
that information and analytics if that's
your target audience then you can see
how they're performing okay so anal
there are a lot of benefits to google
analytics definitely want to take
advantage of
segmenting in google analytics you could
look at your competition so there's a
benchmarking report the great thing
about google analytics you can also look
at content and how your content is
performing when somebody lands on your
website are they what page are they
spending time on what page are they
engaging on the most okay what pages
have the highest bounce rate or the
lowest time on page so you can really
determine what pages work best and then
of course the end result in analyzing
all this data is you want to be able to
fine-tune your website so take advantage
of the data that google analytics or any
other analytics platform is giving you
by learning once you learn what's going
on with your website you can make
adjustments to your website to improve
user experience okay so we went over a
lot of different ways to drive traffic
okay you can incorporate all this to
your website immediately welcome today
we're going to talk about email
marketing tutorial so buckle up and
let's get started with email marketing
tutorial and so let's start out asking
the question why email marketing so
linda is the owner of an e-commerce
company and basically she isn't able to
take her leads leads she's collecting
per day per month and convert them into
customers okay so customers sign up but
they don't buy her product so she's left
scratching her head wondering what to do
so how she gonna solve the problem of
converting the lead she gets into paying
customers well look no further than
email market so you can boost your sales
funnel with the help of email marketing
so email marketing leads to
email campaigns that lead to website
visits that can lead to product
purchasing email markings also and a
it's a very good way to generate a high
return on investment so
linda thinks this is too good to be true
your child i made is a very efficient
way to generate a return on my
investment how expensive is email
marketing well email marketing is
neither expensive or time consuming
that's the beauty of email marketing and
so linda is now
very interested we've piqued her
interest she wants us to explain
email marketing to her in detail and
that's exactly what we're going to do
we're going to talk about email
marketing in detail so for everyone out
there listening what's in it for you why
are you going to invest your time and
listening to
simply learn and me talk about email
marketing because we're going to talk
about everything there is about email
marketing in today's webinar so what is
it for those that aren't really familiar
with the intricacies of email marketing
we're gonna talk about how to set up
email marketing we're gonna discuss all
the benefits of email marketing we're
gonna get into a b testing we're gonna
get into the automation of emails the
types of emails how to engage new users
and we're gonna give you a demo so
there's a lot going on in this webinar
like i said buckle up and let's get
started and talk about
what is email marketing so as i
mentioned to linda it's an efficient way
to convert leads into sales why because
we can send personalized emails to a
specific audience a targeted audience if
somebody's interested in our product we
can reach out to them via email it can
also be used to remarket pre-qualified
leads so anybody who's pre-qualified we
can go ahead and communicate with them
as well so email marketing is very
effective at different stages in the
funnel okay so when i say funnel
customer life cycle so we have awareness
consideration purchase retention and
advocacy okay so let's talk about each
one of these parts of the funnel or
customer life cycle if you will so let's
start with awareness at the very top so
email marketing allows customers to
recognize their problems after which you
can educate them on how your brand can
solve them okay just like any other
marketing channel somebody's looking for
something in need of something and we
can come to the rescue in this case
we're going to come to the rescue with
email and we can go ahead and educate
them on what their need is and how we
can collaborate with them help them
educate them solve their problems with
our product okay so that's what email's
going to do we're going to communicate
with them via email and we're going to
bring awareness to the problem by
solving the problem that's what email is
good for okay good for generating
awareness for our brand for example we
can share a newsletter with our
customers so if we're running a
cosmetics company we can basically
educate them on the five important skin
care products that everyone should have
okay so we can get them to click on the
call to action to learn more so if
somebody's having some skin care issues
or not sure what products to buy you
know an email can cover that okay the
next
step in the customer life cycle is
consideration so customers focused on
searching for relevant products and
compares the products with similar ones
okay so they're definitely looking
they're a little further in the process
they're educated they know what they're
looking for so we can really hit them
with the right email we can send a
relevant email to promote our product
okay discover that perfect moisturizer
for your skin perfect skin moisturizer
smooths hydrates and contains spf 20. so
we got the perfect product for that
person who's further along the funnel
and really is ready to purchase that
product so we can hit that person up
with the perfect messaging talk about
purchase the next step in the life cycle
well purchase well with purchase we can
send an email that encourages that
customer purchase our product by
offering them something okay by giving
an offer for example we can give a
discount discounts always tend to work
so that moisturizer that that particular
customer was considering buying well
they can move from consideration to
purchasing because we're going to offer
them a discount they can't refuse okay
so you know it could beat for a specific
date okay it could be you know something
that's going to get them excited to buy
the product twenty percent off of
moisturizers pretty good deal and
especially if that percentage off is
better than the other products that
we're considering buying so getting
somebody that extra incentive to
purchase the product goes a long way via
email okay we want to take that next
step in the life cycle and nurture our
relationship with customers to ensure
they're loyal okay they've already
purchased how do we get them purchased
again that's retention we want to retain
our customers we want to get them back
to buy the same product or similar
products or completely different
products in our inventory so what do we
do we're going to send an email we're
going to send an email to active
customers okay we're gonna give them an
offer just for them exclusively just for
them in this example we're gonna give
them a combo pack a facial kit at just
39 and get a sunscreen worth ten dollars
for free so you can come up with all
sorts of different combinations on
offers key is the offer is exclusively
just for those who you want to target
and retain as customers because if you
just get somebody to purchase once it's
not going to work those people have
already taken the that step in the
relationship where they trust your
product they purchase your product now
you want to go ahead and treat that
customer special by giving them an
exclusive offer and then what we want to
do is advocacy last step in that
customer lifestyle we want to convert
that active customer into brand
advocates okay we want that customer to
talk about our brand for us we want them
to promote it and talk about it with
their friends so for example we want to
send an email to those customers to
promote our products okay so for example
we could say hey the sales of our
products for this particular day or for
this month is going to go to our
favorite non-profit could be educating
poor children or cleaning up plastic in
the ocean or saving animals we want to
be able to
get them to speak on our behalf and say
look guys this is a really good company
you know they're offering me products
exclusively they've offered me discounts
in the past they have good products they
have a lot of different products and on
top of all that they help they help the
environment they help the needy okay
they care and so we can go ahead and
provide a call to action for these
customers that are loyal to our brand
and have them share the email with their
friends to spread the word on you know
what we're trying to accomplish for our
non-profit or if anything just get them
to promote it maybe give them a discount
for every friend that they get to buy a
product okay it doesn't have to
necessarily be you know just sharing
with friends it can be that extra
incentive of giving them a discount if
they do share with friends and their
friends buy okay so this is the customer
life cycle and examples of different
emails that you can use at every step
along the way in the life cycle so let's
talk about email marketing setup so
email marketing set up we have a series
of steps that we need to go through in
order to get our email set up to go
ahead and send out to our target
audience and that first step is we want
to identify that target audience and
create segments so if you've taken some
of my and listened to some of my
webinars in the past about google
analytics about google ads we talk about
segmenting so it's about targeting a
specific audience that's what segmenting
is taking a piece of the whole so we
don't want to email all users on our
list all customers maybe we want to
target a specific segment okay so we
want to be able to identify that segment
who is that segment is it somebody who
or a group of people or
you know a partial list of our customers
who purchase a specific product i would
say so versus say our entire list of
customers because our entire list of
customers can purchase a number of
different products and so by targeting a
specific segment of our audience or our
customer base we can hone in on the
message so if they all have something in
common like they all bought that
moisturizer then we can go ahead and be
specific with our messaging then we want
to create campaigns and set an
appropriate call to action okay so what
is it that we want to say to these these
people this segment of users then once
you create that campaign and and set up
the messaging and call to action we want
to test the email before we actually
click send this is a very important step
test that email
before we send and then when we send the
campaigns immediately or we can schedule
a time so
my advice here is always schedule a time
you want to be able to figure out the
best time to send that email and then
once the email is sent whenever that is
you want to be able to analyze
performance and there are some key
metrics that you want to hone in on when
we talk about email marketing and some
of those are open rates click-through
rates okay response rate okay so we want
to be able to hone in on certain key
metrics when it comes to emails so
here's what we need to do create our
list add contacts to our list create our
campaign okay we want to select the list
choose a format
modify the template and then send the
email campaign so these are some basic
checklists that you want to do so let me
give you an example and go to mailchimp
so if i'm in mailchimp basically i'm
going to create a campaign okay
so
it's an email that i'm going to work
with and you can see with mailchimp i
have some some examples here regular
automated plain text or a b test i want
to do a regular email and i'm just going
to call it test and i'm going to click
begin
okay so we want to add our recipients
who are we going to add so we're going
to choose our audience okay
so we're just going to choose a sample
test for now okay we can personalize the
two fields if we want okay so what do we
want to do we want to call people by
their first name their last name the
first and last name where we can
customize it just go with first name to
keep it a little bit personal okay then
we have the subject line here so it's
all about messaging right so whoever
we're targeting we want to be able to
add a message so we're just going to say
and and subject line is very key here so
you want to have a subject line that's
really going to resonate with your
audience so whoever that segment
audience is we want to make sure that
the subject line is going to resonate
with them with them so that they can
open up that email okay so uh we'll just
say have any good day we can make it
better
just as an example something that's
going to be attention grabbing if you
will okay you can always tweak the
subject line in fact my advice is always
do a b testing on the subject line so
you can do two different subject lines
with one email to figure out which one
has better open rates and then with
mailchimp we can go ahead and design the
content of our email so we're going to
click design email okay we can select a
template we have some save templates
already okay or we can go with a theme
so mailchimp has a lot of good offers
now there's a lot of different email
platforms out there i particularly like
mailchimp because
of this very feature they have a lot of
good themes here um a lot of different
layouts that you can use okay so you
know we're going to showcase that
product
okay and that's the template we're going
to use here so here we go we're going to
showcase our product we're going to add
that photo of our product here and we're
going to go ahead and put some nice
messaging in here with some nice call to
action we can put our logo up here for
branding again we can edit the content
here so based on that segmented list in
this example
for linda's company maybe she wants to
target those folks who bought her
moisturizer before her face moisturizer
and she wants to retarget them she wants
to go ahead and say hey you guys have
bought my product before check out this
new face moisturizer that we have to
offer so whatever the case is you want
to be able to plan that out ahead of
time you want to be able to plan out who
your audience is you want to plan out
your messaging and you want to go ahead
and set up the messaging based on that
audience so once you have the messaging
in place voila you're more or less ready
to go okay so
once you get the content all set up
you can schedule that campaign
okay and you can also add a social post
to your campaign so we can share that
information on social so email
integrates nicely with social media
so again that's that's pretty much what
you need to do here you need to really
think about who it is you want to target
choose those recipients
okay
customize it
and make it personal create a good
subject line in fact create two subject
lines and then align that content with
that audience okay that's that's really
the checklist here so again we look at
this checklist creating our list who do
we want to send the email to so we added
our contacts to the list we set up the
campaign we selected the list we chose
the format we modified it with a good
subject line with some good messaging
and then we're going to schedule that
email campaign so that's the checklist
to go off okay so remember identify
target audience and create segments and
you create that campaign and in our case
we did set an appropriate call to action
you know get shopping basically we want
people to shop our new moisturizer key
thing here is before we send it out we
want to test that email once everything
looks good we're going to i would advise
schedule it but you can always send the
email when you're ready i would schedule
it at the appropriate time and day okay
so in this case you don't want to send
an email out on a friday afternoon okay
when people are getting ready for the
weekend you certainly don't want to send
an email out over the weekend because
you're not going to have many people
look and open it and you probably don't
want to send the email out on a monday
morning when most people are getting
into the office from a long weekend and
catching up on emails so from my
experience you know tuesday wednesday
depending on your time zone i would
always say you know late morning early
afternoon tends to be a good time but
that's why we have performance that's
why we can analyze performance we want
to be able to see what the open rates
are and the click-through rates are so
that we can make adjustments for future
emails so let's talk about some of those
metrics so when you do send that email
you know we're going to look at that
open so open rate is the percentage of
the total number of recipients who open
an email so okay so if we basically you
know sent it to x amount of people
minus those emails that have bounced so
let's just say you know we sent it to a
hundred and two people okay for
simplicity's sake two of those emails
bounced okay so that means that we've
had a 100 net 100 emails that receive
the email and let's just say 75 open the
email okay we wrote such a good subject
line that they opened it okay that's 75
that's a 75 open rate that's how you
measure open rate click through rate
okay so if they open it we hope that
they click on something and so
for all of those emails that were
delivered okay in this case a hundred
how many actually did click on our call
to action so let's just say
75 opened it out of the 100 that's a 75
open rate but of the hundred that
actually were delivered let's just say
we had 25 that actually clicked on the
call to action and so that's 25
okay and so you want to be able to
measure not only who opens it but who
clicks on the call to action so that's
click-through rate for email marketing
and then response rate so it's the
percentage of the total recipients who
clicked on a link of your email campaign
and actually completed the action so in
our example we're trying to get people
to click on the shopping call to action
and get them to purchase so we sent 100
emails and of the 25 who actually
clicked we had 10 who actually took
action and purchase so 10 divided by 100
is 10
so you have open rate click-through rate
and response rate those are some key
metrics for email marketing okay the
first step is you got to get people to
open it that's where the subject line is
so important click-through rate that's
where the messaging and call to action
is so important we want to get people to
click on that call to action and then
the response rate we want them to buy so
those are our three key metrics related
to email marketing so let's take a look
at an example if we go back to our email
marketing platform mailchimp in this
example we're going to take a look at
some reports so most email marketing
platforms have reporting functionality
built in and so in this case what we
want to do is we want to be able to take
a look at the open rate click-through
rates of the emails that have been sent
out previously so here we could see our
april email coupon versus tools promo
okay so we've had basically you know
opens and clicks so 14 open rate 1.4
click-through rate okay so the march
email that went out did a little bit
better 19 open two and a half percent on
the click-through rate so here we could
see how many people actually were sent
how many open it and how many clicks so
this is a mailchimp makes it very easy
for us to measure you know open and
click rates and then we can measure by
revenue as well based on the campaign so
that's
measuring the response rate so it's all
built in so most email marketing
platforms have open rate and click rate
already built into the functionality so
you can measure those two metrics
against any email so let's talk about
the benefits of email marketing so what
are some of the benefits well we've
already mentioned to linda that it's
cost effective it's time saving real
time marketing less intrusive builds
credibility increases visibility and
brand awareness and it's an easy way to
track roi these are all the benefits for
email marketing we're gonna go talk
about some of these now so basically
when we talk about cost effective you
know some email marketing platforms
charge based on the number of users who
you send the email to time saving well
you saw how quick it took me to set up
that email campaign the key is figuring
out who you want to send it to when we
talk about real-time marketing you know
we're sending this email out basically
in real time trying to meet our
customers needs at the right time it's
less intrusive because we can customize
the emails okay we can as you saw i can
put first name in there to make it more
personal so when something's more
personal it's less intrusive especially
if it's a segment that already knows
your brand okay builds credibility hey
we gain credibility when we offer
exclusive offers to repeat customers or
you know try and build advocacy by
working with non-profits okay it
increases visibility and brand awareness
why because you know we could send our
email out to a large group of people and
that's a good way to generate brand
awareness and as you saw we can easily
measure you know not only open rates
click rates but roi so how many people
from that email went on and purchased so
we can measure that it's very easy to
measure email so let's move into a b
testing so a b testing is key to email
marketing okay so in email marketing
gaining high open rates and
click-through rates will result in more
website visitors and sales okay in
theory that's what's supposed to happen
we get more opens we get more people to
click we get more people to click we're
going to get more people to purchase
okay but it's not as easy as it sounds
so how do we make that possible well
we're going to do that via a b testing
i've already mentioned it when i set up
my example campaign in mailchimp i
stressed and stressed and stressed that
we need to have two subject lines go out
per email okay so before i stress that
again let me just reiterate what a b
testing is and a b testing is a method
to analyze which of the two email
campaign strategies most effective in
terms of high open rates and click rates
okay so in this case an a b testing you
can send out two emails you can send out
two subject lines you can send out two
call to actions you're just really what
you're doing is you're testing one
against the other that's what a b
testing is and so in my example i talked
about that subject line so for better
results a b testing can be done with the
subject line can also be done with the
email content so the subject line
impacts the open rate okay so i wrote a
subject line i don't even know how that
subject line is going to perform but if
i write a second subject line then i'll
be able to
basically give myself a better chance of
getting a better open rate because i'm
offering up two different subject lines
likewise for email content so the
subject line and email content are the
most important elements so we want to be
able to test them if they're interesting
intriguing
attention grabbing then it's gonna in
the case of subject lines a result in
open rates if the content itself is
interesting engaging a good offer good
call to action then the click rates are
going to be increased so we want to be
able to serve up variations for our
audience so we want to consider an
example of an a b test where linda has
set up two variations of the email
campaign as an example so she's gonna
send two different subject lines to test
which one generates more open rates
because that's what subject line a b
testing is going to do one of them is
going to have a higher open rate okay so
in our example here linda sends version
a of the email to 50 of the
recipients with the subject line three
important strategies to increase your
open rate well version b which is sent
to the other 50
has the subject line three important
strategies to increase your open rate so
the only difference here is three and
three the number three spelled out well
because she sent out two different
subject lines she's going to now be able
to measure the success of that a b test
okay and it just so happens version a
has a higher open rate numbers always
tend to work in subject lines by the way
so linda sends version a of the email to
of the recipients okay dollars today but
ninety dollars tomorrow and version b to
the remaining fifty percent eighty
dollars today ninety dollars tomorrow
and the only really succinct difference
here is using the word but versus a
comma and she sent that email out and
that email went out and the date is
coming in and she's going to measure the
success of that a b test well version b
has the higher open rate you know we
want to be short
succinct and stay away from those
conjugations like but okay it tends to
have a negative connotation so the
shorter more direct email our subject
line 80 today 90 tomorrow not so passive
more direct and that tend to have the
higher open rate so you always want to
test those subject lines to generate
high open rates another example here
version a again gets 50 with the subject
line uh-oh your prescription is expiring
version b
your prescription is expiring you folks
listen to this webinar right now i
wonder which one you think will perform
go ahead and put your comments right
below this video i'm curious what
version of the subject line you would
open so let's go ahead and measure the
success of the a b test okay so she sent
the email out two different subject
lines fifty percent got one subject line
the other fifty percent got the other
subject line and it just so happens
version a uh oh your prescription is
expiring there's a little bit of a
you know personalization to that you
know for me your prescription is
expiring seems to be a little bit more
you know command-ish hey your
prescription's expiring so we expect you
to purchase where you have a little
uh-oh in front it's like hey you know i
think your prescription is expiring
maybe you should think about renewing it
okay i think that's how that's
interpreted at least that's how i
interpret it so i would probably go
ahead and click on that email with that
subject line so you could see subtle
differences in the subject lines make a
big difference in open rates so in order
to keep improving those open rates you
need to continue and not continue should
always do subject line testing always
because one subject line is always going
to have a better open write than the
other so always do a b testing when it
comes to subject lines and email content
for that matter okay so
we're always going to do continuous a b
testing so with continuous a b testing
we can test very various elements of the
email so you can always test the
sender's name the subject line the copy
the call to action the design the
imagery there's a lot of different
elements you can test with emails for
example sender's name okay so you wanna
personalize it as much as you can okay
you don't want to do a no reply you want
it to come from a human being in this
case sam okay at least that's what i
think let's see what the test states no
surprise version a has the higher open
rate if you customize these things and
personalize them then it goes a long way
sending an email from a no reply is not
a good
best practice let's talk about
the subject line again uh so we got
webinar increase your email open rates
so the webinar is dynamic on version a
okay so we're sending that out and
because it's dynamic that's going to you
know beat out the static webinar
increase your email open rates a lot
more elements we can test here so for
example the email copy so learn some
easy ways to increase your email open
rates join us on may 10 2019 7 p.m for
an interactive discussion with our
experts well version b is more
personalized it's a same message but
we're actually addressing someone
specific in this case rachel so we can
measure the success of the a b test but
it's no surprise that anything that's
customized that comes from somebody a
name you know with a dynamic email
subject line is going to perform better
it's going to increase open rates and
it's going to increase click rates so we
can also
test that call to action the difference
here is coloring save my seat yellow
versus save my c blue again go ahead and
play along here if you're watching this
go ahead and add a comment and just see
if you're right you think it's blue or
you think it's yellow on the call to
action color does go a long way in email
marketing so let's measure the success
of this a b test and it just so happens
yellow is going to perform better why
does yellow perform better than blue
what's more positive plus it it kind of
resonates a little bit stronger and
easier okay it stands out a little bit
better it's not as pastely and dull as
this shade of blue we're using so you
can see here we're testing every bit of
the elements of the email anything from
the from to the subject line to the
message to the call to action and so at
the end of the day you know you want to
be able to
send out the best email that's going to
give you the best results so we're going
to send that out the entirety of the
email and we could see version a looks a
lot better and why does version a look a
lot better in this example because look
at the font size is a little bit bigger
version b font size smaller harder to
read that's another thing you can test
larger fonts tend to do a little bit
better now you don't want to go
overboard and have them you know 48
points or 50 points and plus you know 14
versus 12 goes a long way we can
continue testing we can test imagery you
can see here we have a hand aligned with
the call to action they just look
different that's all version a has one
type of hand version b has the other
type of hand aligned with the call to
action let's go ahead and send out that
test and see what works well version b
works why the hand stands out a little
bit more clear it doesn't blend in with
the call to action so you can see we're
testing different elements here and
we're always improving and adding to
what's working so we started out with
a no reply versus somebody's name then
we move to a subject line then we move
to personalization then we move to
you know call to action then we move to
an increased font meaning the design and
then we're adding imagery so we're
constantly improving the email with each
test eventually you're going to get to a
point where you know the email is going
to be good and you're going to just
continue to test different options on it
to continue to increase open rates click
rates and response rates final output
looks like this again that personalized
email response from sam versus no reply
you know we got a nice dynamic subject
line gotta personalize the email to
rachel with larger font okay we got a
nice call to action that stands out with
a nice image to accompany that so we've
tested all these different elements this
is the best combination based on
everything we tested so when we get that
email to go this is what it's going to
look like in the future but guess what
we're not going to stop testing so we
can continue to test those subject lines
continue to test the messaging and
continue to test the email design
continue to test different call to
actions continue to test different
images you're never going to stop
testing with email marketing okay so
let's switch over to how to optimize the
subject line subject line is such a key
component to email marketing so as we
showed you in the last segment we tested
a subject line and we used a number the
number three versus three spelled out
just so happens that numbers tend to do
a little bit better they're shorter
easier to read and they resonate better
so including number in your subject line
you can include an emoji in your subject
line your emails come a long way emojis
aren't just social media based you can
use emojis in subject lines i'd highly
recommend it you know i just sat on an
email last month with the subject line
about you know spring showers bring may
flowers and guess what emoji i had in
that subject line a flower okay may
sound cheesy but it goes a long way so
according to experian subject lines with
emojis can increase open rates by 45
people resonate with emojis especially
if they're positive emojis okay so we
want to personalize those subject lines
for better open rate okay when i say
personalize don't be so stale remember
that subject line we tested uh oh just
putting o in there made it sound like we
actually cared it was a little bit
personal it wasn't so personal you
weren't dressed in a specific person but
one little word goes a long way in a
subject line because when people get
emails and they read emails and a lot of
people are inundated with emails the
subject line is what they're reading
first and just by personalizing it
adding a number
adding an emoji just making it positive
and easy to read they're likely to open
an email so personalized email messages
can improve click through rate and open
rates as well so you want to personalize
your email as much as you can whether
that be from the from field to putting
that person's name in the salutation so
personalized subject lines have been
found to increase open rates by up to 50
percent so don't come across as spammy
come across as you know who your
audience is and you're talking to them
and then you want to prefer title case
subject lines so title case subject
lines for example when i say title case
game of thrones is my favorite show
every initial letter in that title is
capitalized okay you can go with the
sentence case game of thrones is my
favorite show it doesn't stand out as
much of course if you go with lowercase
it definitely doesn't stand out it looks
illiterate and somebody's probably not
going to open it so you always go with
that title case the every initial letter
gets capitalized so how to optimize that
subject line well watch the length of
your subject line you want to be
conscious of character counts so 17 to
24 characters you want to keep it short
succinct and to the point but
personalized with an emoji with initial
caps on each word to make it stand out
but you have to do that within
17 and 24 characters so according to
campaign monitor the ideal length of a
subject line is up to 24 characters and
they're more likely to boost those email
rates okay so keep it short make it
impactful make it personalized like i
mentioned before if you get too long
then it may get cut off and it may not
have the same impact as something
shorter so that's why we always
recommend keeping it up to about 24
characters okay if you go over by a
couple characters not the end of the
world but try and stay within that range
develop a sense of urgency okay so when
we say sense of urgency we mean sense of
urgency meaning if that coupon is going
to expire you know you wanna let people
know it's gonna expire that day or the
next day or within a few days okay so
you can use things like hurry up or
limit offer or limited stock or offer
expires on okay so add a bit of sense of
urgency i mean sky's not falling here
but if that coupon's expiring at the end
of the week you probably want to mention
something to the effect of hey offer is
expiring or hurry up so let's talk about
optimizing your email content so we
focused a lot on subject lines let's
talk about the email content itself so
some ways to optimize email content are
we want to send the content that is
relevant to customer expectations so
content needs to match that expectation
we want to use bullet points to make the
content readable we want to follow
logical structure we want to use
compelling imagery and fur design emails
with responsive designs and what we mean
by responsive design is hey most people
are going to be checking that email on
their mobile phone okay so make sure
when you design the email it's also
going to be good not just on desktop but
on tablet and mobile as well and then of
course just goes without saying but
avoid grammatical mistakes go ahead and
spell checked it and that's why we put
an emphasis on testing your email before
you actually send it and when you
actually send an email test email don't
send it to yourself send it to
colleagues you know send it to another
group a fresh set of eyes a fresh set of
eyes like it's going to be able to pick
out that misspelled word that you
overlooked so i can't stress the sending
of the test email because it's going to
be able to
you know in a way ensure that you're
doing everything on this list in
addition to grammatical mistakes you
know the person who's receiving your
test email your colleague at work may be
looking at that email on their mobile
phone and if it doesn't look good to
them they're gonna let you know some
other ways to optimize email content
personalization so we did that on the a
b testing you always want to personalize
it question is hey do i use first name
do i use first and last name well guess
what you can test that but you want to
personalize it okay you want to choose
the right fonts and colors for your
email so
when we were going through some examples
on testing you know i always tend to go
a little bit larger on the font but you
can play around with it i don't think
you should probably use white lettering
on a black background that just is not
very good or best practice but go ahead
and try it if you want okay you can
always play around and test these but
you want to choose something that's
really going to resonate with the
recipient of the email okay you want to
build a rapport with customers by
sharing insights they value for example
the beginning of this webinar we talked
about advocacy we talked about you know
sharing with them some of the
non-profits that we work with as a
company okay if we have a you know
cosmetics company and we have different
products like moisturizers and facial
creams we may want to state that hey we
don't use any animals in the testing of
these products you know we're pro animal
we're not you know we're not going to
use animals in the testing of our
products
and that probably resonates with a lot
of your customers so you want to go
ahead and build a rapport with those
customers by sharing those insights okay
and use recipient names and you always
want to personalize it then add a clear
call to action at the end you always
want to have that call to action
regardless of what the email is hey it
could be just a simple read more or hey
donate it doesn't have to always be so
hardcore in terms of hey purchase our
product that could be a turn off
especially if you're sending emails out
once a week to your customer base
they're constantly hammering them with
buy now buy now by now they're going to
get turned off so you want to mix up the
call to actions and that goes back to
the very first step and what kind of
email are you going to send out who
you're going to send it to so you have
to align those two but somebody who
doesn't even know who your brand is
you're not going to put a call to action
of buy now you're probably going to say
hey check us out we have some cool stuff
for you okay let's talk about automating
emails email automation so triggered
emails are sent to customers based on an
event date or user behavior okay so when
we say an event could be a special
occasion like mother's day okay could be
a date like a birthday or anniversary or
a specific day of the week could also be
based on user behavior you know a good
example of user behavior are those who
abandon the car you can trigger an email
in fact mailchimp has remarketing
functionality so with mailchimp hey if
somebody abandons our car we can have an
email triggered and we can send an email
a nice email that says hey we noticed
you didn't finish purchasing our product
and i'm not sure what happened but hey
here's another 10 off or you can always
just make product recommendations as
well but you want to react to user
behavior and use emails to your
advantage for that so you want to take
be cognizant of different occasions you
want to be cognizant of special events
holidays etc and user behavior so these
types of emails can be automated because
you know when they might happen or that
they are probably going to happen so
autoresponder emails are sent at
frequent intervals based on the behavior
of subscribers so for example if
somebody purchases something then you're
going to get an email that probably says
hey thank you for your purchase another
email that says hey your products on its
way and then another email that says hey
your package your product has been
delivered so that's an example of an
automated email that goes out if
somebody purchases your product you
probably want to thank them for that
then you probably want to let them know
that hey it's on its way here you could
track it and then again you want to
confirm that it's been delivered but
thank them again so that's an example of
an automated email that goes out okay
let's talk about types of email
campaigns so we have different types of
email campaigns and the first is a
newsletter so with email newsletters
subscribers are connected and informed
about product updates so it doesn't
necessarily have to be a product they
buy it could be a product they subscribe
to like software okay you always want to
be able to send out that newsletter to
let them know what's going on with your
product are there upcoming product
updates ahead is there one that just
happened is there a webinar that
discusses the new product update so
that's what the newsletter is going to
do inform the end user about the update
so how to optimize okay so you stack
your email content create a compelling
header share different variety of useful
content like videos articles etc with
those recipients and then follow a
consistent schedule so that's how you
handle a newsletter you should always
create a compelling header but if you're
going to send a newsletter make sure you
support it with some good information
like a video that they can go watch or
an article that will follow up on what
you put in the email or promoting that
webinar that's going to talk about that
product update so example here is a
newsletter that gets sent out and here
you can see
it talks about business process it's got
some nice imagery in there okay call to
action it's got a little bit of
everything in this email template okay
and that's when we talk about stack your
email content that's what you talk about
stacking you can see at the top it's got
work with the industry best subscribe
now okay they validate that with 25
years of top notch service then they
talk about hiring the best talent and
you got the next bit of content below
that so that's stacked email content
okay that's going to be supported by
compelling header and then they're going
to share a variety of different content
in there like there could be clicks in
there to video videos and articles
moving on from newsletters to
promotional emails so we want to be able
to drive revenue by sending special
offers through promotional email okay so
how do we optimize a promotional email
well we want to personalize the campaign
okay promotional we want to definitely
personalize it include time sensitive
offers we want to get people to react
okay so that means you know adding a
sense of urgency in the title and the
subject line okay you can send offer
emails on holidays if it's mother's day
hey send it a couple days before or even
send it on if it's personalized then you
can say hey
so and so we know you're a mother here
take 20 off i mean that kind of
personalized email with an offer goes a
long way here you an example from toms
limited time extra 20 off all styles
they include the code in there okay
again you can see the the sensitivity
and the sense of urgency with the
limited time another email campaign type
and personally one of my favorites is
abandoned cart so a banning card emails
i like working with abandoned card
emails because you know we want people
to purchase and as much as you try on
your email marketing campaign to drive
traffic to the website and as hard as
the website works to get people to
convert through the shopping cart it's
never gonna be a hundred percent and so
abandon cart emails give us that extra
incentive to get that person back to the
shopping cart to purchase okay so these
emails are shared with customers who
have added product to their cart but
didn't finish through the checkout
process in other words they didn't
purchase the product so it's an
effective way of sales recovery it gives
us another opportunity to reach out to
that person who just is almost there but
not quite ready to finish the purchase
so what are we going to do we're going
to send out an email for those that
abandon their car and we're going to use
a simple abandoned cart email template
okay you want to be simple here you
don't want to get complicated we're
trying to make this easy for them to
finish purchasing the products and we
want to definitely personalize it okay
we want to send a series of email
reminders okay in your email reminder
add a product image so as customized as
it can be it could be even the product
image of what they've abandoned and
that's the best practice so if it's that
facial moisturizer that linda's trying
to promote and she can't quite get
enough people to finish purchasing the
product they're they're banning the cart
well she can certainly send out the
abandoned cart email okay so for example
you want to personalize it hey you
forgot to complete your order you left
something in your car can we help
email too hi there so and so items in
your shopping cart are selling out
quickly it's a gentle reminder okay so
come across a little bit different here
okay email three hey so-and-so twenty
percent off on your car valid until so
and so offer on your favorite product so
the first email that went out and the
series of emails hey you forgot
something hey is there anything we can
do to help you complete the product
purchase email too is just that gentle
reminder hey you're selling out quickly
you might want to purchase that product
and the email three is to really help
them along by saying hey here's twenty
percent off valid until so and so so
just a small series of emails that go
out try and get somebody back into the
shopping cart okay let's talk about
re-engagement campaign so in a
re-engagement campaign it's a series of
emails sent to inactive email
subscribers so what it does is it boosts
engagement and helps to maintain a high
inbox placement ratio
inbox placement ratio so we want to be
able to make sure that we're getting
people back on our subscriber list so
how are we going to optimize for
something like this this is now these
are difficult type of email campaigns
we're trying to re-engage with people
who are inactive so we want gamification
to re-engage subscribers or we want to
prefer subject lines like hey we've been
missing you or did we do something wrong
okay we can run a poll or competition to
re-engage with our subscribers so for
example hey we'd hate to miss your
birthday go ahead and update your
account this is a starbucks email so
we'd hate to miss your birthday so it's
that you know message of missing you you
can always soften or sweeten the deal
with an offer as well so that brings us
to how to engage with new subscribers so
we just talked about re-engaging with
inactive we want to talk about engaging
with new subscribers so how to engage
with new subscribers well thank your
subscribers for joining okay create
clear and compelling subject lines that
is a must regardless of what type of
email you send out you always want to
send out that compelling subject line
okay we noticed the good examples within
17 to 24 characters know the ideal time
to message okay again sending it on the
weekends not gonna work okay sending it
out during the weekday
you know in the morning mid-morning you
know sometimes in the afternoon works
really depends on who your audience is
but weekends probably aren't going to
work they avoid the no reply center name
again
personalize it you're either sam or rob
or so and so sally you know let them
know that the email's coming from a real
person okay because if it doesn't come
from a person most people aren't going
to respond okay we want to let our
subscribers know the privacy policy so
we want to let them know that we abide
by a privacy policy okay that's you know
getting you know straight with people
who are new they don't know your brand
they don't know your privacy policy they
don't want to get spammed in other words
so putting that out there makes you more
transparent and trustworthy okay and
again
personalization always personalize if
it's new if it's inactive repeat
customers loyal customers lifetime
customers you should always personalize
and you should always be courteous and
always thank them and then prefer
attractive email designs okay work with
something that's going to be eye catchy
and then most important most important
is include an unsubscribe link i can't
tell you how annoying it is to get an
email and not have the unsubscribe link
there that makes me want to
unsubscribe even if it was a good email
i still look for that because maybe
they're good company but they're
spamming me they're sending me too many
emails so maybe i want to unsubscribe or
change my subscription so you always
want to include that unsubscribe link in
fact in the united states it's actually
law so
there is regulation about that around
that so you need to include an
unsubscribe link it's just common
courtesy if anything so it bodes well
okay of course you don't want people to
unsubscribe but you don't want them to
get annoyed either okay let's talk about
email marketing tools so we talked about
mailchimp so there are plenty of email
marketing platforms out there i use
mailchimp i've used a few in the past
like marketo i've used zoho vertical
response so there are a lot of different
tools out there here some of them again
mailchimp marketo marketo is a marketing
automation tool or system and marketo is
good for sending those automated emails
hubspot
kit send in blue aweber i mean these are
just some of the many that are out there
okay so let's show a demo again of an
email marketing campaign so let's show
an example of a newsletter that one of
my clients had sent out and so this is
paul ekman group paul ekman dr ekman
inspired the tv show lied to me so
well-known in the industry of micro
expressions he's the aforementioned
expert in micro expressions and he sends
out email marketing campaigns and he
sends out a monthly newsletter so this
is a a newsletter was sent out in
november 2018 and if we look at it you
can see here okay it's stacked content
nice imagery okay respectful
disagreements how to deal with
disagreements this holiday season so
really relevant personalized because and
timely because it was set in november
during the holiday season so got some
nice imagery there okay we got content
in here and then right below that on the
stack content what do we have final hour
24 hours 25
off so that sense of urgency built in to
the email then here you go you have some
other content in there based on the face
of contempt okay just an example of a
micro expression and then right below
that what do we see we see a call to
action learn how to use microexpressions
to your advantage so call to action here
then we have some more information here
with the learn more so a newsletter that
went out basically really a blog post
built into the email with some nice
content reminding folks hey they have 24
hours got some other useful information
in the email so this email went out very
timely 98 000 okay see subject line here
controversy respectful disagreements and
thanksgiving okay could the subject line
be a little bit shorter yes possibly but
if we look at the open rate 15
16 open rate okay industry average in
education and training is 18 okay so
they're close to the industry average on
the click rate you know 1.6 percent on
the click rate industry average 2.1 so
we can see what the top links were
clicked okay so they have a lot of links
and and mailchimp will help you measure
what links were clicked the most who
subscribed what subscriber with the most
opens we can see opens by country but
that's an example of a newsletter for
this particular company okay stacked
content okay sense of urgency okay you
can see the subject line timely
newsletter so this is a
a good i think a good example of an
email for the time of year okay so let's
go over the checklist again for email
marketing so good reminders on the
checklist this is a checklist you want
to make sure all boxes are checked you
want to create interesting subject lines
as they boost your open rates direct
correlation with open rates is subject
line okay you want to keep your content
relevant and consistent with your brand
you want to check the sender name okay
so you want to make sure not only is it
personalized but the name aligns with
the email address okay you should always
personalize always personalize the
subject line and the email copy text
meaning you know don't just say hello
say hello to sally pete rob
michael et cetera always include an
unsubscribe link in emails okay give
people the option to unsubscribe okay
you can always re-engage them another
way or later on but you don't want to
irk any one of your potential customers
use a b testing we talked about a b
testing the webinar there's lots of
different elements we can test from
subject line to content to font to call
to action to imagery to subject line etc
there's no shortage of elements in an
email you can test you want to use
welcome emails to build good customer
relationships so when somebody signs up
for a newsletter send out a welcome news
email to them hey welcome thank you for
signing up you should always segment
your list based on user behavior so you
have a group of people who purchase
product a customize your email for
product a but you know you can mention
product b and c in there but know who
your audience is so you can talk to your
audience and you can always ask your
subscribers to update their preferences
as well because you want to make sure
you're sending out emails to the right
person right address okay this is a
short checklist now we can expand upon
this but these are some of the most of
the key items when it comes to email
marketing some other items on the
checklist include features such as
countdown timers and live polls okay
make it interactive okay choose the
right email frequency don't be sending
emails three or four times a week once a
week is probably as much as you want to
go depending on what it is if somebody
purchases something then you probably
want to send an email thanking them for
the purchase another one letting another
product has been shipped and another one
with thank you the product has been
received reward those subscribers send
out exclusive offers okay make sure your
emails are optimized for mobile that
means send out test emails and check it
on different devices
create a schedule okay you can automate
these emails so create a schedule that
makes the most sense have a footer and a
header in the email and in that footer
and header is going to be some
information okay just like i showed you
with the micro expressions there was a
footer and header avoid spam filters
okay how do you avoid spam filters well
apply best practices and don't have
spammy subject lines have an actual name
associated with the reply to email and
and split up your list as well when you
send out one email to 150 000 people it
could probably get caught up in some
spam so segment out your audiences keep
your audience list short so that your
messaging can be
specific to the audience that's going to
help avoid spam and then of course you
always want to measure and analyze
results so remember a lot of these email
marketing platforms have the results
built in especially open rates
and today we're going to talk about
mailchimp so we're going to go through
the features and benefits of using
mailchimp as your email content platform
so buckle up and let's get started with
mailchimp so the first thing you need to
do is sign up for an account with
mailchimp and that's simply just
providing an email address an id and a
password and i recommend when you
actually sign up for an account you sign
up with the free plan first and let's
take a look at what the future plan
features are for mailchimp so i'm
recommending the free plan but when you
actually sign up you have the option to
actually pay for a plan so you have the
essential the standard the premium or
the free and so i recommend you go with
the free version first it's like buying
a car you want to test drive it out see
if you like it see if you like the
features and benefits and you can see
here that with the free plan you get a
lot of features and benefits so you get
all the basics for businesses that are
just getting started so if you're just
getting started with email marketing i
would recommend the free plan here
because you have a 2000 contact maximum
so that means you can send out an email
to your 2 000 recipients free of charge
so not a bad deal for businesses who are
starting out i mean if you are prepared
you've used mailchimp before then go
ahead and sign up for one of the paid
versions each version has a different
set of standards a different set of
features and benefits from the essential
all the way up to the premium where
you're gonna get you know advanced
features um and more customization but
that's 299 dollars a month so if you're
not prepared to pay that amount then my
recommendation start with that free plan
now when you actually do set up your
account you're just gonna again provide
a
id
email address and password you're going
to go through a couple of steps and one
of these steps that i would recommend
you do right away is connect your
facebook and twitter accounts so if you
already have a facebook and twitter
account very simple all you're doing is
authorizing mailchimp to connect to the
account and the reason for that is when
you actually connect your twitter
facebook account you'll be able to then
you know share content on those
platforms and mailchimp will do that for
you automatically okay so here you're
just asking it to
more or less interact with the platform
social platform and i recommend doing
that as you're going through the setup
process very simple to do if you're
already logged into your twitter
facebook account all you need to do is
click on the plus button as you go
through the setup wizard and authorize
mailchimp to access your twitter or
facebook account here you can see what
mailchimp's going to be able to do
they're going to be able to retweets
from your timeline post tweets for you
on your behalf if you want them to if
you want them to you're gonna allow
mailchimp to secret and manage your
advertising data including the campaigns
and audiences and the reason for this is
you may you know want to integrate your
email marketing efforts with your social
media efforts and the great thing about
mailchimp is hey look if you want to
post content on these platforms you'll
be able to if you want to leverage other
benefits from facebook and twitter and
integrate them with mailchimp you'll be
able to so having these two platforms in
the case of facebook and twitter talk to
mailchimp is a positive because then
you'll be able to do a little bit more
get your message out there a little bit
more so i highly recommend you take this
as a necessary step when you're going
through the setup now it's optional you
don't have to but i recommend it now
when you're actually setting up your
account you're going to be asked to
you know design a template okay so you
could pick a template just by default
you could pick one just to get the
account going but you can always go back
and add or change out the template so
here you can see i'm in the setup wizard
but i arbitrarily just chose a template
i can go back and choose some of the
templates that are available to me now
again you can create your own template
if you want to okay so you just click
create template and
you'll be you know asked to choose kind
of a you know template that you can
pretty much change and customize so if
you're thinking about sending out an
email with an announcement then that's
the type of template you want to choose
and so here now you can see we have a
logo we can change the announcement here
we can add photos etc so if i want to
add my logo i'm just going to go up to
this top portion here click the little
pencil icon that allows me to edit here
you can see it's the default logo i
don't really have a logo so i can say
replace it i can also link to it and
here you can see in the content studio
of mailchimp i don't have any images to
choose from so i'm going to go ahead and
upload one and i'm gonna go ahead and
upload my logo that i've had on my
desktop okay so it's gonna upload and
now i can select that and insert it so
now i have my logo as part of my
template here and you can also see you
can add some styling here
to this hot header part so i can add a
nice border around that okay so i can
align its center i can go edge to edge
okay so i can customize the image in
this particular template here so i'm
just going to click save and close now
i'm ready to move on to the next part
which is just click on edit i want to
make an announcement okay share your big
news okay we're
having a launch party okay so here you
can see again just in this template this
quote unquote announcement template i'm
able to just make changes to each
section now i'm in the section of the
announcement part where i can now
customize the text and you can see i can
you know bold it you know i can choose a
different font go ariel i can choose the
size you can make it smaller larger
pretty easy to use i could again style
it with different color and so i can
make multiple columns here
if i want to so there's a lot you can do
just in this one section as well so
let's go ahead and just do one more
thing here that's maybe color or
something i mean you can see i can add a
link let's go ahead and make it blue
that's the background so i want to
change the background so i'm just going
to click control z
i'll change the color of the font itself
there you go very simple and easy to use
now i can add photos here if i want to
so let's go ahead and edit this bottom
part here so i'm going to click again
the edit icon okay so here you can see i
have three images in the template i'm
going to go ahead and add to that so
here i can go ahead and upload some
files so i have some files waiting for
me on my desktop i'm just going to go
ahead and add them and upload them to
the content studio and
now that i've uploaded them i can select
one of them to insert okay now i'm going
to go here insert the second one and now
i'm going to grab the third one and
insert that in its place here you can
see now i can go ahead and you know
style each one of these if i want to
okay i can add a border again okay i can
go ahead and do rounded corners okay
settings you can see how i can set it up
this so they're all vertical i can do
this so i have a lot of flexibility
and
what i add to these particular you know
templates okay this is again just the
announcement template and so now i'm
going to click save and close
and
here you can see i can add some other
things to it if i wanted to i can play
around with the design and header and
once i'm done really if i'm happy with
my email i can just close it out and i'm
done so what i could do now is when
you're done with this template you can
just preview and test it so i could send
a test email or enter preview mode so if
i enter preview mode this is what the
template i chose is going to look like
if i happen to send it out okay this is
what it looks like on desktop this is
what it looks like a mobile and if i go
inbox preview i'll need to upgrade my
account because i'm on the free version
so but i can certainly see what it looks
like on mobile on desktop so i'm just
going to click out of that
and this is a template and so i can go
back and edit this anytime i want so
when i'm done i'm just going to go ahead
and click the mailchimp icon in the
upper left it's going to ask me to name
my template so i'm going to name this
the announcement template i'm going to
click save and now it's in my templates
so i'm free to use this template anytime
i'm ready to send an email okay and
again i can you saw how easy it was to
make a change in the template itself so
when i'm ready to use the template i can
just go ahead and grab it okay and again
i can go ahead and style it and design
it any way i want so you have different
sections of the page that you can style
and here you got you know mobile style
designs if you wanted to now if you
wanted to in the template if i want to
like duplicate the whole block i can
duplicate that whole block and you can
see it just copied it or i can just get
rid of it it's a very easy to use
wysiwyg if you will or interface it
allows you mailchimp allows from some
easy you know functionality easy
features to go ahead and manipulate and
change to your liking okay so again i'm
working with a template here so anytime
i'm ready to use that template for an
email i can go in and start using it
okay and if i go to templates again i'm
gonna find my template here i can always
edit it i can always share it i can
always preview it i can replicate it and
that's the important thing so if i
replicate it i'm basically creating a
copy of it okay so i just created a copy
so now if i wanted to create a or change
the copy of it i can do that so if i
don't like this whole block i can just
delete it and now that i'm done i can
rename this i'm just going to say
announcement template v2 so now it's
been renamed and now i have two
templates just simply by choosing one
and replicating it so again if i go back
to templates here here i go i have my
two templates and i can store these in a
folder so i'm going to add a folder i'm
going to call it announcements and i'm
going to add the folder and that's it so
now i can store these in the folder so
you can organize all your templates in
different folders if you want to so i'm
going to take these two templates here
move them to my announcements folder and
there you go there in the announcements
folder so if you're going to create
multiple templates then i would
recommend you go ahead and organize it
create folders you know and set up as
many folders as you want and need
because you're going to probably have
different templates for different
occasions depends on what type of email
you're sending out so i just chose
arbitrarily an announcement type email
so now if i go back to create templates
okay you can see again let's go through
some of these others again i just chose
make an announcement you could tell a
story follow-up educate you got all
sorts of different templates that you
could choose all sorts and here you got
some themes so you can even go with a
theme if you wanted to so for example if
you're selling products let's just say
you have a boutique store let's just
choose this boutique template if i
choose this here is my themed template
and so now
just like the other template i was
working in i can go ahead and edit this
here you can see at the top i got the
middle section you know i got all these
different sections that i can now go
ahead and edit so just about really it's
about choosing the theme template that
works best for you and feel free
to
you know try these different templates
out and see what works best for you so
here you can add in certain things like
you know social share so if i just drag
and drop i can add in a social share
image card so a lot of these themes are
very flexible in what you can do in
terms of the design in terms of the
content so again if you go back and i'm
going to cancel and not save this temp
well let's save it what we call boutique
we may use it again in the future so i'm
going to go ahead and click save and now
it's a template it's going to be located
in templates and again if you always
want to access templates just go to
templates you'll see the templates that
you already have created and added so
you can edit them always just by
clicking the edit button now that's
again if you want to create a new
template just create click on the create
new template call to action again you
got themes you've got layouts or you can
even create your own from scratch you
can import another template that you
created in another email marketing
platform or you could do simply just do
everything from scratch and html so you
have three different options here
layouts themes and creating a template
on your own okay and that's either by
importing or by creating it from scratch
okay my recommendation i like some of
the layouts that mailchimp has you can
see a lot of flexibility here and when
you actually choose one again you're in
full control of how to design and
message it so you're in full control of
that so if you just want it again tell a
story i'm gonna select this template
here okay now i'm on the free version so
keep in mind with the free version i
don't have access to all the templates
so here i got to upgrade to use this one
but for example if i don't see the
message upgrade to use then i'm free to
grab it so you can see the one column
i'm free to use so i'm just going to
select that and now i have this template
available to me so again i'm free to
edit this one as i see fit i mean i can
go ahead and again drop in any one of
these elements that are available to me
here i'm going to drop in my social
block okay so here you can see i can now
customize my social block if i want to
add in another platform i can do that
social media platform click save and
close so you can see they're very
customizable all of these themes and
layouts are very customizable and again
when you're done it's just a matter of
you can preview it or test it you can
enter preview mode or you can send
yourself a test email okay so if you
send yourself a test email you can
actually see how it looks when it comes
in so let's go ahead and do that here so
i'm just going to send myself a test
email and the email's been sent so let's
go check our inbox so here is the email
that
i just created from the theme you can
see here all i did simply when i edited
i just dropped in my social block in
here so this is what the email looks
like and the great thing about mailchimp
is they have an option that
you can view the email in a browser if
you can't or you don't want to look at
it in your in this case i'm looking at
gmail so you can always or recipients
can always view the email in a browser
versus the email client that they're
using in specific now when it comes to
completing your profile on mailchimp
you're going to need an audience to send
these emails to and so when you click on
audience here if you don't have an
audience already imported into mailchimp
you're going to be asked to import so
you can see i already have one contact
that contacts me because i added my
email address on that test email so
mailchimp is smart enough to say okay we
don't have this email address and our
contact list so we're going to add them
so here we could see we can manage our
audience so we can add subscribers we
can import contacts we can have sign up
forms and we can manage our contacts so
if we import our contacts if i click on
import here i'm going to be asked to
import either from a csv or copy and
paste or i can just go ahead and
integrate it so if i choose for example
any one of these then it's going to pull
in the context i have there and so
it's up to you how you import your
contacts now the whole point of contacts
is you want to probably or really not
probably it's a best practice to
actually create different lists so that
you can use different audience lists
with different emails and so here you
can see i have one email address i can
again import contacts or i can add them
individually so i can add subscribers
here okay that's another option that's
the slower option my recommendation be
import them but when you import make
sure you you're importing lists that
have some commonality so you can manage
those lists so if you have one list that
or say
you know clients who have never
purchased then you want to create a list
for them if you have clients who have
purchased separate those out okay so
that's the way i would go about it now
if you're trying to build a list
mailchimp has what they call signup
forms so you have different forms that
you can embed and or have as a pop-up
and when people add their email address
to that form then it's automatically
going to get added to your mailchimp
account so that's a great feature in
mailchimp that allows you to
you know build out your audience just by
using one of their forms so again we
have a subscriber pop-up you've probably
seen some of these and some of the
websites you've gone to
so you can customize it and if you want
somebody to subscribe to your newsletter
for example all you need to do is enter
in their email address and click
subscribe okay that's the the pop-up
version now again you have the
opportunity
to
you know use other forms as well so you
got a form builder here or an embedded
form okay or you can integrate the form
okay so if i click form integrations
here i can use wufoo or squarespace i
can integrate with them if i go back to
sign up forms if i choose form builder
here i have a signup form and then i can
customize that form with different boxes
okay or fields okay so whatever field i
want somebody to add information to i
can have that in there and then this
form could be you know on your website
so that's a great feature about
mailchimp is it helps you build an
audience so i can add this form to my
website and anybody who fills out that
form is going to be added to
my subscriber list that i can use for
future emails to take that a step
further i can even go from building a
form to building a landing page so here
you can see if i click on audience i can
go ahead at the bottom right here i have
an option to create a landing page so if
i click on that just like everything
else in mailchimp it's fairly easy to
use i'm just going to name it test click
begin here i can choose my audience
again i can what audience do i want to
add these emails to i click begin and
i'm going to accept and here now i have
all these different templates that i can
use as a lanny page so if you want to
use these landing pages to collect
emails and those emails are going to be
added to your audience then you have a
nice selection here at your disposal
okay so here i'm just going to choose
one you know grow my list okay this is a
landing page so i can customize it just
like i do with my email template i can
add my logo okay i can start adding
different fields here like an image i
can drop an image here okay i can go
ahead and
you know drop in my social shares okay i
can drop in a box text box okay and then
i can start customizing it with some
text some imagery you know some other
information again this is a landing page
that i can then add to my website and so
anytime somebody goes to the landing
page and fills out their email address
and hits subscribe it's going to be
added to that audience list and then i
can turn around and send an email using
one of mailchimp's templates to that
audience so mailchimp really does a
great job of allowing you to grow your
list within your own website via a
landing page a form submission or or
forum or pop-up so there are lots of
different options available to us so i'm
going to click save and close here and
now this landing page is available to me
so i can customize the url i can edit
the audience that these emails go to i
can add a page title and again i can
edit the design so i can really make
this an integrated part of my website by
designing it so it fits the feel and
look of my website i can add a specific
url and i can add a nice page title to
it so mailchimp again does a great job
of just making it so easy for you to
build out a landing page for you to use
on your website to collect email
addresses so if you're doing a
pay-per-click campaign on facebook or
google you can actually drive traffic to
these landing pages and get people to
fill out a form submission and when they
fill out the form submission that email
address is going to get added to your
audience that's an option or you can
just add it as part of your website and
people who go there from say organic
search can find that page and add their
email address organically so that's a
great thing about the audience feature
in mailchimp and that not only can you
select an email template but you have
options to grow your audience okay again
importing contacts you can simply just
add contacts you can add you know a form
submission via pop-up or regular form
fields to your website or you can add a
landing page so it's important to note
that in mailchimp if you go to the
content studio that's where you're going
to find all the files that you've added
to all your templates or landing pages
that you used before so if i click on
content studio here here you can see the
files i've added to my templates if you
have products you can add your products
here okay so if you have an e-commerce
store you can certainly add your
products and then those products can be
used on your landing page or your email
templates you have something called a
giphy you can insert these into any of
your emails make it fun exciting
engaging here you have instagram so what
you could do is you can integrate you
know any one of your instagram accounts
if you have multiple accounts or if you
have one instagram account you can
integrate that one instagram account in
with your mailchimp account and when you
do that it's gonna pull in all the
images that you've had on instagram and
then you have an opportunity here just
to add a logo okay so you can use any of
your instagram images within your emails
use one of these cool giffies again you
can import your products that you can
use for your email templates or just
keep tabs on all the files that you've
added before just by clicking on my
files now when you get to the point of
building different audience lists and
sending down emails you're gonna have
the option to look at reporting to see
how those emails perform for those
specific audiences now again an audience
is a set it's like a segment you know
these are set of individuals who are
going to receive a specific email so in
this example you can see i have
different audiences and if we look at
say any one of these audience or even
just go to all audiences we'll be able
to see
how we fared on some of our emails okay
so for example if i sent out an email
here in april and this is april of 2019
i could see how many total subscribers
i've had now along with the number of
subscribers you have you have what we
call open rate and click-through rate
now we explain a lot of the reporting
and the specific email metrics and
another recording that we did last week
so if you're interested in learning more
about some of the metrics then check out
the video that we have on youtube email
marketing tutorial uh we recorded this
last week go into details about all the
different metrics you
uh can learn about with email marketing
so take a look at this video email
marketing tutorial it'll be a nice
precursor to the mailchimp tutorial so
to give you some insights as to what
metrics to really pay attention to with
email marketing but in mailchimp we know
we can look at the total number of
subscribers we know that we have how
many opens and we know what the open
rate is and again the total number of
clicks and what the click-through rate
is okay so with mailchimp very easily
you just hover over it you get the raw
number and then the percentage so open
rate is how many people actually open
that email based on the total number of
people that the email was sent to so
here we could see in this particular
email last year in april you know we've
had 14 14 1.1 percent to be exact and
that is 13
377 divided by
four 97
nine so that's how many people open the
email so thirteen thousand out of ninety
seven is about fourteen percent now when
somebody opens it we hope they're going
to click on it and so here we got a one
point four percent click-through rate
again that's the total number of clicks
based on the total number of subscribers
or people that were sent the email and
so
mailchimp just gives you a nice overview
of how many subscribers were in this
particular audience list and then the
open rating click rate so we can really
dive in here
and we can actually see how that
particular email performs so if we just
pick one email here we can just click
view report we have other options here
we can print we can download we can
share it the whole campaign or just view
the email if we want to view what the
email look like we can select that so we
just want to view the report so we're
going to click view report and now we
can get into some nice detailed
information about the actual report
itself so again here you can see total
number of recipients and this came from
the audience list called newsletter okay
it was delivered last year september 26
2018 again i have the option to view it
download it print it or share it so
let's take a look and view the email to
see what it looked like okay so this is
what the email look like we have our own
template here and here you can see it
takes into account some of the best
practices involved with email marketing
you know we have some nice content
imagery some call to action here some
other links okay we have our social
icons okay so that's what the email
looked like okay so we'll go back and
we're going to click view report now we
want to view the report again here's
what it look here's when it was sent
okay the open rate for this was 21
click-through rate was 4 so for us the
list average this list here newsletter
the average was for the open rate 16.8
so we're above the average on this email
for the click-through rate the list
average is 2.7 so we're above the
average so we've done a good job on this
email at least generating more opens
more clicks and mailchimp even takes
that a step further they'll even show
you what the industry average is for
your particular industry and in this
case we're education and training so we
did better than the industry average for
both the open rate and for the
click-through rate so we could see some
other specifics we could see the raw
numbers of opens clicks how many people
bounced meaning the email address wasn't
valid anymore and so mailchimp does a
good job of any email that actually
bounces it'll be scrubbed and removed
from your list and then here you can see
347 unsubscribe so the the thing about
you know mailchimp is we want to be
careful we don't have too many
unsubscribes and also people abusing or
reporting abuse meaning you don't want
to send out an email multiple multiple
times a week where it gets the point
where it's spammy and so you want to
avoid a high number of unsubscribes and
a high number of abuse reports and so
here you can see
most emails are open within a 24-hour
period and then it kind of just tails
off so here we can see opens and clicks
based on the time of day so within 24
hour period okay so this is how most
emails operate within that first 24
hours you're going to get a lot of opens
a lot of clicks and then it's going to
tail off from there great thing is
mailchimp provides me more detailed
information about what was clicked so i
could see here the top links that were
clicked and let me just point one thing
out here
whether you use mailchimp or you use any
other platform whether that be vertical
response
or any other type of email marketing
platform you want to use utm tracking
with your links so that google analytics
can pick up the actual campaign so here
you can see we have utm tracking
appended to our links and let me just go
in to detail on that for just a minute
so mailchimp again gives us nice data on
open and click-through rates but when we
send out an email and people actually do
click on one of these links they're
going to go to our website and from
there google analytics is going to take
over on the tracking so this is as far
as mailchimp goes so we want to be able
to bridge the gap between mailchimp
reporting and google analytics meaning
when they came from the
email when and went to the site did they
convert meaning did they download
something did they purchase something
and so we want to be able to bridge the
gap and utm tracking which is simply
appending the original url with some
tracking parameters named utm
it allows us to bridge that gap so all
you need to do when you set up a
mailchimp campaign is just go to url
builder in google then you're going to
click on campaign url builder and we're
going to go ahead and set up an email
campaign so for example if we go back
here this was the original url so if i
just copy this original url here and
paste that as part of my website url
what's my campaign source i'm going to
put mailchimp what's my medium i'm going
to put email so mailchimp is the source
of where the traffic came from the
medium the means in which they
arrived at our website was via email and
the campaign name we're just gonna put
maybe whatever it is summer promo so
with the url builder you have five
parameters for utm tracking you don't
have to use all five okay so here we
need to put in the url and we need to
put in the source but the other four
parameters medium name term and content
are optional so you don't have to put
anything there but the more parameters
you put in the more specific it is for
you to track the behavior of that email
campaign so here i can see mailchimp
email summer promo and then for the
content i can use that to differentiate
my subject line so when you send out an
email we mention this in the email
marketing tutorial you always want to
send out multiple subject lines meaning
one list gets one subject line another
list gets this a second subject line
because you want to be able to measure
open rates based on subject lines so i
can use the campaign content parameter
for different subject lines and notice
the url builder once i enter in my
parameters it's going to append the
original url
with a new url appended with utm
tracking so if i copy that i can simply
just paste that in my browser just to
see if it works and here you can see it
works the page loaded the original url
with utm tracking and so that's exactly
what you want to do because when you're
looking at your reports in mailchimp
it's going to show me the top links that
were clicked now if i go into analytics
i want to be able to see how that
campaign or how that link actually
performed so let's take a look at that
real quick so if i go to my google
analytics account and i go to
acquisition campaigns all campaigns what
am i looking for well if i click on
source and medium source and medium are
two of the parameters for utm tracking
i'm going to look for mailchimp so here
i could see
my original url mailchimp and then the
date stamp and then the mediums email so
if i go back here i can see for example
any one of these mailchimp emails that
went out and then i can see how many
people actually came from the email what
the balance rate was meaning if they
arrived on the site did they leave after
arriving or they actually go to another
page and then i could see other
engagement data like how many pages they
looked at did they how much time did
they spend more importantly did they
convert so that's the whole idea behind
using utm tracking because with utm
tracking you can can bridge the gap from
open rate click-through rate to behavior
on the website all the way through to
the conversion and that's what we want
to measure we want to measure did
somebody go from the email open it click
on one of the links go to the website
engage on the website and convert and so
that's the whole idea behind utm
tracking because mailchimp and any other
email marketing platform is only going
to give you at most your open rates and
your click-through rates okay so here we
could see
the top links clicked i see 4 000
recipients clicked on this email they
went to the site and now i need
analytics to kind of tell me the rest
and here i can see what subscribers have
the most opens and if i integrated
social i can see some social performance
and so that goes back to our original
setup so if you integrate your twitter
account or your facebook account you'll
be able to
integrate that email in with your
twitter and then from there i'll be able
to see you know tweets or or how many
likes for example and to top it off i
can see how many people from around the
world clicked on the email so that's
reporting in a nutshell on mailchimp
reports are fairly easy to look at you
know all sorts of other information like
links specifically links uh you can look
at social so if i click on the social
tab here if i integrated my social i can
look at social reporting likewise for
e-commerce and notice analytics 360 i
can integrate google analytics in with
mailchimp if i want to so i have all
sorts of options on my reporting so
that's it for mailchimp i mean it's
fairly easy to navigate you have all the
campaigns that you've sent out so if you
just click on campaigns i'll be able to
see all the campaigns i've set up and
all the campaigns that have been sent
and obviously the ones that have been
sent i can start looking at reports i
can pick and choose templates okay i can
pick and choose my audience and manage
my audience okay i can see what the
growth is from audience again i have
different options to grow my audience
okay i can certainly add form
submissions landing pages
sign up forms i can import more contacts
and i can manage them through different
lists content studio is where all your
files are going to be located from the
files you've uploaded to e-commerce
products to githi's to instagram to my
logo and then you have reports and the
reports are there for you to measure the
performance of your email campaigns once
they've been sent so you can look at
them from reports or just from the main
campaigns view that's pretty much it so
if you're ready to go at it again click
that create button click that template
choose that audience you can go ahead
and send yourself that test email when
you're ready go ahead and send that
email off to your audience it's that
simple in mailchimp and today we're
going to talk about affiliate marketing
so
let's jump right into it and take a look
inside an office environment right now
we have chuck here chuck's doing a
little bit of pacing john walks in the
office hey man what's with all the
pacing everything all right chuck
responded hey i'm just worried that i
might have exhausted every way we can
advertise our product i mean i've done
seo i've done paid search i've done
email i've done social media nothing's
working i gotta come up with something
new asap well john responds hey don't
worry i think i've got your solution for
you man hang tight relax take a load off
here's my solution affiliate marketing
first off before you ask the question
what's affiliate marketing let's talk
about why we need affiliate marketing so
let's dig into affiliate marketing so
john's just taking over now and he's
gonna let chuck know everything there is
to know about affiliate marketing so the
first question john answers for chuck
what is affiliate marketing so affiliate
marketing is a form of digital marketing
that involves a merchant it involves a
merchant paying commissions to a website
or other entities so if i'm selling a
product basically somebody else sells
that product for me i'm gonna pay that
person a commission for selling my
product it's that simple that's what
affiliate marketing is okay so basically
what these merchants are doing or other
entities they're advertising
your product so they're advertising your
product with a referral so they're
passing on their own customers to you so
that they can buy your product and again
the exchange is you give that website or
other entity a commission that's more or
less what affiliate marketing is so
john's gonna have us take a look at each
of these components of affiliate
marketing in detail take it away john so
john says first we have the merchant aka
the brand the seller the creator the
founder the owner the inspiration the
innovator hey this is the person who
came up with this brilliant idea this
brilliant idea has to get out there
we're the merchant we're trying to get
this brilliant idea out to the masses so
this is the component of affiliate
marketing that creates the product the
merchant could be anyone okay so it
could be startups to large multinational
companies international companies
non-profits for-profits individuals
independent contractors freelancers a
group of people who have a passion for
something okay it could be anybody
there's no limit the affiliate aka the
publisher so the affiliate is basically
that third-party website or entity which
promotes the merchant's products and
tries to convince potential customers of
the merchant's product's value so this
affiliate going to represent the
merchant on their behalf and try and get
their clients to basically purchase that
particular merchant's product so the
affiliate could be incentivized based on
you know registrations email sign up
sales and subscriptions so it doesn't
always come down to you know sales you
know if i'm just trying to get you know
build my email list then hey i can
incentivize that affiliate to push email
signups if i'm got this big you know
offline you know promotion that i'm
doing at this particular mall and i want
to get people there well i can get an
affiliate and incentivize that affiliate
to drive and help me drive registrations
for this event so it doesn't always have
to be sales per se so in effect you the
merchant and the affiliate work out some
type of commission deal based on what
you're incentivizing so the relationship
between the affiliate and the merchant
is made possible with the help of an
affiliate network so that's the third
component here we need somebody to bring
the two together that merchant who has
this brilliant idea and the affiliate
who has potential customers that could
potentially drive registrations sales
signups etc to the merchant so the
affiliate network is the one who brings
the two together so the affiliate
network in effect acts as the middleman
the person in between the merchants and
affiliates it allows merchants to find
and collaborate with not just any
affiliate but the affiliate best suited
for their particular brand and product
because you want to find somebody who is
going to be passionate who's relevant
who has your prospective customers in
mind because they're the ones that are
going to help those protective customers
purchase your product so that's what the
affiliate network does it helps bring
the merchants and affiliates together so
that the affiliate can help advertise
and sell on behalf of the merchant so
with the affiliate network merchants can
use tools for tracking and reporting and
processing payments for affiliates so
really that affiliate network is the
glue that holds it all together they're
not just one to introduce a merchant an
affiliate they offer it all so as a
merchant you want to be able to manage
your affiliates so you're not going to
have one affiliate you're going to have
multiple affiliates so you want to be
able to use the appropriate tools
available to you in the affiliate
network to see and track how sales are
going and when sales happen okay or
commissions happen you want to be able
to use that affiliate network to
compensate that affiliate appropriately
and then finally the customer customer
aka the consumer is the most important
component of all of this take it away
john so the consumer is the final and
most important component without
customers to buy products the merchant
would not have any revenue and the
affiliate would not get any commission
so we need customers so john what is the
process of affiliate marketing well john
says let's have a look at the process so
it's affiliate marketing time so we're
going to use a tool or platform like
commission junction commission junction
is a popular you know platform that
affiliate network platform that brings
merchants and affiliates together so the
merchants can use those affiliates to
advertise their product so let's take a
look at
commission junction as a good digital
marketing tool for affiliate marketing
so we're going to use commission
junction as an example here remember at
affiliate marketing it's an ecosystem
between
publishers and merchants so remember
merchants are selling products
publishers are selling those merchant
products on their site and so commission
junction is the middleman so to speak
okay so commission junction just known
as cj now is the middle person they're
introducing the publisher and the
merchant and so let's go ahead and log
in here so when you log in like any
other digital marketing tool any other
platform you're gonna have your own
settings and whatnot so really the whole
idea behind any affiliate marketing tool
is really
there to manage your publishers who do
you want as a publisher who do you want
selling your product you obviously want
somebody who's relevant somebody who's
going to be able to sell a product
somebody who has a targeted audience
that's similar to yours okay so we go
into cj.com we're going to log in and
here you can see a publisher's link so
we're going to click on the publishers
link and remember when you sign up
publishers you have to have program
terms and so if we click on publishers
program terms we're going to be able to
see
all the different program terms
available so here we could see
the different program terms we have set
up for certain publishers so we just
click on that we'll be able to see
that's the default program term so
remember you could set up your own
program term for any publisher so as a
best practice if you have publishers who
are actually performing well who are
selling your products maybe you want to
offer them a little bit more on the
commission side maybe you want to
sweeten the deal maybe
you know these guys these publishers get
better program terms versus say other
publishers who don't and so here we can
see the program terms basically you
could see what the terms are the action
and the different policies here so
everything you need to do to manage that
publisher in terms of payment is done
under the program terms now if the
program terms are met the publisher
actually sells your products cj is the
broker they're the ones who are going to
initiate the payment based on the
program terms so be careful on the
program terms you want to be able to set
them appropriately cj has templates cj
has some default program terms that you
can use and offer up to different
publishers so based on the program terms
that's how your publishers are going to
get paid and so here you can have as
many different program terms as you want
there's no limit here you want to be
able to align and reward program terms
again based on performance and so
here we can see what publishers are
under what program terms so again if
your publisher is performing well
sweeten the deal offer them a better
program terms and so you can align
publishers with different program terms
and so that's the whole idea behind
program terms is you want to be able to
align publishers with that so when you
sign up a publisher they're going to get
a line with a program term meaning what
are they going to get paid for selling
your product now if we want to manage by
status instead of by program terms we
could see all the different
organizations we have in our network
these are our publishers we're the
affiliate we're the ones selling the
product we want to know
who's selling who's not selling and so
we can look at all our publishers by
program terms or by status okay so
basically you can see here the term
status whether it's active or not
earnings basically what they've sold
over the last basically seven days or
three months so you could look at
basically how your publishers are
performing just by clicking on manage by
status here in cg.com so when you're
looking at reports in
cj.com or really any other affiliate
program you might see the acronym epc
this stands for earnings per click
actually it's a little misleading it's
actually earnings per 100 clicks so
basically cj calculates you know how
much your publisher is actually making
per click you know just like paid search
we're paying google x amount per click
it's the same thing here we can't or
these publishers can't make any money if
they don't generate clicks so that's why
you have an epc model or metric so to
speak so you can measure earnings per
click cj does it over seven day period
and over a three month period so you
could sort based on seven day or three
month to see
who's earning the most per click in
terms of publishers now you can select
under publishers groups now you can
group your publishers okay so if you
have say a group of publishers in a
specific region like the united states
or india or if you're just focused on
the united states and say you have
publishers in different states like
texas california missouri arkansas well
you can group those publishers into
different groups and you can look at
your different group names here so here
we could see canada and so we have our
publishers grouped into
a group called canada why because
they're based in canada makes sense so
you want to be able to organize your
publishers because the whole idea behind
affiliate marketing cj is you want to be
able to get the best publishers
available for your network and so as you
get more publishers for your network
you'll be able to
basically start grouping them where it
makes sense now the example i gave you
is by geography you could do by
geography or
you could do by publisher status meaning
my best performing publishers go into a
group if they're in a group then they
get aligned with a certain program term
so you can group your publishers any way
you want by status meaning they're
selling more these are our best
performing publishers or by region or
you know by promotion i mean how you
group your publishers is totally up to
you however take advantage
of the option to create publisher groups
because the whole idea again i'm going
to repeat it is you want to get
publishers you want to start building
your base of publishers because the more
publishers you have the more chance you
are to sell your product remember if
nobody clicks on your product then
nobody's going to buy your product so if
you have publishers who are promoting
your product for you
then you have a good opportunity to sell
it so the more publishers you have on
board the better the opportunity so now
once you have publishers you can start
grouping these publishers accordingly to
whatever makes sense the business
decision just know the options available
in cj to group publishers now when
you're in cj and you're starting out
okay you want to start recruiting your
publishers so you click on recruit and
based on your settings based on what
you're selling cj is going to try and
put you in front of
some good publishers and so here we
could see if we click on recruit we're
going to get a list of publishers and
this search results list of publishers
that we can recruit into our network are
all listed here and you could actually
see what's interesting you can see the
name of the publisher and you can see
the url and then you could actually see
if they're a good performer or not so
you could actually see their history as
a publisher just by looking at their
network earnings and then also looking
at their seven day earnings per click or
three month earnings per click and so
if a publisher has a very high earnings
per click epc
then they're probably a good publisher
somebody you're probably gonna be
interested in so if i see a publisher
with you know three month earnings per
click of 105
then that means hey if that's my
publisher i'm paying 105 or 106 dollars
over seven days
you know they're generating some clicks
for me and they're generating sales you
can't deliver commission if they don't
sell and so to me i want to be able to
look at the
seven three month earnings per click for
these publishers and so i can just click
on any one of these publishers here and
get some more insight about that
publisher right here in cj so
here i can see the particular url the
company some other urls that they have
associated with them in cj i can see the
category that they're in again i can see
the seven three month epc here you can
see the description okay you can see
some other promotional methods that
they'd use when promoting products and
you get some permanent performance from
this particular publisher just by
pulling down the pull down menu here i'm
gonna look at this year and see what
their performance is and why i'm waiting
for that to load i could see hey they're
also in other countries as well so i can
get a good snapshot of
a particular publisher by recruiting
publishers seeing what their performance
is over a period of time and potentially
you know recruiting that publisher would
be part of my network because if they're
part of my network then hey if they're
selling products if i'm selling products
and i want my product on their site and
they're doing a good job of selling
other products then i want them to be
you know part of my ecosystem part of my
network now remember
cj's doing the introducing here they're
introducing you to recruits so
you want to be able to again take a look
at the site does do any of the sites
that a particular publisher has interest
you you know again we can just click on
it go to the specific site take a good
look hey virgin atlantic okay do we want
them selling our product maybe maybe not
um so you want to take a look at the
website make sure it's not spammy make
sure it aligns with your business goals
it makes your aligns with your product
your target audience remember a lot of
things you want to make sure
the website aligns with because they're
representing your brand okay very
important here very important and so
that's what you want to be able to do
and you could do all that just by
looking at the publisher detail in cg
and then again take a look at earnings
per click if they're selling products
for other merchants and they're doing a
good job maybe you want them selling
your product as well okay so you can
also you know sort by country
you can also do network earnings and you
can really filter here so we want you
know choose high network earners in a
particular country a particular state
you know we could definitely filter in
on a particular
type of publisher okay so you want to be
able to hone in on somebody to align
with your geography or you know
definitely you want to align with
somebody who's a high network owner now
when you get all your publishers set up
you're going to need to provide them
with some good promotional materials
some good banners um you know it could
be text links some messaging okay so
you're the one who's going to provide
the publishers with you know the
information they need now
as a best practice remember you can get
on the phone with these publishers have
monthly calls or quarterly calls see
what they need you know reach out to
them via email or reach out to them via
the cj platform figure out hey you know
how's your banners working for you do
you need new banners so you want to be
able to constantly you know push new
content out and so
if i click on links here and manage i'll
be able to see everything that i have
available for my publishers to use okay
and then you can actually look at
banners that have actually produced for
you in terms of epc
or you know if it's a specific promotion
okay you could set that up here so
you're gonna be able to see it here you
can see all
the banners you can see some text links
in here so all the you know advertising
that you want these publishers to have
is gonna be situated under links and so
you can see what the active ones are you
can look at archived you can look at
again text links content links or
banners and as a best practice if i
click on a banner as a best practice
ideally what you want to do is use utm
tracking okay so you want to have some
type of tracking in place however
cj does a lot of the tracking for you so
they're going to be able to tell you how
many times a banner's been clicked and
how many times a banner's been seen okay
they'll also tell you more importantly
not only was that banner click but did
it generate a sale and so here i can see
that i have three publishers using this
particular banner i can see over this
period of time 412 impressions meaning
412 people viewed the banner and i
received one click on it so you can get
some in-depth detail about your
different marketing materials and how
they're performing okay you can also see
what publishers are using them okay so
the key here is
you want to be able to communicate with
your publishers give them the
promotional material and that they need
to promote your product now you could
set up specifically you could set up a
unique banner for a publisher or you
could set up a banner for a group of
publishers that's where the group comes
in so you have some options here and
then as a best practice what i would try
and do as you can see here is come up
with different banner sizes so you can
see here we got a 728 by 90. okay you
got a 160 by 600 you got a 300 by 250.
okay so you want to have different
banner sizes and you also want to mix in
some text um ads as well okay you want
to be able to give
your publishers some options in terms of
what to use on their websites so that's
the whole idea because a publisher may
not have space on the home page they may
only have enough space for you know a
text ad or a 300 by 250. so you want to
be able to mix it up and then also mix
up the messaging as well so you can have
the same 300 250 banner but you can have
different messaging just like you see
here 300 by 250 got this messaging here
and we got a different set of messaging
with the same banner size so the more
options you present for yourself the
more of an opportunity you have for the
publisher to use that messaging that
banner that text that on their website
and then that gives you a better
opportunity to get the click get the
conversion that you seek out so
that is
links so you want to be able to continue
to
push out different banners and text ads
now cj also has a great feature in here
if you're selling a lot of products you
have a large inventory of products you
could actually upload a product feed to
cj so you can see in this example we
don't but
if you did let's just say you have a
hundred products that you want to sell
you can go ahead and upload that fee to
cj and then the publisher will be able
to use that entirety in its of the feed
or pick and choose different products to
use and sell so let's jump over to
reports and cj you have reports of this
is really the bulk of where you want to
be spending your time because you want
to be able to
you know not only recruit those
publishers but after you recruit them
you want to be able to see the
performance how are things moving or are
publishers moving product are they
generating clicks are they selling your
product so go no further than reports
right here at the top navigation we're
going to click on performance reports
and so we want to be able to see
over a period of time you know are we
selling our product and here you can see
over the last 30 days you could see how
much commission was paid out remember cj
gets a fee they're the broker okay so
that's part of the program terms okay so
it's based on program terms who's
selling okay what program term are they
associated with cj gets their commission
okay so you can see the total commission
and then the sale amount okay so we can
see how many sales were generated how
many items were sold how many clicks
were generated how many impressions so i
can get a good sense here day by day
over who's selling who's not selling and
it's all broken down at the very end to
earnings per click so that's my
performance report so we want to be able
to see over a period of time you know
are we selling now i can go into detail
if i click on transaction here from the
pull down menu i can look at a specific
order i can choose a specific publisher
or website and i can get details about
that specific order publisher website
etc just be look by choosing transaction
so i can get really granular about the
data i see for a specific transaction
that's just by clicking reports
transaction now we can also click on
promo codes and if you're running any
promo codes for your publishers you'll
be able to see
how many conversions those promo codes
delivered and the set total sale amount
over the last 30 days so building a
network is all about recruiting the
right publishers giving them the
materials they need measuring the
performance of the publishers and then
communicating it's just so key so cj has
a nice message center built in so you
can actually you know look at the
messages you're getting from your
publishers and turn around and
communicate with them so
communicate
seamlessly and efficiently right in cj
here so i just clicked on mail and we
can see the messages we have so you can
also click on email campaigns and if you
have any email campaigns that you want
to run you can look at them right here
in cj so cj offers up some email
campaigns then we can see how many
people we targeted you know how many
people opened it and how many people
joined in this case joined our network
so
here we have you know a breakdown of
each of the email campaigns that we've
run over a period of time and their
status and how many people were
targeting and opens deliveries etc so if
you want to run an email campaign write
in cj it's available to you as part of
the platform so if we move over from
mail to placements we have an
opportunity to place some promotional
material on a publisher's website and so
here we could see a breakdown of
different publishers who basically will
offer up some promotional material that
we can leverage okay so here you got
this particular promotional placement
it's a one month placement and review
page with your ad so we can actually you
know take advantage of what publishers
are offering up on their own website so
the whole idea here is if it's in a
prime position on their website then we
can take advantage of that so then what
we want to be able to do is if we like
what they're offering up you can see hey
this particular publisher saying hey i
have a creative the placement is a home
page banner or full page review provide
an email with a copy of the ad that
you'd like to be displayed and we're
going to email this person here so if we
want to take advantage of a specific
promotional placement on a publisher's
website then we can do that just by
clicking on placements and we'll be able
to see who's offering up what notice
there's a fee involved so it just gives
you an opportunity to
reward a publisher that's performing
well for you and if they turn around and
offer you a better placement for a
little bit more money it might be worth
it so the whole idea is to take
advantage of placements because if your
product is in place properly then
nobody's gonna see it if nobody sees it
then you know they're not gonna click on
it and then you're not gonna get sales
so that's the whole idea here
is take advantage of what publishers are
offering up in terms of promotional
opportunities so cj also has a
pay-per-call
click uh model as well pay model so
basically
your pay per performance is based on
calls so
basically the whole point here is a cj
points out you want to promote more high
ticket and consultative products and
services you want to expand your reach
and you want to get more qualified sales
then you can offer up a pay per call and
the beauty here is cj tracks the calls
so
you will be able to see
the actual phone number and calls so
instead of offering up say you know
banner with a click you can offer up you
know promotional number and have cj
track the calls from the publisher and
that just opens up another opportunity
for you to give your publishers an
option to have people call if they call
then great you know it's another way for
somebody to get in touch and purchase
the product so the pay-per-call method
is available under cj as well so if we
want to get more insights about how our
program is performing we just click on
the insights cj's gonna take us to this
overview this dashboard if you will with
some really good data based on a time
frame okay so we're comparing july
through
of july of 19 through july of 2018 we're
able to see revenue and commissions paid
out and how many clicks average order
value so
there's kind of an overview dashboard if
you will about how our
overall program is performing there are
other similar tools and resources to
include you know max bounty trade
doubler amazon associates there's plenty
of networks out there you want to find a
network where you're going to have
affiliates that are going to be
passionate and going to be relevant and
have the prospective audience that you
need to sell your product so do your due
diligence on the number of different
platforms out there so what's the
process of affiliate marketing so the
process is really setting up rules
guidelines specifications around
branding commissions etc for the
affiliates so that's really step two
step one is you gotta find that network
step two you gotta then establish the
process within that network within that
affiliate network and so the merchant
provides specifications such as hey
here's what type of creative i want to
use you know it could be a banner it
could be just a text ad it could be a
video and
we want to be able to specify the
messaging in that ad we want to specify
the specific parameters around the image
what size image are we going to use okay
we want to specify the landing page or
the link we're going to send people to
and then most important within that
affiliate network the merchant is going
to set the commission and so you can
have multiple incentives so remember you
can incentivize based on email signups
or registrations okay not just sales so
you could set the commission at say five
percent for email signups and 15 for
sales so you could specify what kind of
creative and text you want the affiliate
to use so this is really important
because if you're pushing a product like
a camera or some type of electronic
gadget you can also specify
what promotion you want that affiliate
to use you could specify the call to
action again you can specify the image
specifications the price point the
language in the ad so as the merchant
you're in total control over
what creative and text you want the
affiliate to use so john is going to
stay further john the commission that
each affiliate we receive is also
mentioned so let's look at the scenario
where an affiliate receives 15
commission for each product purchased
through a referral code so 15 commission
so the customer clicks on a referral
link from the affiliates website the
customer buys the product for let's just
say twenty seven dollars and ninety
seven cents well fifteen percent of that
is four dollars twenty cents so the
affiliate will get a commission of four
dollars and twenty cents so as the
merchant you have to be able to set that
commission appropriately you don't want
to give 100 commission away you don't
want to get 50
you want to set a commission that's
going to incentivize the affiliate so
that it's a win-win situation you're
getting a sale philly is getting the
commission the customer's happy with the
product and everybody comes away with an
ecosystem that works for all parties so
what is the process of affiliate
marketing well affiliates apply to
advertise on your behalf okay so that's
the third step here so first step choose
that network second step set up all the
guidelines third step really affiliates
are going to apply and say look merchant
i want to sell your product on my
website so john take it away john well
affiliates can contact you through the
affiliate network that's the whole point
of the network or through a page you
have set up on your website specifically
for affiliates so really there's two
ways for affiliates to reach out to you
through the network or directly through
your website either way we're trying to
get affiliates who are going to be
passionate about selling our product for
the commission we're offering so if you
look here at the bottom you may see a
link that says hey you know if you're
interested in our affiliate program
click on the affiliate program link and
from there you're going to be able to
see all the details about how to become
an affiliate so that's an example of
what you could do on your website if you
have an affiliate network so the last
step in all this is to select the
affiliates that are best suited for your
brand so when you set up that network
you set up all the guidelines you're
offering a great commission it's a
win-win scenario then you're gonna have
all these affiliates apply to sell your
product you're the one in control you're
the merchant you're representing the
brand you need to pick and choose the
affiliate that's best suited for your
brand this is probably the most
important step you want to get your
product out there on the website that is
best suited to position your product to
your prospective audience so john take
it away well you could select an
affiliate from the ones that have
applied for your affiliate program this
can be based on a number of factors one
how much traffic the affiliate website
gets you know we want to choose an
affiliate that gets a lot of traffic you
don't want to choose an affiliate that
gets very minimal traffic what's the
point you want to get your product out
there in front of people the second
criteria is how successful was his or
her previous affiliate campaigns were
they successful in selling other
merchants products do they have a good
track record were they good affiliates
then third criteria is the most
important is that affiliate okay with
the commission offered now you can
always go back and renegotiate a higher
commission for those that have been or
proven to be successful in the past at
selling products or you can renegotiate
the commission for affiliates who are
proven to sell your product so
for example if you have a hundred
affiliates selling your product and you
have ten of those who have proven to be
really good affiliates for you then you
can go ahead and give them a raise so to
speak so instead of 15 commission you
can bump it up to 20 so you can create a
whole new commission agreement for quote
unquote best affiliates and likewise on
the flip side well you know an affiliate
is not selling your product then you
probably don't want him or her hanging
around you probably want to try and see
if you can incentivize them and if you
can't incentivize them then the
affiliate network is there to broker not
only the agreement but you know separate
the agreement as well so you could
certainly get rid of affiliates who
don't perform but you can incentivize
affiliates who do perform but really it
comes down to first do they have a good
track record you know do they get
traffic and are they okay with the
commission you're sending forth so
consumers click on the adder link which
sends the users to the merchant's
website so they're going to the
merchant's website from the affiliate
website the see it called to action will
direct you to a page where you can buy
for example in this case software so
we're buying software here and you can
see here from the software we could
choose what we want the full version
we're going to go for the full version
we're going to go through the checkout
here we're going to click on buy now
after we've entered in all of our
details so it's almost seamless from the
affiliates website to the merchant's
website or landing page all the way
through the checkup process and remember
the affiliate network is the one
tracking all this behavior so as the
person goes from the affiliates website
to the merchants to the merchant's
shopping cart the affiliate network is
tracking the entire behavior so after
the customer makes a purchase
on that merchant's website the affiliate
network records the details of his or
her transaction this is important
because the affiliate network records it
they're the ones that are going to
calculate how much commission gets paid
out to the affiliate so again if it's
that 27.97
product 15 commission then the affiliate
network's gonna make sure that that
affiliate gets his or her commission of
four dollars and 20 cents okay so the
transaction is validated and credited to
the affiliate okay so this is all
recorded in the affiliate network that
you choose whether that be commission
junction cj or something else okay the
affiliate is then paid his or her
commission once they're paid it's almost
seamless nothing is stopped nothing is
halted nothing's paused that affiliate
is going to keep on promoting that
merchant's product the more that
affiliates incentivize with commissions
i guarantee the more that affiliates
going to want to push the merchant's
product because they know they're
getting sales by that particular
merchant's product by that merchant so
it's a win-win situation the merchant's
getting his or her product sold as a
result of these affiliates websites the
affiliate is getting commission via the
affiliate network thanks to the
merchant's product so it's a win
combination and it's a successful
combination so affiliate marketing to me
is equivalent to an ecosystem that
creates a win-win environment you the
merchants getting your product out there
hey the affiliate's getting an
opportunity to make some money so john
what do you have to say well the whole
process repeats itself it doesn't stop
so you as the merchant you got to keep
finding affiliates and on the affiliate
side hey you're gonna offer up that
product to keep getting incentivized
with commissions so it's a constant
constant process that just continues to
recycle itself so that everybody
continues to win so some of the
advantages of being able to select an
affiliate that's relevant to your brand
are one you could choose an affiliate
best suited to represent your brand and
products okay that's important you want
to choose and a relevant
affiliate two you only need to pay
commission if a conversion takes place
okay that's the great thing about it no
conversion no sale no commission now
again you can offer up other incentives
like registrations and emails so that
way you're getting something and the
affiliate's getting something in return
maybe a lower commission but they're
still getting something in return can
the affiliates audience are more likely
to be interested in your product if it's
relevant affiliates relevant to your
product then chances are the audience
gonna be interested in your product on
the affiliates website so the system
works on a semi automatic basis the more
commissions the affiliate gets the more
they push your product the more sales
you get you get sales affiliate gets
commissions everybody wins process just
keeps going so john what are the tips
for success in affiliate marketing well
john says hey look now that you know how
affiliate marketing works here are some
tips on how you can get
better at affiliate marketing one
provide competitive rates to attractive
successful affiliates so remember we
talked about this a couple of minutes
ago hey affiliates ad or performing at a
higher level offer them a higher
commission hey gamify your compensations
into tears to reward best performing
affiliates okay so break them off in a
different tiers best middle lower
performing okay maintain a good
relationship with your affiliates with
regular communication so the
communication doesn't just stop and end
once you accept the affiliate
communication continues reach out to the
affiliate have monthly calls weekly
calls in some cases it could be daily
calls or it could be emails or text
messaging you know offer up different
promotions or more importantly get some
feedback from the affiliate get their
ideas about your product they're the
ones who are selling your products they
probably have some ideas on how you can
better improve it or maybe they receive
feedback from their audience they can
pass along so it's important to maintain
a good relationship with your affiliates
to keep the relationship strong then set
up ground rules regarding the liberties
affiliates can take with your brand
remember you're setting up the brand
guidelines at the beginning you want to
make sure affiliates abide by those
brand guidelines but give them a little
bit of flexibility here now you're the
one setting the guidelines but let them
have some lead way in
for example how much they can post your
product where they can post your product
they know their website better than you
you know your brand better than them
together you can compromise to come up
with a winning formula be flexible with
your budget provided it generates sales
and profits so in other words you don't
want to give away too much on the
commission side you want to keep it
within a specific uh range so that way
you're still gaining an advantage on
each sale meaning you're gaining profits
they provide promotional ideas and
talking points and new affiliates to
nurture them in other words hey pass
along some best practices pass along
what the best performing affiliates have
done to the new affiliates if it works
for one it may work for another it may
not but hey sharing is caring sharing is
informative sharing is knowledge sharing
is important so share some ideas with
new affiliates to get them going as
quickly as possible and then enhance
your promotions with product information
that affiliates can create a buzz around
so you know listen you can have
recurring calls with affiliates and you
can get some ideas from these affiliates
about promotions but really what it does
is it comes down to you to create a good
promotion that you will incentivize the
affiliates to really push for it you
know it could be a buy one get one free
a nice percentage off it really depends
but you gotta you you're the one you're
the merchant you're the brand owner you
need to push uh the affiliates and help
the affiliates to give them ammunition
to help sell your product chuck is just
at this point ecstatic john has given
chuck a lot of information he's given
them some networks to choose from he's
giving him the steps he needs to set up
the affiliate network anything from
setting up the guidelines to
choosing the right affiliates to
communicating with the affiliates best
tips and practices and methodologies
chuck is really thankful to john for all
the explanation chuck's gonna go right
away and look for that affiliate network
so he can get moving with choosing the
right affiliates to help sell his
products so chuck is thankful for john
jones thanks for chuck and everybody
lives happily ever after in the
professional world of affiliate
marketing guys i'm proud from simply
learn and today i'm going to tell you
how you can become a digital marketer so
here's what we'll be going through today
first off who is a digital marketer how
to become a digital marketer the salary
of a digital marketer and how you can
become a certified digital marketer so
first off let's answer the most
important question who is a digital
marketer now a digital marketer is
responsible for several things let's go
through some of them first off they're
responsible to develop as well as manage
marketing campaigns to ensure that the
goals of the organization are fulfilled
they need to create a marketing strategy
which is based on analyzing their
competition as well as the benchmarks
within the industry they need to drive
website traffic as well as acquire leads
which are then worked upon by the
organization or the business they need
to utilize web analytics tools so that
they can measure and optimize the
campaign which is basically figuring out
how well the campaign is doing and if
it's not doing well how they can make it
better and finally they need to be able
to enhance brand awareness which is just
letting people know that the brand
exists and how the brand can make their
lives better next up let's talk about
how to become a digital marketer to
become a digital marketer you need a
certain set of skills skills like search
engine optimization search engine
marketing or sem email marketing social
media marketing affiliate marketing
content marketing and finally mobile
marketing so the first step you need to
take to become a digital marketer is to
learn seo so seo or search engine
optimization is the process of
increasing the quality of your organic
traffic which is nothing but the traffic
that comes to your website without
having seen any paid advertisements just
because your website is one of the first
few results when they search a
particular query on a search engine seo
involves on-page seo as well as off-page
seo so how to do on-page seo first off
you need to do keyword research keyword
research is one of the most important
steps when it comes to seo it is the
process of identifying popular words and
phrases used on search engines by users
you need to be able to identify keywords
with high search volume high relevancy
and low competition next up we have
technical audit so search engines around
the world have internet bots performing
a particular process known as crawling
in this process these search engine
internet bots these search engine bots
also known as spiders scan a website and
copy the entire website's content and
store it within the search engine for it
to index now you need to ensure your
site is being crawled and indexed next
you have on-site optimization you need
to develop high-quality content meta
tags url and sitemaps and finally user
experience you need to provide good
website architecture as well as internal
linking structure next up let's talk
about how to do off-page seo this is
made possible with the help of link
building this is the process of
navigating links from other websites to
your own and by building external links
to your website your organic search
ranking can be improved now let's talk
about some seo tools you have moz google
keyword planner semrush and ahrefs now
let's talk about the next step required
to become a digital marketer which is to
learn sem or search engine marketing
search engine marketing is a practice of
marketing a business using paid
advertisements on search engines and
other websites so basically this is a
way of attracting users towards your
website or a particular product that
you're offering so how can you do sem or
search engine marketing first off you
need to determine your goal and define a
budget you need to ensure that you have
a goal in mind for example do you want
more leads do you want to increase
traffic or improve brand awareness and
much more after you're done with that
you need to define a budget how much
money are you ready to spend to achieve
this goal then you need to choose a list
of relevant keywords which is keywords
on which you'll be bidding to advertise
you need to finalize your keywords and
then bid on them which is basically are
you ready to pay for how many clicks
you're getting or for acquiring
customers or making them leads and so on
you need to create a compelling headline
for your ad campaign you need to monitor
the performance of campaigns and measure
results which is basically finding out
whether the campaign is working out well
and if it's not to optimize it so that
it works the next time and you need to
target your audience with remarketing
campaigns for example if a customer does
not go through with the conversion
process they can be added to the
remarketing audience so that they can be
advertised to again some of the popular
sem tools are google adwords editor fb
ads manager bing ads and ad role now for
the next step to become a digital
marketer you have to learn email
marketing now email marketing is a
really efficient as well as inexpensive
way to generate high return on
investment it can be used to convert
prospects into customers by sending
personalized emails to a targeted
audience so how do you perform email
marketing first off you need to discover
your target audience and create segments
in which you can divide them depending
on their behavior you need to select and
create your type of campaign depending
on the goals you want to achieve you
need to select a suitable design for
your campaign you need to have a
compelling subject line and email
content which is very important when it
comes to email marketing you need to
send campaigns immediately or schedule
an email and finally you need to measure
results such as open rate click-through
rate response rate and so on you also
need to perform eb testing to find out
what works and what doesn't some of the
popular email marketing tools are
mailchimp hubspot marketo send in blue
and so on and now for the next step you
need to learn social media marketing
social media marketing involves the
promotion of your product and services
on different social media platforms
using different types of content now
this could be just sponsored posts video
advertisements images articles and so on
now how can you do social media
marketing first off you need to choose a
suitable social media platform for your
business it could be facebook youtube
twitter linkedin and so on next up you
need to find your target audience now
each of these platforms has a particular
niche that occupies it now for example
facebook requires an active social media
marketing strategy pinterest is usually
used by females linkedin can be used for
employee networking and youtube is a
platform where people create as well as
share video content and that's the only
content that works on youtube you need
to create as well as curate engaging
content because without your content
being engaging nobody's going to be
interested in your product or service
then you need to choose a social media
management tool and finally you need to
test evaluate and optimize your results
now let's talk about some popular social
media marketing tools we have hootsuite
tweet tech buffer sprout social and so
many more now for your next step to
becoming a digital marketer you need to
learn affiliate marketing now affiliate
marketing is a form of digital marketing
that involves two players a merchant as
well as an affiliate now a merchant is
an individual who pays a commission to
the affiliate who could be a third party
site or entity to drive sales bring
leads or new customers with the help of
referrals now how can you do affiliate
marketing first off you need to choose a
tool through which you can find
affiliates who can advertise your
product now you need to choose affiliate
on the basis of how much traffic the
affiliates website gets how successful
the affiliates previous campaigns were
and and how much commission the
affiliate asks for then you need to
specify the format that the affiliate
must use when they're advertising your
product or service you need to keep a
record of the customers who purchased
your product or service through the
affiliate and finally pay the affiliate
based on the commission rates now let's
talk about some of the popular affiliate
marketing tools there's cj affiliate
volume has offers and even now for the
next step to becoming a digital marketer
you need to learn mobile marketing now
mobile marketing enables a business to
communicate with a targeted audience
through any mobile device this is
through sms emails mms's and so on so
how do you do mobile marketing first off
you need to create a mobile buyer
persona which is you know what kind of
person is using the phone you need to
set business goals like what goals
basically determining what goals you
want to achieve with the mobile
marketing campaign then you need to
conduct your campaign and reach your
target audience with a personalized
message to these users and finally you
need to monitor these metrics and
optimize them if required now let's talk
about some popular mobile marketing
tools there's slick text localities
admob facebook mobile ads and much more
now for your next step in becoming a
digital marketer you need to learn
content marketing content marketing is a
bull marketing technique of creating as
well as sharing valuable content now
this could be blogs videos or articles
which solves the problem of the target
audience this holds their attention by
adding value to their lives and can end
up converting their interest into a
purchase so how do you do content
marketing firstly you need to define
your goals as in what you want to
achieve you need to define your target
audience then you need to determine what
kind of content you're creating it could
be blog posts ebooks case studies
infographics and so on you need to
brainstorm for new content ideas you
need to perform a content audit which is
to evaluate content elements and
information assets and choose a suitable
content management system now you can
plan create publish and measure your
results all in one place using a content
management system using a content
management system such as the hubspot
software next you need to promote your
content using email affiliate and social
media marketing finally you need to
measure your success and optimize your
content now let's talk about some of the
popular content marketing tools there's
linkedin pulse paper.li flipboard trapit
and many many more now let's talk about
some additional resources now there are
a huge number of videos online about
digital marketing and i recommend you go
through some of them so that you have a
basic idea about their fundamentals now
this is where simply learn's youtube
channel can help you you can take
advantage of simplylearn's digital
marketing tutorials you can go to this
playlist right here and here you have
tutorials on what is seo how you can
rank number one on google keywords
research facebook ads tutorial how you
can rank your youtube videos facebook
advertising tips and tricks social media
marketing google tag manager google
analytics and so much more now let's
have a look at the salaries of a digital
marketer in the united states the
average salary of a digital marketer is
approximately 65 000 per year similarly
the average salary for a digital
marketer in india is approximately 5
lakh rupees per year now let's talk
about how you can become a certified
digital marketer now there are a number
of different certifications available
for you there's the google ads
fundamental certification the facebook
certified planning professional
certification the hubspot content
marketing certification the hootsuite
social marketing certification and
simply learns digital marketing
specialist masters program now here's
another way simple learn can help you
simply learn has a number of different
digital marketing certification has a
number of different digital marketing
certifications let's talk about the
digital marketing specialist masters
program in this program there are a
number of different certifications such
as the digital marketing certified
associate advanced web analytics
advanced seo and so on the certification
also provides the omcp certification
exam voucher worth 395 dollars upon the
completion of the master's program it
has 45 plus projects and can help you
get a salary of close to 17 lakhs per
annum it is also accredited by hootsuite
facebook the omcp and so on so now let's
have a closer look at the digital
marketing course or the digital
marketing certified associate
certification training now this
certification provides 53 hours of
instructor-led training 40-plus hours of
self-paced videos instructor-led online
project mentoring sessions helping you
prep for examinations from the omca
google ads and so on it has industry
accreditations from hootsuite facebook
and the omcp and it covers more than 35
tools such as facebook insights youtube
analytics crazy egg google keyword
planner google ad manager linkedin ads
buffer semrush and so on so why don't
you go on to simplylearn.com so that you
get so that you can get started on your
journey getting certified and getting
ahead and today we're going to talk
about digital marketing careers jobs and
resumes so welcome and let's get started
so we live in a world where everything
is digitized whether we're communicating
reading watching interacting everything
is digitized and one of the benefits of
our digitized world is
opportunities and those opportunities
have arisen in the world of digital
marketing so
when we mean by digital marketing we
mean advertising to people via different
channels and so we're gonna hone in on
digital marketing and look at what those
opportunities are so let's talk a little
bit about digital marketing so digital
marketing really
involves selling a product or service
using several different online slash
digital marketing channels so some of
the most popular digital marketing
channels used by a lot of companies
today is seo which is search engine
optimization
sem which is search engine marketing
that's paid search so if you see a
sponsored ad on google that would be
related to sem mostly you're probably
already familiar with email marketing
meaning you probably received an email
from a company trying to promote or sell
a product or service so those are some
of the most popular channels of course
there's other channels like video social
affiliate influencer marketing display
so there's a lot of different marketing
channels that fall under the umbrella of
digital marketing and so
those are some of the online marketing
channels used by companies to promote
their products and services and so in a
sense that's what digital marketing is
and so because digital marketing is
involves a lot of channels a lot of
companies need people to you know work
on those channels for that company
promoting that product or services so
let's take a look at some of those
particular roles involved with digital
marketing and the first one really is a
digital marketing manager so that's over
seeing all these different marketing
channels okay so somebody looking and
managing these different marketing
channels we just mentioned like seo
slash organic search or paid search or
social okay so digital marketing
managers oversee and implement these
different campaigns across different
channels with the strategy of either
brand awareness or
selling a particular product or
promoting the company services and so
with the digital marketing manager it's
a broad title in a sense but it comes
with a lot of responsibilities
so if we look at some of these
responsibilities it's really designing
and overseeing all the aspects of
digital marketing when we say all
aspects we don't mean just campaigns but
really what we mean is managing a
marketing database if you're
implementing campaigns and you're
collecting information as a result you
want to be able to store and manage that
information appropriately it also comes
down to
being able and being familiar and being
fluent in
different marketing channels like
jumping from email marketing to display
marketing when you manage multiple
campaigns and channels you have to have
a budget so you got to be able to
develop and maintain a budget so
being a digital marketing manager means
you know being able to
articulate and respond to channels that
are working and assigning budget
accordingly based on performance and not
only just assigning budget but making
sure the budget gets implemented
appropriately social is a big part of
digital marketing and so in itself
that's an 800 pound gorilla meaning it's
a lot of responsibility so plan and
manage social media platforms you know
for a lot of companies they're quick to
jump out there on the deep end when it
comes to social so digital marketing
manager really is someone who can reel
that in and say you know what look we
don't need to be on twitter or or
linkedin you know having that
responsibility taking the responsibility
for managing the social media platforms
accordingly what are the biggest jobs of
a digital marketing manager in my
opinion is maintaining reports and it's
not even maintaining reports i mean a
lot of tools like google analytics will
create the report for you we talk about
maintaining reports we really mean
looking at those reports looking at the
performance of these campaigns and
channels and reacting accordingly and
that leads to the next bullet point
really with the digital marketing
manager and that means coming up with
new growth strategies because if let's
just say a paid search campaign is
really performing okay how are we going
to grow that strategy how are we going
to grow that campaign vice versa if your
facebook ads aren't performing what can
we do to get them to grow and perform so
that's the job of a digital marketing
manager react according to
the performance of campaigns and
continue to grow and build out the
campaigns and channels and then with
that comes you know some side projects
and some issues that need to be resolved
and so a good digital marketing manager
has their pulse on everything related to
that particular digital marketing
channel for example a website okay if
the website's getting rebuilt or moving
to a new platform or being redesigned
digital marketing manager needs to be
part of that project and needs to be
able to help manage that project
alongside the channels and campaigns he
or she is responsible for so as you can
see a lot of responsibility
with a digital marketing manager so
with that responsibility comes
experience and so to jump into the deep
end on becoming a digital marketing
manager in my opinion you need to have
some experience maybe not across all
channels but at the very least some of
the most important channels we've talked
about already seo sem email
social uh email's been around a long
time seo is just so key it's the biggest
marketing channel out there your paid
search is very fast and dynamic involves
a lot of budget and management so you
need someone with experience and you
know someone with at least five years
experience in digital marketing or
advertising can fit the role of course
there's always going to be growth this
is digital marketing it's still young if
you compare digital marketing against
traditional platforms like tv or radio
or print we're only talking about 15 to
20 years of experience for digital
marketing out there as an advertising
platform so having five years out of 20
years of existence is not too bad
now with that comes a degree of some
sort with marketing okay so
you need to have at least a bachelor's a
master's degree really goes far because
usually those that contain a master's
degree usually has a have an mba or
masters of business administration and
to me that's a nice complement to having
a nice set of experience in digital
marketing and so it's also a plus to
really have some knowledge about social
media okay some of the best practices uh
that go with social media some of the
analytics that go with social media and
not just social media but in general too
so what are some digital marketing best
practices that you with your experience
can apply what's your knowledge of
websites do you have any programming
experience do you have any design
experience do you have any web analytics
experience okay having those skill sets
meaning understanding html or css or
javascript or being able to articulate
how a website is performing in google
analytics definitely complement the role
of a digital marketing manager in most
cases is part of the role of a digital
marketing manager and then one of the
biggest skills required i think every
company looks for this communication and
interpersonal skills so you have to be
able to communicate with your colleagues
with your stakeholders with your clients
with your contractors with anybody else
supporting your efforts or
the efforts you're supporting for
somebody else so communication is key
and today's world there's a lot of
communication tools out there i mean you
have traditional email you have text
messaging you have nice tools out there
like asana and slack to help you know
solidify the way communication is
streamlined and so you have to be able
to stay on top of communication because
you're going to be reporting up and
you're going to be reporting down to
you know those that are part of your
efforts and then a real big big bonus is
up to date with trends and technologies
and digital marketing so stay in the
know stay in the know attend conferences
attend webinars attending this webinar
definitely helps your positioning so
stay up to date and what i usually tell
you know other students
of mine is hey you know sign up for two
or three sources out there on the
internet it could be for example
google's webmaster blog or google
analytics video or youtube channel or
you subscribe to website magazine or
you know get an email subscription to
search engine land there's hundreds of
hundreds of thousands of resources out
there on the internet there's no excuse
not to stay up to date and then one
thing that's not listed here that i
would highly recommend is have a blog
having a blog offers up multiple
advantages one it promotes you as a
brand okay two whatever you're blogging
about and in this case it could be
something general like digital marketing
or could be a specific channel like seo
or could be analytically driven meaning
you know numbers and everything related
to digital marketing when it comes to
analytics whatever your niche is you
know write about it because it puts you
in a good position that one you're up to
date with the trends again you're
promoting your brand and two it shows
off your communication style so having a
blog whether you keep it updated once a
month twice a month four times a month
goes a long way versus not having a blog
at all because it shows you're
enthusiastic about the industry and the
job profession of digital marketing and
it really puts you in a good spot so
that's my recommendation there in
addition to all the skills required for
this position and you know salary
you know it depends it depends on
experience it depends on the company i
mean if you go with a non-profit versus
a poor for-profit company the pay might
be lower it depends on the company you
could go with a startup versus a more
traditional company and if the startup
they may pay more it really depends on
the company it really depends on the
industry the organization the experience
that you have the skill sets you bring
to the table all of that plays a role so
the salaries listed here are really just
averages
really it's averages because if you look
at 73 000 annually in the us okay if
you're you know get a nice digital
marketing job and say kansas 73 000 is a
lot of money
well it's all relevant because if you go
to california and san francisco 73 000
is not even the medium salary for
somebody who lives in san francisco so
it is contingent also on location so
what you need to do when it comes to
salary is take a look at your own
experience take a look at what you've
been paid previously if you have five
years experience and you're making 50
000 and you feel you've done a good job
and you've earned the skill sets and the
experience needed for the new position
you're applying for then there's no
reason why you can't ask for more money
than say the average okay so really a
lot of things are contingent on salary
but the one thing you can do to control
salary is make sure your skill sets are
in line with the job required so let's
move on to content strategist and
you know content strategist it's just a
title that we're using for this webinar
um there's a lot of job titles out there
the key thing here with a content
strategist is somebody who's involving
themselves with content so they're
developing content okay so you can call
it a content writer a copy writer a
strategist a developer content developer
the king of content the queen of content
it doesn't really matter what the title
is when you see the word content you
know that your job is to develop content
that caters to the company's objectives
and so with a lot of digital marketing
channels out there today okay content
strategists are in high demand very high
demand so
some of the responsibilities that go
with a content strategist is you want to
be able to manage the editorial calendar
to ensure timely publication and what do
i mean by that well as a content
strategist you could be asked to write
social post supporting a social media
manager okay so you want to be able to
come up with a calendar of sorts to be
able to post at a specific point in time
that's going to ensure high engagement
so having some sense of time definitely
goes along with the job okay you want to
identify gaps and content and recommend
new topics so for example a blog if
you're responsible for generating
content for the company's blog you
probably want to take a look at the
categories and the topics that have
already been written about and you want
to be able to identify new areas of
content that's just an example but you
want to do that across all channels okay
you want to be able to create brand
style guides if a brand doesn't have a
style guide already that's a place where
you can really shine okay because a
brand needs to have a certain tone a
certain message a certain point of view
okay it needs to stand for something and
a good content strategist is one who can
help create it help
implement it help enforce it okay so
brand styling goes a long way with the
job okay being able to not only ripe
proofread and edit pieces before
publishing them goes a long way too you
know some of the best content strategies
i've ever come across are ones that ask
me or colleague to proofread their own
content okay so
you know a good content strategist is
one that looks outward to make sure that
the copy or the content they're
producing is up to snuff it's aligned
with the brand it's articulate and is
centered and geared towards the intended
target audience so having somebody else
proofread to me says something about a
content strategist and vice versa being
able to proofread somebody else's work
to make sure yes what they're writing is
good solid grammatically written up the
brand intended for the right target
audience i mean so that's part of the
job being able to proofread and editing
okay another responsibility with a
content strategist is identifying
content topics based on keyword research
and this aligns with search okay so
with search engine optimization it's all
about keywords and you need to be able
to identify the content that goes along
with those keywords okay we talk about
this in depth on some of our other seo
webinars and i'll mention those in a
couple minutes but being able to
identify the content that aligns with
those keywords is really part of an seo
strategy and to me this next bullet
point really goes a long way you want to
be able to monitor web traffic and
engagement because if you're responsible
for the website if you're responsible
for producing content on a particular
website you want to see how that
content's performing so just because
you're a content strategist doesn't mean
necessarily you're not immune to looking
at data you are you everybody has a role
when it comes to the website everybody
should take a look at data and react
accordingly to the data including those
who produce content and then you want to
be able to coordinate with stakeholders
in the organization because the
stakeholders are the one who ones who
are going to have some say and what
content so just like a digital marketing
manager to me another piece of
responsibility is for the content
strategist to be able to communicate
with the stakeholders let them know hey
this is the content that's going out
this is our editorial calendar hey let
me proofread some of your content hey
this is the brand style okay so the
content strategist really is somebody
who's center in terms of all content
that's developed for a particular
organization now some of the skills
required to me you know you can have a
nice marketing degree or journalism or
literature anything that's going to have
some background in writing some
experience as a content strategist or
manager or in a similar role so you
could be a blog ambassador for another
brand and fill the role of a content
strategist you can be an influencer and
be somebody who really influences
different companies and industries that
job would be able to fit a content
strategist because most influencers
write or produce content so having a
basic understanding of html and web
publishing so you want to be able to
understand how the web works you know
you want to be able to understand what
it takes to create a web page because
every web page has content you need to
have experience with seo and you need to
have experience with keyword research
tools because to me a content strategist
is the one who drives this part of the
seo process to me the content strategist
looks at data when it comes to keyword
analysis is able to
aptly pick and choose keywords to align
with content and then write content not
just write content but optimize the
content for seo and then experience with
social media and not only just social
media but the different platforms out
there when i talk about understanding
social media for business and the
different platforms that can help a
business thrive in that channel you need
to understand you know the tended
audiences that go to that platform you
need to understand the formatting and
the opportunities for writing the
content on that platform you know
anybody can you know stroke a keyboard
and put words on a screen or break out a
pen and put words on paper but it really
takes someone with you know really fine
experience to really know who they're
writing for what platform they're
writing for
and the guidelines and the regulations
that go along with writing that content
so to me that separates out a good
content strategist from an average
content strategist and of course
excellent writing and editing skills go
a long way that comes with experience in
my opinion but what you could do if you
lack experience and editing is volunteer
for non-profit most non-profits have
blogs volunteer to write a blog post for
the nonprofit or if you don't even want
to go that route like a digital
marketing manager have your own blog if
you have a passion for food or passion
for travel or passion for animals or
pets or dogs write about it that's
what's going to give you the experience
and writing editing and it shows hey
look you're enthusiastic about something
and it shows your brand and your tone so
like a digital marketing manager having
a blog goes a long way if you don't have
your own blog then be able to gain the
experience necessary in writing and
editing by doing it for others even if
it means pro bono volunteer so salary
just like a digital marketing manager
commencement on
a lot of factors experience location
organization
you know the department of the
organization the type of organization
the industry i mean like i said with the
digital marketing manager position hey
if you're at a startup you and you're
applying for a content strategist role
chances are you're probably gonna ask
for more money than the average because
you're probably going to be writing
content not only for the website or the
blog not only for social but it could be
some offline opportunities as well
meaning press releases brochures tv ad
spots radio spots so you got to be open
as a content strategist especially when
you're working in a startup because
you're likely going to wear many hats
now if you're applying for a traditional
job at a company that's been around a
long time then your job may be really
focused and honed in on a specific you
know role so keep that in mind as well
so these salaries are average so a lot
of factors are involved so let's go into
seo so an seo specialist so it could be
an seo pundit an seo expert somebody
who's really familiar with the role and
the channel of seo so to me seo is a big
channel a lot of responsibility
so
scs specialists are responsible for
analyzing reviewing implementing not
just changes to the website but things
that happen off the website because with
seo seo is built into two branches or
two strategies off-page and on-page okay
so being an seo specialist you gotta be
able to hone in on what to do on your
own website for on-page seo but you
gotta be able to be savvy enough to put
together an off-page strategy and not
only that you got to be technically
savvy because a lot of what goes into
seo involves some technical aspects like
4-4 page load or site maps or css
or
you know accelerated mobile pages mobile
usability
structured snippets featured snippets
all of these are factors that are
related to seo so an seo specialist is
somebody who really is able to juggle
both the website from a technical
standpoint on page optimization and off
page optimization it's a big role and so
therefore if we break down the
responsibilities again it's reviewing
and analyzing the site for improvement
and optimization in other words somebody
needs to be savvy enough if they're
called an seo specialist to be able to
conduct an audit for an seo strategy and
be able to identify areas of improvement
so preparing strategy reports so what
does that mean well that can mean a lot
of things so when we talk about strategy
and reports you need to be savvy enough
to create a keyword analysis okay you
need to be savvy enough to be able to
assign keywords you need to be savvy
enough to even know how to optimize a
page yes you may have a content
strategist do that work but as an seo
specialist you need to be able to know
how to do that as well okay you need to
be able to identify keywords okay in a
keyword analysis just like a content
strategist you need to be able to assign
keywords and you need to be able to
write effective seo content not only for
the blog or website and social media but
it could be across other different
channels as well so being part of the
content is part of being an seo
specialist because if you work at a
startup you may not have a quote-unquote
content strategist to support you so you
may have to do everything you may have
to you know not only audit the site you
may not only have to address some of the
website needs from a technical
standpoint but you may have to do the
keyword analysis the keyword assignments
and optimize the content for seo and
then take it to off page you may have to
write the content
for off page seo meaning social or it
could be on other platforms like
wikipedia medium reddit quora okay so
all of these platforms require content
that are part of an seo strategy so
being able to you know prepare a
strategy being able to identify keywords
via keyword analysis being able to write
content that supports your seo strategy
are all part of the responsibilities of
an seo specialist and again part of that
strategy because it's on page and off
page is you need to be able to put
together an off page seo strategy and
that's going to again involve content so
before you start writing content for
various platforms you need to be able to
put in a sound strategy what platforms
are we going to go after you know what
are the domain and page authority of
those platforms how much content do we
need to write how often the frequency
what type of content are we going to
write all of that's part of a link
building off-page seo strategy and to me
one of the biggest responsibilities of
an seo specialist is being able to not
only analyze keywords and seo techniques
used by your competitors but just being
able to analyze and measure seo overall
yes you need to be able to look at what
your competitors are doing but you need
to be able to for example
leverage an seo platform
look at that seo platform understand how
your overall seo efforts are performing
and continue to make adjustments so
that's an seo specialist wrapped up
and if we look at some of the skills you
know you need to have some seo
experience not having seo experience and
applying for an seo job is really
selling yourself short because seo
involves some technical aspects some
creative aspects and some good sound
strategy along with a lot of analytics
so you need to be familiar with
analytics tools and other tools that are
going to measure the performance of your
seo strategy so
you need to be able to familiarize
yourself with some of the seo platforms
that are out there like moz or sem rush
because they produce analytic data as
well meaning ranking information or
domain and page authority you need to be
able to understand what those metrics
are and how to react to them you need to
be able to understand google analytics
from an organic search perspective you
know what are some of the kpis you're
aligning with organic search how are you
measuring organic search behavior from
an engagement standpoint or from a
conversion standpoint and because seo
has a technical aspect to it you need to
be able to understand you know the web
platform that you're on is it wordpress
okay how do plugins work do i have all
my plugins what theme am i using you
know what's the css of that theme so you
need to be able to understand all the
elements of your website that are going
to affect seo and so with that you need
to stay in the know you need to
understand all the different ranking
factors and how these different search
engines run in terms of their algorithms
you know the pundits say there are 200
plus different factors that affect
google's ranking algorithm so what are
those 200 ranking factors do you have a
certain knowledge set of how search
works okay do you know how the bots work
okay do you know the best practices for
site map okay so these are all the
things you need to know and all the
skills you need to obtain to be an seo
specialist and just like every position
we're gonna cover and we've covered
already you need to stay up to date with
the latest trends and practices because
seo changes frequently google changes
their algorithms and they change their
algorithms without even letting you know
so you need to stay up to date with what
google's doing okay or some of the other
search engines and so there's a lot of
different resources available you need
to be savvy enough to pick and choose
the resources that are going to keep you
up to date you need to know you know how
search console works i mean there's just
a lot of different factors involved with
seo it's a very well-rounded channel
with a lot of responsibility so you know
if you don't have the experience
necessary
well in my opinion you can come in
easily as a content strategist you can
come in as a web developer and be an seo
specialist because you're going to have
some working knowledge of you know how a
website works or how social or off-page
seo works but an seo specialist is one
who puts it all together and so to me
you know salary again
these are just averages and they do vary
okay whether you're in india usa europe
other parts of asia south america you
know salary is going to be contingent on
location it's going to be contingent on
your experience and the one thing here
to prove your experience and to prove
your worth in terms of salary is to be
able to show what you've done in the
past in terms of progress for another
client or another website so you need to
be able to be able to show
you know those who you're looking to
work for here's what i've done in the
past here's the methodology here are the
metrics i used to measure
here are some of the results of that
effort okay so you need to be able to
show you know some case studies best
practices and historical performance and
to me if you could show that then you're
worth every bit of the salary that that
particular company would offer up so
let's move on to sem specialists so seo
specialist a lot of factors involved
there off page on pitch sem is search
but it's a whole different set of skills
versus seo a whole different skill set
and why because an sem specialist it
could be an sem manager or whatever
again you want to call it but the
channel here is sem search engine
marketing and and really somebody who's
part of sem is going to be able to
manage paid search campaigns across
multiple channels across multiple
networks okay so may not even be just a
search network it could be the display
network okay so you need to know how
google and yahoo and bing and baidu and
linkedin and twitter all these paid
search platforms you need to know how
they work and be able to manage
campaigns effectively on those platforms
so some of the some of the
responsibilities now i will say this but
then s with sem it's very fast paced so
you need your responsibilities to keep
up with campaign performance and
some of the things you're going to do
some of the responsibilities you're
going to conduct while being by managing
campaigns are going to be testing a lot
of testing and a lot of analyzing data
okay so you need to be able to react to
the data you see okay so you need to
identify trends to achieve maximum
return on investment so in my opinion a
good sem specialist is one who
identifies their kpis beforehand and
then identifies the strategy beforehand
and then being able to execute that
strategy and then after executing that
strategy being able to optimize the
campaign so you're able to achieve
maximum performance and maximum results
that's really the job of an scm
specialist so you need to be able to
execute according to strategy you need
to be able to track and report on the
performance and not just track and
report but you need to be able to react
because with pay-per-click or cost per
click or sponsored search or search
engine marketing whatever you want to
call it it's going to be fast-paced
meaning you're going to get data and
you're going to get data very quickly
and so you have to be good at looking at
numbers and reacting to those numbers
and another
major responsibility is being able to
manage a budget if a client gives you
money you need to be able to manage that
budget accordingly first things first
you need to be able to plot a strategy
that's going to spend that budget wisely
and you need to be able to monitor and
maintain that budget so you don't
overspend the budget and not only just
overspend the budget but underspend the
budget so if a client hands you a
thousand dollars don't spend 500 of it
don't spend 1500 of it spend a thousand
look at the results along the way and
come back to the client tell them hey
here's the maximum results for that
thousand dollars and here's what i
recommend moving forward based on the
work and the optimization we've done
that's part of being an sem specialist
is being able to
manage and maintain the budget and
maximize your efforts for those paid
search campaigns while you're spending
that budget and some of the other
responsibilities with an sem specialist
is not just managing numbers and data
it's being able to write ad copy and not
only write a copy but know the different
guidelines and formats of these
different paid campaigns and platforms
because the guidelines for google are
going to be different from the
guidelines on facebook and so you need
to be able to also react to that ad copy
according to the platform and not only
the ad copy but the landing pages as
well you need to be able and be savvy
and technically savvy enough to be able
to set up unique landing pages for your
pay-per-click campaigns okay that's part
of an scm specialist leading the way on
creating landing pages and not just
creating landing pages but also doing a
b testing on those landing pages a good
sdn specialist with experience is going
to be able to
raise their hand and say look this
landing page is not performing let's put
an a b test in place so that we can
improve performance of a paid search
campaign so
one of the ultimate jobs of an sm
specialist is always always looking at
keywords being able to identify keywords
that are performing you know being savvy
enough to pause the keywords that are
not performing being able to optimize
keywords to gain better performance and
to expand the keyword list whether that
be in a different campaign or ad group
or you know ad set so identifying and
managing keywords is probably the number
one job of an scm specialist because
keywords are what drive a lot of paid
search especially on google yahoo and
bing so a lot of responsibility within
sem specialists you're giving the
responsibility of running a campaign
against a budget and you have to move at
a fast pace so it's not an easy role
it's not for the fainted heart you need
to be able to react to data at a very
fast pace and so what are some of the
skills required for job like this well
you need to have experience with search
engine marketing in general but it would
help to have experience across multiple
platforms i would even go as far as not
just saying yahoo and bing and google
but facebook linkedin
ad role and not only just google search
but you need to be able to show that you
can manage paid search campaigns across
google's display network meaning display
banners and even video campaigns on
youtube or remarketing campaigns or
shopping ad campaigns so you need to
have a well-rounded
view and well-rounded experience on how
search works and all the different types
of campaigns you can run on a search
platform you need to be well versed in
metrics paid search is about reacting to
data and performing the campaign at the
maximum so if you're managing a campaign
for an e-commerce website what are your
kpis what's your cost per acquisition
you know if i'm selling a t-shirt for
twenty dollars do i want my cost per
acquisition to be 25
no so you need to be able to understand
the different metrics and different kpis
align with a specific strategy or
website or business and you need to
manage against those metrics whether
that be cost per acquisition or
conversion rate or raw conversions you
need to be staying up to date with the
latest sem trends because paid search
especially on google they come out with
a lot of features and updates all the
time and you need to be able to know
what those updates are so you could take
advantage of them do you know that you
know google offers up responsive ads
okay do you know that they have
different ad extensions for say mobile
or location okay you need to stay up to
date with all the features on every
platform so you can maximize those
features for your clients again you need
to have strong analytical skills you
know if you're not good with numbers
then being an scm specialist is probably
not for you being comfortable with
numbers and being able to react to those
numbers that's a sign of a good strong
analytical skill set now sem involves a
lot of testing because a b testing and
pay-per-click go together because
pay-per-click's a controlled environment
so doing a b testing and being able to
identify a b testing not just for
landing pages but for ad copy so you
need to be able to
be familiar with how a b testing works
and being comfortable you know
identifying areas that need a b testing
coming up with variations coming up with
those kpis and then having a
well-rounded knowledge of how a website
works never hurts because you may be
tasked with setting up the a b test for
landing page so to me you know being an
scm specialist it's a cool cool job i
particularly like pay per click it's
very fast paced you get to react you get
to do a lot of different things here
across different platforms and to see
the fruits of your labor pay off for the
client meaning good campaign performance
is well worth the reward of being an scm
specialist and again you know we're
looking at 65 000 in the u.s and that's
contingent on experience and to me
i would probably go as far as saying you
know you need to have at least five
years experience as an sem specialist
and you need to be able to show a
well-rounded view of what you've managed
in the past so whether that be paid
search campaigns on google search
display
video shopping remarketing you know
social paid ads on different platforms
like linkedin twitter facebook you know
you could even do paid search on other
platforms or websites as well and even
understanding you know how adsense works
you know the other way around how a
publisher gets money because that's part
of the display network so looking at if
not from an advertiser point of view but
from a publisher standpoint so showing a
well-rounded knowledge of how paid
search works really goes a long way into
how much you actually make as an sem
specialist let's move over to social
media marketer so social media social
media marketers are in high demand
because a lot of companies are on social
media so social media marketers achieve
customer engagement intimacy they want
to drive website traffic they want to
convert that traffic to revenue okay so
they want to take advantage of all the
features available on that particular
social media platform and so some of the
responsibilities involved with being a
social media marketer involves you know
building and executing a strategy on
that particular social media strat
platform so you want to be able to look
at what your competitors are doing you
want to put in a good strategy and when
i say a good strategy that means
identifying what platforms identifying
the messaging okay is it going to be
brand or seo based or sales based okay
being able to build an audience on that
platform knowing who your target
audience is okay that's first and
foremost from a social media perspective
a good social media marketer needs to
know what they're getting themselves
involved with before they execute okay
and then once you are able to plan and
strategize
then comes the work you need to be able
to generate edit publish and share
content and the whole point here is it's
based on strategy so is it brand
awareness is it community building at
the end of the day you're going to want
to see some type of engagement or you're
going to want to be able to see
something in return for the content
you're posting so are you in for likes
or are you in for shares or are you in
for website traffic or are you in for
conversions okay so you need to be able
to manage that based on the content you
publish and so to me when you're talking
about content and you're talking about
social media you need to be able to lean
on a good social media platform there
are plenty out there like buffer or or
sprout social or hootsuite or later
there are plenty of social media
platforms out there and you need to
familiarize yourself and be able to
leverage that social media platform to
manage your content manage the data
you're seeing from the social media
platforms and then basically the whole
idea behind social is it's based on a
strategy so you need to be able to
improve that strategy by analyzing those
metrics insights and understand some of
the best practices in order to improve
so
it's a very broad sense of
responsibilities because it does depend
on the platform it does depend on the
business it does depend on your strategy
you could just be responsible for
twitter okay so twitter has you know
very limited number of characters
involved content but just because
there's not a lot of content doesn't
mean the strategy isn't as intense as it
would be on facebook or linkedin so you
need to be able to adjust and adapt to
the platform you're working on and so to
me some of the skills required you know
it helps to have an mba but i think it
definitely does help to have experience
as a social media marketer you know two
years is probably good enough experience
but in my opinion the more experience
you have and the more experience you
have across
multitude of platforms definitely says
something about your skill set so it
needs to cross over as well it needs to
cross over that skill set needs to cross
over into different marketing channels
for example paid search why because you
could be asked to write content for paid
ads on facebook it needs to be able to
cross over in seo why because you could
be asked to write content for off page
seo on a particular social media
platform it needs to be able to cross
over and say email because you could be
contributing to that email newsletter
that goes out that's pulling snippets of
content from your social work so you
need to familiarize yourself with how
different marketing channels work
because they overlap with social media
and then just like a content strategist
just like seo sem a digital marketing
manager you need to be able and be
comfortable going into google analytics
or your analytics platform you need to
be able to identify social as a channel
and be able to measure how that
particular channel is working and not
only how it's working in terms of your
kpis which could be engagement or
conversion based but you need to be
savvy enough to react to the data let's
just say you're not driving enough
traffic from facebook and facebook is
your primary social media platform what
are you going to do how are you going to
adjust that strategy to drive more
traffic so that's a good savvy social
media marketer somebody who's able to go
into an analytics platform and react to
the data they're seeing based on the
strategy that they're trying to
implement and then you know having
well-rounded experience with all the
different social networking and social
analytics tools definitely shows your
experience if you have one experience a
little experience with just one platform
like sprout social then get experience
jump into hootsuite or buffer or some of
these other platforms and know the
differences between them because
basically one social media platform may
not work for one company you may have to
lean on one or two based on the features
that they offer and you need to be savvy
enough to identify that so that you can
assist the organization you're working
for so that to me shows a lot of
maturity and experience knowing where to
go to maximize your efforts so social
media marketers they're in abundance but
they're in need okay so
you can really niche yourself a good
career whether that be at a startup or
whether it be in a traditional company
whether it be a non-profit or for-profit
whether that be in tech or real estate
or law or medical or insurance it
doesn't matter social media marketers
are in need but a good social media
marketer are those that take into
account the skills we talked about okay
let's turn our attention to email
marketing
so let's take a look at email marketing
here so email marketing has been around
a long time so email marketing
specialists if you will are those that
promote the organization organizations
product or services via email so the aim
is to really get those emails to work so
email marketing has been around
most people today have email addresses
are familiar with email marketing
because most organizations use email
marketing as a digital marketing channel
and so a good email marketing specialist
is responsible for the design and the
implementation of an email marketing
campaign and so to me they need to be
able to also
identify the platform that they're going
to be working with so if you're going to
implement an email marketing campaign
you need to be able to identify the
platform that you're going to work in
and there are plenty of email marketing
platforms and there are plenty of
marketing automation tools that offer up
email as a feature so you need to be
able to identify
not only a marketing automation platform
that works with your email marketing
strategy but a good email marketing
platform you know there's vertical
response there's mailchimp there's you
know a lot of different marketing plot
email marketing platforms out there so
try and test a few of them
and understand how they work just like
social media there's an abundance of
email marketing platforms so you need to
be able to identify one that's going to
align with the strategy and give you all
the features and benefits available and
you need to be able to identify your
target audience because you're not going
to send one email
to your entire audience list you're
going to need to be able to dissect that
entire audience list into different
segments and that's what a good email
marketing specialist does identify
different segments of audience you need
to be just like a content strategist
able to proofread copy in some cases you
may be writing that copy for the email
if you work at a startup and you don't
have a content strategist maybe you are
a content strategist who is also
assigned as an email marketing
specialist either way you need to be
able to
look at the copy that's in that email
and ask yourself you know is this copy
intended for target audience does it fit
our brand guidelines does it fit our
brand messaging do the call to actions
fit what we're trying to achieve you
know all that's part of an email
marketing specialist an email marketing
specialist is a good set of eyes and you
need to understand the technical aspects
of email because no longer are we
sending email to somebody on a computer
on a desktop who's downloading that
email onto say some software program
like outlook not today today most people
are
looking at email on the fly on the go
via mobile so we need to make sure that
emails you know fit our audience across
multiple devices so you need to be able
to ensure that
you know your emails are mobile friendly
because most people are looking at
emails on their mobile phones and timing
is everything with email
metrics just like any other channel is
important with email so you need to know
when you're going to be able to send
that email what time of day you're going
to be able to send that email and you
need to understand the campaign
performance why
so that you can respond and optimize the
email marketing efforts moving forward
and then another responsibility not
really listed here but it does go with
the job and that's a b testing so just
like an scm specialist you need to be
able to understand how a b testing works
why because you may not just be
optimizing landing pages for an a b test
you may be looking at an a b test for
subject lines in fact a good email
marketing specialist never sends out an
email without a b testing the subject
line and so you need to be familiar with
how a b testing works because that goes
along with improving campaign
performance and
knowing
industry policies and best practices
especially with email goes a long way
because there are a lot of regulations
involved around you know email and it
does come down to also the industry what
you could say and what you can't say by
industry does factor in so staying up to
date with industry policies and best
practices definitely is part of the
responsibility of an email marketing
specialist now
skills required
should have experience with email
marketing and to me i would take this a
step further you know having
well-rounded experience working for a
startup working for a larger company and
working for a company that has different
target audiences meaning segmented
audiences you can show that hey i know
how to send out an email to a large
number of people and they could be
subsets of a bigger audience and you
need to be able to show you know the
different styles and the different
platforms uh for email marketing that
you've worked with and a lot of email
requires html or knowledge of html so
you're gonna have to know html because
you may have to edit html you need to
know how utm tracking works okay urchin
tracking modules so if you don't know
what utm tracking is and you want to be
an email marketing specialist you need
to know what that is and get some
hands-on experience using utm tracking
because you need to track emails and if
you're using google analytics azure
analytics platform then you definitely
will need utm tracking because you need
to be able to be comfortable to go into
google analytics and look at your email
campaign performance does it align with
your kpis and you need to be able to
have some project management skills
because a lot goes into email marketing
you know it's the design of it it's the
timing of it it's the copy it's the a b
testing it's the analytical part if
you're working for a big company that
has 35 different target audiences you
could be sending out multiple emails on
a daily basis for different audiences
and so you need to be able to project
manage each of these email campaigns and
so those are the skills required for an
email marketing specialist and again
salary contingent upon experience the
more experience you have as an email
marketer the more you're gonna make and
experience to me is based on you know
how many email marketing platforms you
work with how many companies have you
done email marketing for how well
rounded have your emails been how many
target audiences how big have those
target audiences been do you understand
the concept of analytics and the concept
of a b testing so if you do and you
checked off all those boxes then you can
command more than what the average is
for an email marketing specialist so
let's take a look at a digital marketing
resume so
my recommendation and this is just my
opinion
would be to build your resume off a
platform like linkedin so if you're not
on linkedin then i would definitely
recommend you get on linkedin and if
you're going to be a social media
marketer then you definitely should be
on linkedin if you're going to be a
content strategy even digital marketing
manager you need to be on linkedin
linkedin is a business to business
platform so it allows you to put your
best foot forward in front of a lot of
people so not only those you connect
with but there's a lot of recruiters who
work on linkedin and these recruiters
are looking for people with experience
who fit the job they're trying to fill
and so to me
we look at a good resume you know
especially on linkedin linkedin allows
you to have a platform to put in all
your experience and so
you know depending on what you're trying
to go for i would niche towards that so
if you're going to be a digital
marketing manager then you could see in
this example two years experience with
content seo marketing automation email
sem and market research those are part
of the skill sets required for digital
marketing manager so you want to put in
a summary a good summary to include how
much experience you have and anything
that supports your claim to be a digital
marketing manager or an email marketing
manager or social media marketing
manager that's part of the summary and
then you want to put your experience in
there and to me putting your experience
in there is key i would include all your
experience everything you've ever done
geared towards the job you're going for
and to me
one thing about experience is when you
write out your experience put in what
your responsibilities were and then i
think what's key here in this example
you could see
this person had associate digital
marketing manager experience for one
year and what they did was they actually
showed the improvements they made as a
digital marketing manager so you can see
increased organic pages 30
with a reduction of bounce rates on
websites through site content management
and sem analysis so they actually put
some quantitative data in there to show
that hey this is what i've done
and this is what i've done to improve
this particular company's uh website and
so to me it's action oriented it shows
some quantitative analysis it shows
you've actually done work that made
improvement and it also shows that you
have command of analytics because every
job under the digital marketing realm
involves quantitative and analytical
data and so putting analytical data and
your resume
shows that you know what you're talking
about so here you can see
on the next example hey as a marketing
intern for nike you know one good year
here's all the tools i've worked with so
to me that's also a plus you want to
show again a lot of these positions
require knowledge of some of the most
common platforms okay whether that an
analytical platform an email marketing
platform an seo platform or social media
platform if you worked in that platform
put it down it shows that you're
well-rounded and so that's a good
suggestion to show hey you have
experience working with these platforms
and hey you have command of analytics
obviously putting your education down
there you know to me i'm not a recruiter
i don't think cpa is such a big deal to
me experience is more of a big deal and
then you definitely to support that
experience to show that you're in the
know the show that you stay up to date
that show
that you're up to date with the latest
trends and best practices i would
definitely put your certifications and
so if you're trying to be an sem
specialist or strategist then make sure
you have google ads certifications and
not just google ads but all facets of
google ads and what google ads has to
offer get your certification in mobile
get your certification and video get it
in shopping get it in display put those
notifications down there because it
shows you're well-rounded and regardless
of what position you're going for
whether it be content or email
go for the google analytics
certification all these certifications i
mentioned by google are free bing has
certifications facebook has
certifications get those certifications
and put them down there because again it
shows that you're in command of your
career it shows that you're up to date
with the latest and greatest it shows
that you know what you're talking about
because you've taken the initiative to
get a certification so to me these are
all the key ingredients to a good resume
you know niche it to what you're trying
to do write a good summary that supports
your effort you put your experience down
there but when you put your experience
support it with quantitative
measurements and metrics put down all
the experience you have with platforms
you know put some other
elements in there that are intangibles
like communication you show that you
know how to communicate hey we use slack
to communicate to a team of 100 across
five different countries as an example
because it shows that you have a grasp
of what it takes to communicate with a
team at large of course put your
education but more importantly get those
certifications put them down there
because it shows you know what you're
doing you're walking the walk not just
talking the talk so if you're interested
in a career in digital marketing and you
don't have the necessary experience and
say google analytics then take a look at
our google analytics tutorial for
beginners you know looking over the
webinar give you some more insight into
google analytics and propel you into
maybe taking the certification likewise
we have one for email marketing if
you're interested in being an email
marketer you know take a look at our
webinar and email marketing and then seo
if you don't have the necessary
experience and you're not sure of
everything involved in seo then take a
look at seo tutorial for beginners so we
have a lot more webinars available at
simplylearn so if you're lacking in one
area the other you know go to our
channel on youtube to fill in the gaps
of what you need to enhance your career
thank you for joining and today we're
going to cover digital marketing
interview questions and answers so
thanks for joining again and here's how
it's going to work so we broke out a few
questions and answers uh in different
categories a lot of you are going to be
interviewing for some jobs out there and
some of the jobs maybe an seo manager or
or search engine marketing manager or
email marketing manager or content
marketing manager or social media
manager so
we broke up those questions into those
areas and so that's what we're going to
do we're going to start with seo we're
going to go through some questions and
i'm going to explain the answers to
those questions so if you have any
questions to these questions or answers
feel free to just comment right below
this video and we'll get back to you as
soon as possible so let's get started
we're going to start with seo search
engine optimization we're going to go
through a series of questions and i'm
going to answer those questions for you
okay so the first question that you
might be asking an interview is
differentiate between do follows and no
follows okay so if you've taken or
listened to my seo courses on youtube
for seo we we talked a lot about do
follows and no follows and and simply
put i mean do follows are just signals
to the search engines to follow the link
so there's a link on site a pointing to
site b
we're gonna basically tell google bing
and some of these other search engines
hey go ahead and follow that link now i
know file's just the opposite so no
follow link doesn't allow the search
engine crawlers to follow it so if we
have a link on our site
site a pointing to site b
we can put a nofollow tag in there and
what that's going to do it's going to
signal to the crawlers hey don't follow
this link so
in the end if the crawlers don't follow
the link then there's not going to be
any link juice passed and so google is
not going to give you credit or give
that site credit for having a link
pointing to it or pointing to another
site or from another site and so it's
all about linking so we can control if
there's links on our site whether we
want the crawlers to recognize those or
not simply with no follow text so just a
reminder link jews is the reputation of
equity passed from one website to
another so if you have a link on another
website and that website is of high
quality meaning their page authority
their domain authority is high they have
a lot of content you know they're not
spammy they're really rich and they're
relevant then you may want to make sure
that the link pointing from that site to
your site is a nofollow so that way that
google can recognize the link from that
site to your site and basically that
reputation is gonna be passed on to you
okay so that's a do follow versus a
nofollow and why would we do a no follow
well it depends it really depends a lot
of social media platforms like facebook
have no follows if you have a lot of
content you may not want to be pushing
out a lot of do follows it could
actually look bad from an external
linking standpoint and so a lot of sites
are really particular about who they
want to pass link juice onto and give
credit for the link so it's a business
decision at the end of the day there's
really no hard fast rule here except
from an seo perspective if i have a site
and i have a lot of external links
pointing outward to other sites i'm
going to be particular about who i allow
the search engine to follow and what
links i allow not to follow so here's an
example of what they look like so do
follow is simply just the href notice
the nofollow has the the tag appended to
it the href tag with a nofollow so if
the search engine's crawling your site
and they see that no follow there
they're not going to follow that link
and vice versa if there's a link on
another site pointing to yours and
there's a no follow there you're not
going to get credit the search engines
aren't going to pick up that link okay
so question two what is 301 redirect and
how is it different from a 302 redirect
so
301 redirects tell users and the search
engines specifically that an original
page has been moved and this is the
keyword here permanently so permanently
moved we're going to explain that in a
minute so it's just moved from one page
to another and so if we
don't have a page anymore but we have a
new page let's just say you built a new
website with new urls you want to make
sure the old page is pointing to the new
page
with a 301 redirect so if a 301 redirect
is permanent then a 302 is temporary so
we want the search engines to
recognize that we have 301 permanent
redirects in place why because if we
have temporary then it might alert
google to
not keep that page in its search engine
rankings because it's temporary so why
would google want to keep a temporary
page or even a page that is pointing to
another page on a temporary basis so
they may remove both pages from its
index okay but if we have something
permanent in place google may say okay
this page is permanently linking to
another page or redirecting to another
page therefore it's stable it's
permanent we're going to keep that new
page in the index and eventually remove
the old page so really something
permanent is more stable in the eyes of
the search engine something temporary
may not be as stable in the eyes of say
google and if they don't see it as
stable then they may remove both pages
from the index okay so the idea is we
want to be found in google search index
and we get it sometimes pages go away
for a variety of reasons and if it does
go away just make sure you have a new
page for it and that new page is a 301
permanent redirect okay so question
three why are backlinks important in seo
well we kind of hinted on that a bit
with the nofollow because if we have a
link from another website pointing to
ours and that link from that other
website is really relevant and and it
has a high page and domain authority
then it's going to benefit us and so
backlinks are important because if we
have backlinks from quite quality sites
it's going to improve the credibility of
our site especially if it's a do follow
tag so the search engines are gonna
recognize the relationship between the
site that has a link pointing to us okay
so it's just gonna build our credibility
it's gonna increase increase our domain
authority and then the net effect of
that is if we're credible and we have
high domain authority then that's going
to increase the rankings of our pages
and when the pages increase in ranking
then we're going to get more of a lion's
share of the traffic for certain
keywords that our pages are found for
and if our pages are found and getting
traffic then because we have increased
rankings we're likely going to have
increased traffic and then it's just a
snowball effect so more traffic leads to
more engagement and conversions so the
whole idea for seo is remember you have
an on-page strategy and an off-page
strategy building external links is part
of an off-page seo strategy and we want
to make sure that you know we are
relevant in the form of a link or in the
form of content on other high quality
sites being on a high quality site only
benefits us because again increases our
domain authority google sees this is
more relevant therefore pages are going
to benefit by ranking higher and
therefore when we rank higher we get
more traffic so it's a snowball effect
so having backlinks is important because
it snowballs all the way through to
conversions okay so what are the best
practices to rank your videos on youtube
this is a great question really great
question given the importance of videos
especially with seo because videos are
found youtube in itself is a search
engine so if we have a video how are we
going to get it to rank on youtube well
first things first you never want to put
a video out there and want it to rank if
it's not engaging or informative so
make sure you go ahead and follow the
best practices of having engaging in
informative content in your video now
once you have that video in place you
want to optimize it and then some of the
key factors for optimizing the video are
you want to choose a title that has high
search volume and low difficulty just as
you would keyword for example for web
page you want to choose a title with a
keyword in it that has high volume and
low difficulty i.e low competition okay
so you want a nice ratio there and you
know what you want to choose a title
it's going to get people to watch the
video too so it's not all about just
choosing a title just for the sake of
high volume you also have to choose
something that's relevant that's going
to be catchy as well and then with that
title goes the description so you want a
description that's very relevant to your
title okay because most people aren't
going to click on a video just for the
sake of the title they're going to want
to probably get a sneak peek via the
description what it is so again you want
to optimize that description but make
sure the description is is just as
snazzy as the title okay you also want
to use accurate and relevant video tags
just as you would on twitter facebook
tag these videos okay so make sure your
title tag length doesn't exceed 100
characters because it will get chopped
off so again that goes back to just
writing something really
short and to the point that's going to
grab somebody's attention okay you also
want to upload a captivating thumbnail
something that's relevant that's going
to grab somebody's attention and then
again we set it similar to the video
tags we want to use relevant hashtags
again just as you would with twitter and
facebook go ahead and throw some
hashtags in there that people could see
because people search via hashtag and
then this goes about saying you did all
the work created a really great video
it's engaging it's informal you
optimized it feel free to promote your
video on other social media platforms
okay don't just stick with youtube per
se
so the benefit here is if you post it on
facebook or linkedin or whatever
platform of your choice and it gets
engagement people click on the link go
to youtube they're gonna like it and
then other people are gonna see that
engagement they're gonna see how many
people liked it or how many subscribers
you have so
promote your videos to help you with the
ranking of the video on youtube so that
does play into it so go ahead and
promote it so other people can watch it
like it comment etc and that's going to
engage other people to want to do the
same so what is mobile first indexing
this is a really important and timely
question mobile first indexing means
google's just using mobile friendly
content for indexing and ranking
websites so in other words google for
example has two bots they have the
traditional desktop bot and they have a
smartphone bot and eventually everybody
that has a website is going to be
migrated over to the smartphone bot and
so with that smartphone bot goes to your
website and starts crawling what do you
think they're looking for their
smartphone bot they're looking for
mobile friendly content if it's not
mobile friendly meaning the page isn't
designed for a smartphone browser or
let's just say the images are way too
large or you have to expand the text
just to read it you know a lot of these
these issues that somebody would have
just simply trying to read something on
a web page on their mobile device
google's not going to grab that content
so you want to make sure it's mobile
friendly so it gets indexed and so if
your website has a responsive design
google will rank your website based on
its performance on mobile devices okay
so you want to make sure that your
website is mobile friendly and if you're
in an interview and somebody asked this
question you could even take it a step
further and say look i'm going to
measure how friendly my my website is
for mobile devices in google search
console because google search console
has a report that will show you what
pages on your website are not mobile
friendly and it's not a guarantee but i
can tell you if i'm google and i'm
crawling your site with my smartphone
bop and that page or one of my pages is
not mobile friendly i'm probably not
going to index it or rank it so you want
to leverage that report in google search
console to see what pages are mobile
friendly so that's a little bonus for
you to really impress the interviewer
who asks you this question because how
are you going to know if one of your
pages is mobile friendly or not if you
don't look at a report so keep an eye on
google search consoles
mobile usability report okay number six
list down the most important local seo
ranking factors okay so
organic local ranking is just as
important as anything else in organic
search because if you have a local
business you want to use the likes of
say google my business to show up when
somebody types in you know looking for a
florist or
you're looking for a coffee shop so what
you want to do is you want to create a
web page for every product and service
okay you also want to opt for your
business listings on google my business
and and there are plenty of other local
business directories out there like yelp
for example or bing even has one so go
ahead and also make sure you have a
business listing as well but since
google in the united states has a huge
market share you want to start with
google first you want to update your nap
citations on your website maintain
consistency of your nap okay so nap is
name address phone number so
you want to make sure that that's
current and consistent so if you have a
number on your website make sure it's
the same number on google my business
okay you can embed a google map on your
website you could certainly optimize the
meta tags and content not only on your
web pages but within your google my
business directory so you can add your
business to other local directories like
i mentioned yelp and then also just as
important opt for reviews and ratings
okay so the more reviews the hat you
have the better off you are okay so i
always say this with the with local
search three of the main factors in
showing up for local search on say
google is obviously the key word the
second is the proximity of where that
person is and then third is the reviews
so you can't really control the
proximity but you can control the
keyword and you can control the reviews
to some degree so work hard at getting
reviews for your business but at the
same time you can certainly work in some
keywords let's just say for your product
and service pages on your website but
also you can translate that over to
google my business okay so working in
those keywords making sure your your
number your address your name they're
all consistent and and really just
spreading
your the the business out on other
directors that's really all these are
really key factors for local seo okay so
question number seven how to avoid
duplicate content getting penalized for
duplicate content so for example if you
have two different versions of a web
page you may result in a duplicate
content issue so it's just seo 101 you
never want to have two two or more pages
with the same content so what do we do
well we can avoid this in having google
penalize us by again setting up a 301
redirect remember three or ones are
permanent we can also use what they call
canonical tag and a canonical tag
basically alerts the search engines as
to which page is the original okay so if
we have an original page we want to
point to that page with our canonical
tag and then the third option is opt for
preferred domain in google search
console okay so if you have multiple no
names make sure you set up a primary one
in search console so those are ways to
work around it of this three i would
always go with the canonical tags
because that's just a tag that's gonna
sit on the page it's going to alert
google as to what the original is just
in case they get their hands on the
duplicate so all the pages that have the
same content are gonna have the same
canonical tag pointing to one page so
again three ones are permanent you can
simply just redirect one to the other if
you end up having duplication or you
could just tell the search engines hey
this is the original page or you can go
through search console okay number eight
what are the tactics to increase a web
page speed okay so what are some of the
tactics well when you build a site
especially for mobile you want to keep
it as simple as possible and what i mean
by simple as possible really i mean hey
use a simple website design don't get
overly creative if you will most
websites all websites have images you're
not going to be able to get around that
but just make sure you optimize your
images in other words don't have such a
large image size if you don't need
something very large don't have it okay
you want to improve server response time
what do we mean by that well your site's
sitting on a server somewhere you could
own that server or you can be renting it
out from say amazon web services or
let's just say godaddy as your register
they also have web hosting well if you
have it on say godaddy server you may be
sharing that server with other
businesses and at certain times of the
day other businesses may get a lot of
traffic and suck up a lot of bandwidth
what is that going to do that's going to
reduce the server response time for your
site and so you want to make sure you
have
an idea of you know what server your web
page your website is on and you want to
be able to can have some control over
that because if your server response is
slow that's going to slow down
everything else in terms of loading in
the browser and that's not going to be
good for seo okay optimize your code
what we mean by optimize mimifying when
we see mimifying we mean get rid of some
of the redundant code if you have css
you know get rid of chop some of the get
rid of the javascript you're not using
so that's what we mean by optimizing
code reduce redirects okay ideally you
just want to have one redirect in place
you don't want to create a daisy chain
so to speak of redirecting and
redirecting after that that's never
gonna bode well and it's gonna slow
things down as well enable browser
caching so if you enable browser caching
basically if somebody comes back to the
page they've been on say two days ago
they're probably going to see a cash
version of that page and then off for
the content delivery network as well so
these are some of the ways to reduce
page speed now if you're curious about
the page speed of your website you can
always go to google's page speed
insights tool and all you have to do is
just google page speed insights or even
just something generic like google page
speed and you're gonna get this tool
page speed insights and all you need to
do is just plug in a url when you plug
in the url google is going to analyze
the url for both mobile and desktop and
so here we could see google gives a
score so we could see the score from
mobile and we could see the score for
desktop just by clicking on desktop and
so here i could see
some of the issues that the site may be
having in terms of page load time for
their desktop if i flip over to mobile
you know here i can see some other
issues for example they have a server
static assets with efficient cash policy
now if you're not sure what the heck
that means you can always just click on
it and you can see some specifics here
anywhere you can just always google it
as well uh here you got the reduce the
impact of third-party code okay so
that's another thing uh reduced
javascript execution time so again going
back to a lot of some of the comments we
met about coding okay so sometimes too
much code or code not functioning as
well as it should will tend to slow down
the site okay so you can use pagespeed
insights you can always get a glimpse of
how pages are loading simply by also
going to for example google analytics
under behavior okay you can go to site
speed and if you click on overview okay
google what google does is they do a
sampling of pages over time and in this
case based on 89 page views they have an
average page load time and so you can
get a sense of how quick specific pages
load your site overall simply by looking
at the site speed overview report in
google analytics to get a sense of
how quick your pages are loading now
there are certain factors that do affect
load time so obviously the way the page
is built with the code the images etc
but also the browser each browser loads
differently okay so you want to take a
look at it by browser also by country
every country has a different network
you can be
in the united states and have worse
network service than you do say in
you know
ivory coast in africa okay so it really
depends on the network you're on so and
also the page every page is built
differently so you want to get a sense
of what pages are loading quicker and
which pages are not you can simply just
go to page timings and google analytics
you get a sense of what pages do not
load fast which ones do and maybe hone
in on the pages that aren't loading fast
and address those pages first okay so
you have two tools at your disposal one
google analytics and one page speed
insights okay so let's look at question
number nine here so when should an
individual target short tail and long
tail keywords okay so
remember short tail are usually one to
two keywords very broad in nature long
tail keywords maybe three four keywords
in a query or maybe an entire sentence
those are considered long tail keywords
so usually short tail keywords have
higher volume but also higher
competition longer tail keywords usually
have lower
volume but also lower competition but
the great thing about long tail keywords
the conversion rate will tend to be a
little bit higher than say a short tail
because it's less vague and more
specific so you can use short tail
keywords if you're trying to drive a lot
of visitors because those keywords are
going to be vague or broad in nature
long tail keywords are used for targeted
pages such as product pages and articles
so if you have a specific product with a
long name you can certainly optimize
that page for that product name again
the product name may have low volume but
if somebody types in exactly that
product name you show up the chance of
you them converting are going to be very
high so you don't have to always be that
specific with the product name but try
and be as specific as you possibly can
in order to get somebody to click on
your link in the search engine results
and get them over to your site to
convert okay so those are really the big
differences short tail very broad very
vague a lot of volume but also a lot of
competition but hey if you're ranking
for short tail keyword you're probably
going to get a lot of traffic the
conversion rates may not be as high as
something say long tail where hey maybe
you're just honed in on a few set number
of products and you're not care you
don't care a lot about the traffic you
just care about getting the relevant
traffic to your site to convert okay
number 10 what are the important
elements to focus while developing a
website so we're talking in terms of seo
okay so if somebody asks me this
question in an interview what am i going
to focus on when developing a website
well the answers are right here yes we
talked about mobile mobile is so
important because a lot of websites are
going to be
indexed with google smartphone bot so
mobile usability is very important so we
need to make sure our website is
responsive for mobile just some basic
practices when it comes to site
architecture and navigation we want to
have a simple url structure okay no
overly cumbersome the navigation should
simply be clean and need okay if you
have five products okay maybe
you have uh in your navigation you have
something called products with all five
listed or you have all five products in
the main navigation the key is you just
wanna make it clean and neat and easy
for somebody to find the the rule of
thumb is if it's good for the end user
probably going to be good for google but
if complicated for the end user it's
probably going to be complicated for
google you always want to create a
sitemap now what is that sitemap a
sitemap is simply just a formatted file
with to that includes all your urls and
assets your images and your videos
they're going to be sitting on your
server as well so you want google or
these these bots to be able to find your
pages and assets and by the way you want
to take it a step further and make sure
you upload that site map which is
sitting in the root directory meaning
domain.com
sitemap.xml
okay you want to take that sitemap and
make sure you input that sitemap
location in google search console that
way google search console has a one-way
ticket to grab the elements in the
sitemap another important element to
focus on while developing a website is
having a robot's text file and all a
robot's text file is it's like a lock i
always say to a house so if you lock a
door in your house nobody's gonna be
able to get in that door so it's all a
robot's text file is you're telling
google and these other bots that are
coming across your site what's locked
and what's not logged meaning what they
have access to what they don't have
access to so you want to be able to make
sure you have a robot's text file if
you're trying to
not index specific pages of your website
because if you tell google don't crawl
these pages or this directory they're
not going to get crawled if they don't
get crawled they're not going to get
indexed so robot's text file is an
important element to focus on while
you're developing your website and while
you're developing your website it could
be on a you know in a directory just
called new website so you probably want
to have new website as the directory in
the robots text file and just to let
google know don't go into this directory
because it's my new website i'm not
ready to go live yet so you don't want
it indexed so
there's a lot of reasons to have robots
text files that's the main reason
sitemap you want google to get these
pages and assets quickly okay you white
to make sure that your site architecture
navigation is in order you want to make
sure your site is mobile friendly and
you also want to make sure you have
content on your website that's the key
because that's what's going to keep
people on the website and engaged and
when i say content i don't necessarily
just mean words i also mean videos i
also mean images you know something
interactive okay you want to keep people
engaged that's the key behind it trust
me if an end user finds your site
engaging google is likely going to find
your site engaging okay so those are
good brownie points to bring up if
somebody asks you this question in an
interview so just to recap here it's
important to have a better site
structure so the bots can easily access
and mix the content okay with a
responsive design helps to make your
website mobile friendly and user
friendly would also increase the amount
of time a user spends on your website
which may improve your site's ranking
sitemap is simply just a file that helps
search engine bots to understand the
structure of the website okay how many
pages are on your website and where are
they located along with the videos and
images okay and then the robot's text
just instructs the search engine
crawlers to understand what pages should
not be indexed okay this is simply just
a text file and it's added to the root
directory again think like a door think
of a lock okay you can tell you can lock
whatever doors you want in your house
then give it that way okay so those are
our questions for seo again if you have
any additional questions or if there are
other questions maybe you've been asked
in an seo interview then go ahead and
add them to the comments section below
we'd love to hear from you now we're
going to turn our attention to search
engine marketing so let's turn our full
attention to search engine marketing so
we're moving away from seo and over to
pay per click and so you really have to
know your stuff here you really do uh so
a lot of the questions we're gonna ask
gonna be centered around google ads
formerly known as google ads words and
so if you're familiar with google ads
the platform then you should have no
problems whatsoever answering these
questions but that's why we're here and
that's why you're watching so
there's anything you want to add to any
of these questions as a reminder feel
free to comment under the video and so
right out of the gate question 11 what
is ad scheduling so ad scheduling is a
feature in google ads and really all it
does is allow you the advertiser to set
up certain hours or days you want your
ads to shout it's as simple as that so
if you have a customer that you're
running
ads for on google search and
let's just say they have a restaurant
and they're closed during certain hours
of the week then you can go into the ad
scheduler and schedule your ads to not
show when they're closed as an example
okay because if somebody calls and
they're not there to answer the phone
then it's not going to be good for the
restaurant or you the advertiser and so
that's why they have the ad scheduling
so it ensures your ads are not running
when they're performing poorly let's
just say
you know you're running a business and
you just don't get that much traffic
during the weekends well you can go in
and adjust accordingly it also there to
make sure you could serve your customers
when you do have limited client service
hours so let's just say you have a
customer service team that's going to
answer phones for a couple hours a day
well again you can schedule your ads to
show during those couple of hours a day
and then really what it comes down to is
you're making sure you can satisfy
customer demand and supply and so that
means showing your ads when you you can
best fulfill the customer's needs okay
and so that's really what it's all about
uh and that's what ad scheduling is so
take advantage of ad scheduling schedule
it according to the business hours
schedule according to how they can best
serve the customer schedule the ads when
it's performing best and don't schedule
the ads when you know you're gonna have
poor performance okay so next question
what are the different ad formats
available on google ads it's a trick
question because it really does come
down to what network you're advertising
on so google has two networks the search
network and the display network okay so
on the search network there's only one
ad format and that's text okay so google
recently
changed the format of the text ads now
they're called expanded text ads so here
you can see you can have up to three
headlines and two description lines and
then you can also have ad extensions and
so you can see here underneath the ad
you have what they call site links so
shop by category in here headphones on
ear headphones those are all site links
to specific pages on the site so
text ads are available only on the
search network but they're also
available on the display network as well
then you have responsive display ads now
responsive responsive display ads are
only on google's display network okay so
here you could see
some samples of responsive display ads
and these ads adjust their size and
format depending on the space available
so again you could have text ads or you
can have display ads now display ads
again come in different sizes so you can
create ads for a variety of different
sizes for example 250 by 250 or 468 by
60. so those are some of the different
ad types there's there's an a plethora
of different ad sizes you can choose
however your ads not going to show on a
website if they don't have that
particular size available so it's always
best practice to create different ads
but create ads in different sizes as
well okay and then have a backup text ad
as well just in case the site doesn't
even display a display ad for you or
serve up a display ad so you can have a
text ad as a backup okay so lots of
different ad sizes but this is the
second ad format that's responsive
display and again the responsive part is
google will automatically
show the ad that's best performing based
on a series of headlines descriptions
and images that use you provide google
and so the responsive part is hey if
this combination of headline description
and image work best meaning it has the
best click-through rate then google's
going to serve up that ad so that's why
they call it responsive so
obviously gonna have just an image ad
that's not responsive again across
different ad sizes you know they could
be again 250 by 250 300 by 300 468x6
there's a number of different sizes
google can provide you that information
but the one thing to note here is that
when you do create an image ad it could
be
jpeg it could be
interactive or it could be static so
different types of image ad formats like
png for example or it could be a static
or it could be interactive so
definitely take advantage of the
different opportunities uh meaning a
static ad versus an interactive ad you
might want to have two variations of
that so you could see which one works
best okay there's also app promotion ads
so these ads are used to drive app
downloads so you're gonna have to set up
a campaign accordingly okay but here you
can see this is what it looks like with
the call to action so it allows you to
go ahead and click and install that app
so that's an app promotion again if you
have an app and you want to promote it
you can use this type of ad format to
align with a campaign that's driving
traffic to download your app okay and of
course you have video ads well google
owns youtube and so if you have videos
you have the opportunity to advertise on
youtube okay so these ads can be
standalone or inserted into other
streaming video content and so to me
video ads work well with specific
strategies and what's one strategy you
would use a video ad for brand awareness
or education explainer videos and so
youtube allows you the advertiser the
opportunity to get your ad your service
your product in front of a lot of
eyeballs so that's the beauty of video
ads they attract a lot of eyeballs and
definitely help with the strategy of say
brand awareness okay another ad format
going back to the search network is
shopping ads so if you sell shoes then
you may want to think about having a
campaign for shopping so shopping ads
work with google merchants so google
merchant is another google product and
basically google merchant allows you to
manage your inventory so if you have a
hundred different types of shoes that
you're selling you can upload your
inventory to google merchant connects
and talks to google ads so basically
what you're doing you're setting up your
your campaign and google ads and
connecting your inventory from google
merchant to google ads and so the great
thing about the shopping campaign is it
puts your products front and center it
puts the price it puts any promotion
that you have and it puts the brand all
front and center so when somebody does
type in let's just say lime green
sneakers or women's sneakers and this
particular shoe shows up here the third
one from the left then somebody's gonna
see it's from the united colors of
benaton it's a woman's shoe it's on
amazon and it costs 45
so the great thing about shopping ads is
if somebody's interested they're gonna
click okay if somebody's not interested
say well you know it's a little bit more
expensive i can get something similar
another shoe on amazon for less okay
they're probably gonna click on that
particular app so again the great thing
about shopping ads put your product
front and center with any promotion the
price the brand so if somebody clicks on
it then they're probably serious buyers
okay so that's the beauty of shopping
ads it allows you to get your product
out there and on the search network it's
a cost per click so you're only paying
for the click so if somebody looks at it
but doesn't click you're not paying for
that so that's the beauty of shopping
ads and so
you can showcase your shopping ads so
these ads have an image and a
description that expand when clicked so
you can provide more information more
product and store information as well
you also have call only ads okay so call
only ads are enabled to users to connect
with your business directly using the
phone number provided okay so it allows
somebody on a mobile phone who in this
example is searching for drywall repair
well if you're in the business of
drywall repair you can have your ad show
up on mobile with the phone number and
somebody can easily click on that phone
number and just call you directly now
the way
call only ads work is you're still
getting charged for the click okay so
anytime somebody clicks and calls you're
going to get charged and you're going to
get charged just as you would if
somebody clicked on your ad so it works
the same way so it's a cost per click
again this is on search so search is
cost per click and the beauty about call
only is again you can track the calls
riding google ads so you can have google
ads track how many people click on the
number and you can even count those
calls as conversions if they meet a
certain criteria for example the
criteria is somebody
talks to you for a minimum of 60 seconds
or one minute then google will count
that as a conversion so you can monitor
calls right in google ads and it's a
cost per click model so you can actually
see what the average cost per click is
so moving on question 13. okay what is
rlsa and how does it work well rlsa
stands for remarketing list for search
ads so if you're familiar with
remarketing on display it's similar they
just call it rlsa okay so it enables you
the advertiser to customize your ads for
people who have visited your site just
like a typical remarketing campaign okay
so you could tailor your bids and ads to
these visitors when they're searching on
google and search partner sites okay so
they're two basic strategies for using
rlsa okay so you can optimize bids for
existing keywords for visitors or you
can bid on keywords that you don't
normally bid on just for people who
recently visited your site or converted
on your site the key here is you're the
one that's picking the customer you're
the one that's enabling the list if
you're trying to target people who went
to your site and didn't convert well you
could certainly optimize your bids for
existing keywords for people who went to
your site and didn't convert or you
could set up a whole new campaign for
rllsa
and have a different set of keywords
with a different ad because you know who
you're talking to you're talking to
somebody who's already been to your site
they know your brand they just didn't
purchase and so this all happens on the
search network and that's the beauty of
remarketing is one you know who your
audience is because you're the one
establishing that audience and two
you're the one creating the ad so you
can talk directly to that audience when
they see your ad again in this case on
search so that's rlsa remarketing list
for search ads i recommend pretty much
any industry any client any customer run
remarketing list for search advertising
and remarketing for display so those are
two key campaigns you should always
recommend running to a client because
one again you're defining the audience
two
you're the one that's talking directly
to youngs because you know who the
audience is and three if they see the ad
and they click on it again because it's
cost per click then the chances of
converting are going to be higher
because they've already been your
website they know who you are and so if
they click on your ad again then they
must be interested so those are all the
benefits of running an rlsa campaign
okay so number 14 what types of
audiences can be used in gdn google's
display network so a lot of different
audiences here okay so let's go through
them so you have affinity audiences so
basically affinity audiences are
basically
what are people's interests and habits
what do they have an affinity for are
there food sites travel sites shopping
sites fashion okay so that's what
affinity really relates to okay then you
have in-market custom intent life events
these are what they're researching or
planning for so again it could be travel
it can be finance etc okay you have
remarketing we just went over that with
remarketing list for search advertising
rlsa and so with the remarketing it's an
audience that has interacted with your
website so they either came from mobile
or came from mobile and didn't convert
or female came from mobile and didn't
convert so you're the one defining the
audience there you also have a similar
audience so this is what google creates
on your behalf so these are users with a
similar interest to your site visitors
so google is monitoring the type of
traffic that's coming to your site and
based on that traffic they're going to
create a similar audience and then you
have a custom match so what you know
about your customers activities
basically so these are all the different
audience types and you can see the
different types of ads available okay so
notice the far right column video ads so
video ads are available to every one of
these audience types why because youtube
so google knows what people's interests
and habits are based on the videos they
watch they know what they're looking for
okay they
you know that they've been to your
website because they're cooking so you
can remarket them okay so video ads are
very powerful tool for any one of these
audience types so next question what are
the types of keyword matching available
in google ads okay so this is a good
question
very important if you're going to manage
a google ads account and a campaign you
have to be aware of the different match
types you can't just go broad match
that's a sign of somebody who doesn't
know what they're doing is by bidding on
a one keyword phrase that's a short tail
keyword if you think back to seo we have
our long tail and our short tail
keywords the worst thing you could do is
bid on a keyword short tail keyword
that's broad match because what is broad
match basically broad match are keywords
that appear when a user searches any
word in the phrase now you can define
specifically
what you want your ads to appear for in
terms of keywords and when i say
specifically you can use a phrase match
so phrase match are ads that appear only
when a user searches for that exact
keyword phrase in the precise order but
with some additional words in the
beginning or at the end of the query
okay so usually these are sentences so
you could be you know bidding on
red adidas running shoes and somebody
could type in looking for red adidas
running shoes in portland oregon okay as
an example okay so as long as red adidas
running shoes are in order in that
keyword phrase then your ad is going to
appear because it's a phrase match and
then you can get really specific by
doing an exact match so exact match are
keywords that are triggered only when
that keyword and exactly that keyword
phrase is queried so if you do an exact
match for
red adidas running shoes and somebody
types in only red adidas running shoes
then that's an exact match and your ads
going to appear so let's take a look at
these again so you got broad match okay
we got a term cheap smartphone so if
somebody types in smartphone cheap phone
smart mobile phone cheap any one of
those combinations your ads going to
appear now there's one thing you can do
for broad match and it's called broad
match modifier so you could put a plus
sign in front of the keyword for example
let's just say you really want to
emphasize the word cheap okay you're
selling really inexpensive smartphones
okay not just any smartphone but an
inexpensive smartphone so you can put a
plus sign in front of cheat and so
somebody puts in you know just
smartphone or smart mobile your ads not
going to show up because the word the
keyword query has to contain sheep so
anytime you put a plus in front of the
keyword query you're bidding on then
that means that keyword has to be part
of the keyword phrase so that's a a
broad match modifier if you will and
that prevents you from getting unwanted
impressions so we have phrase match
again blue smartphone so somebody could
type in smartphone in blue color cheap
blue smartphone notice though the second
one where it says smartphone and blue
color your ads not necessarily going to
show up because guess what blue
smartphone is the keyword query and
you're at your the query here is not in
that order so remember in order for you
to show up for phrase match the keyword
has to be in that order so i'm looking
for a blue smartphone
that is less than 100
okay that could be somebody's query blue
smartphone was in that query in that
order so if somebody says looking for a
smartphone that happens to be blue less
than a hundred dollars then your ad is
not going to show up so remember it has
to be in that ex precise order one thing
i want to go back to on the phrase match
notice that there's quotes around the
keyword anytime you see quotes around
the keyword that signifies it's a phrase
match because if we look at exact match
notice there are brackets around the
keyword red shoe that signifies is an
exact match so if you put brackets
around a keyword then you're signifying
signaling to google that this is an
exact match and i only want to show up
for the keyword red shoe well the only
option that will work here is the second
one red shoes okay so because that's an
exact match okay so disregard the first
and the third one because shoe and red
color is not going to work and footwear
that's red is not going to work because
this is an exact match so you're saying
i only want to show up for the keyword
red shoe and google recognizes plurals
and singulars together so somebody did
type in red shoes then your ad is going
to show up okay so moving on what are
some of the reasons as to why your ads
could have been rejected it happens to
the best of us if you're writing ads and
they get rejected it could be for a
number of reasons so at the end of the
day you're violating google's
advertising policies so
some of the policies that could have
been violated are and just some of the
many we're just listing some here
prohibited content prohibited practices
restricted content or editorial
technical so when you look at prohibited
content i will say this you're not going
to be able to sell drugs even if you're
selling
pharmaceutical products that's
considered drugs and that's going to be
prohibited or prohibited practices like
selling drugs online that's illegal in
the state so you're going to definitely
get flagged for that okay so there are a
lot of different ways in which your ads
can be disapproved okay
but if you do see restricted content
then that means you can advertise but
with limitations and usually those
limitations are restricted to say only
google search and not google search
partners or to a specific geography so
usually the key here is if somebody asks
this question okay there are a lot of
different reasons google is usually
going to provide the specific or the
reason why it got disapproved and
they're usually going to include a link
that you can refer to okay so at least
google does that much they're not going
to leave you in the dark and tell your
ads just been disapproved they're going
to tell you why and include a link that
you can go to figure out how you can
best resolve the disapproved ad so what
are the different kinds of bidding
available in google ads so we already
covered part of this earlier on so
remember google search network is only
cost per click cpc when we talk about
google's display network you have three
options cost per click cost per view and
cost per impression and cpm is cost per
1000 impressions so you're paying per
1000 impressions impression is when
somebody actually sees your ad cost per
view
is actually somebody looking at your ad
for at least 30 seconds or the entirety
of the ad so if the ad video ad only
runs 15 seconds and somebody watched the
entirety then you're going to pay per
cost per view so if your video is two
minutes long and somebody watched 30
seconds you're gonna pay cost per view
okay so again let's go through these
cost per click it just enables you to
set up a maximum price on the cost of
somebody clicking on your advertisement
you only pay when somebody clicks on
your ad okay cost per view again this is
the default method to set the price
you'll pay for your video ads okay you
only pay when a viewer watches your
video advertisement for at least 30
seconds and then cost per 1000
impressions so this is the amount you
pay each time your ad is displayed in
the search network and you pay for
impressions that are in generated for
your ad and you're paying for every 1
000 impressions so the m is actually the
normal
roman numeral for 1000 so that's where
the m part comes in so you're paying for
1 000 impressions so every 1 000
eyeballs you're going to pay a price and
so cost per impression is good for brand
awareness if you're trying to generate a
lot of eyeballs onto your brand then
you'd want to go with a cpm model okay
so question 18 what are some automatic
bidding strategies so let's define
automatic bidding strategy automatic
bidding allows google take over okay not
you google's taking over and they're the
ones setting the bid amounts
automatically and it's gonna be based on
criteria and some of that criteria is
going to be centered around conversions
so if google bids on your behalf
automatically basically what they're
doing is they're collecting data on the
behavior of your ads and so if your ad
is likely to get the click or conversion
then google is going to set the bid
amount so you can win that auction in
order to get the click or the conversion
so
there are different types of bidding
strategies but remember you have to
align a bidding strategy with the
strategy of the campaign so for example
if your goal of the campaign is to
increase site visitors you just want
people to click on your ad and go to
your website then you're going to have
an automated bidding strategy of
maximized clicks that aligns with your
campaign strategy so this strategy
automatically sets your bids to help to
get as many clicks as possible within
your budget so google is going to do its
best based on historical performance of
the campaign to generate traffic to your
site that's the goal that's the biz
strategy okay let's take a look at some
others so
hey the goal of our strategy campaign is
to increase visibility so that's an easy
one remember cost per impressions hey we
want to maximize how many people look at
our ads okay so target impression share
so this bidding strategy allows your
bids to show at the top of the page okay
so you're getting the impression so
people are able to look at your ad okay
so you're telling google hey i want to
be shown at least 50 of the time when
somebody types in a keyword that i'm
bidding on so they're gonna make sure
that they meet your target impression
share 50 so they're going to set your
bids automatically to make sure your ad
shows at the top of the page so it's
seen at least 50 percent of the time
that's the goal of the campaign that's
the bidding strategy goal we set up a
campaign to drive conversions so there
are a couple bidding strategies against
conversions so target cpa so this
strategy sets a search or display bid to
get as many conversions as possible but
there's a caveat here cost per
acquisition is what cpa stands for so
we're trying to get as many conversions
as possible but at a certain cost for
example if i'm selling t-shirts for ten
dollars do i want to pay twenty dollars
cpa for every sale do i want to pay
google twenty dollars now i'd be losing
money i'd be out of business okay so if
i'm selling t-shirts for ten dollars on
my website i'm probably gonna put the
cpa about two dollars or three dollars
again depending on my cost of goods so
if i factor in my cost of goods i'm
trying to make a profit then i'm going
to tell google look i'm trying to get
some sales but i don't want to lose
money getting the sale so you're going
to put in a threshold and that threshold
is your target cpa
and so google is going to automatically
bid and win the auction for keywords
when they feel those keywords can get
you a target cpa that you put in for
example two dollars okay so the goal of
our campaign is to meet a target return
on ad spend meaning return on
advertising spend meaning we're getting
more revenue than we're spending that
ratio needs to be positive so google's
gonna help us again adjust our bids to
make sure that our return on advertising
spend meets our criteria so we could put
a
roas as 100 200 etc and google's going
to adjust our bids accordingly based on
the keyword that they think will meet
that criteria of a hundred percent or
200 percent so that's target return on
advertising spend and that's there to
see if google can help you generate a
profit so we have another campaign set
up we're trying to get more conversions
we have a budget we want to spend the
budget but we all we want to get
conversions so this is a giving the
bidding strategy here would be maximized
conversions so this strategy sets bids
like all the others it automatically is
going to adjust your bid that is google
it's going to adjust the bid to help you
win the auction based on historical
performance so if a keyword and
historically has performed in terms of
conversions you better believe google is
going to try and win the auction on your
behalf to get the click to get that
conversion and that's maximize
conversions okay moving on question 19
and this is probably the most important
question that you're going to get if an
interview asks you this question this is
what google ads is all about quality
score so what is quality score so simply
put quality score is a score between 1
and 10. given every keyword you've been
on and basically between one and ten
it's based google's giving you the score
the quality score of that keyword and so
how does google come up with that score
between one and ten well there's three
main factors here one is expected
click-through rate the second is ad
relevance and the third is landing page
experience so obviously a higher quality
score the better off you are okay a low
quality score it's not going to bode
well for you and so if you have a low
quality score google actually
will tell you
which of these three components you're
not scoring very well on so you're
either going to get a below average
average or above average for each of
these three components that make up
quality score and i will tell you this
if i were to divide them up into thirds
click-through rate expected
click-through rate is more important
than the other two so that's about
two-thirds of quality score and expected
click-through rate is basically google
saying look other advertisers have bid
on this keyword and their click-through
rate has been historically around say
for example three percent so if you
can't get three percent then your
quality score is going to suffer ad
relevance is simply does the ad or is
the ad relevant to the keyword you're
bidding on likewise for the landing page
but the landing page experience a little
bit more subjective because the landing
page has to load well fast no pop-ups no
a lot of external links nothing spammy
no ads being served up so a lot of
factors in landing page experience
google wants to make sure somebody
clicks on your ad that they're going to
have a good experience when they land on
that page and so quality score is so key
here it is very key because if you don't
have a good quality score the
repercussion means you're going to have
to bid higher because quality score
times bid
equals ad rank so for every auction
whoever has the highest ad rank is gonna
be at the top of google search results
so if you have a low quality score let's
just say one and you're bidding four
dollars on that keyword then your ad
rank is four one times four is four so
you gotta keep that in mind because
other advertisers could have a higher ad
rank or better quality scores for that
keyword so again expected click rate
this just shows how likely it is that
your ads will get clicked when shown for
a particular keyword google expects a
certain number here you should always
try to achieve the highest click-through
rate possible and click-through rate is
simply how many times your ad was seen
versus how many times it was clicked
that's all click-through rate is clicks
divided by impressions so you should
always try to achieve the highest
click-through rate possible that will
avoid getting a low quality score add
relevance so add relevance simply means
how relevant is your keyword to the ad
okay so if you're bidding on red adidas
running shoes then make sure your ad
discusses and mentions multiple times
naturally red adidas running shoes okay
and remember with those text ads you
have three headlines you have two
description lines of up to 90 characters
you have side extensions okay you have
path one and path two that meaning you
can add additional keywords to the end
of a url so you have lots of
opportunities to make sure the ad is
relevant to the keyword and then landing
page experience again this is a little
subjective but hey google is going to
use landing page experience to estimate
how relevant and useful your website's
landing page will be to people who not
only click on your web but land on that
page so does that page load fast does it
have any unnecessary pop-ups does it
does it have some quirky external links
that looks spammy okay you got to take
all these things into consideration and
think about the end user here then last
question for search engine marketing so
what are the hallmarks of a good ppc
landing page so going back to landing
page experience this is a good segue so
you always want to make sure you have an
attractive and powerful headline on the
page remember it's got to be a nice flow
you're bidding on a keyword somebody
types in the keyword they see your
attractive ad they click on that
attractive ad which has the keyword in
it they click on the ad they go to
landing page they want to be able to see
something very similar to what they
typed in the ad they saw they want to be
able to see it seamlessly on the landing
page and so that attractive and powerful
headline should include that key word
should also have persuasive copy that
can convince prospects to convert to me
bullet points always work here simple
bullet points easy to read easy to
understand easy to just convey the
positives about what you're trying to
sell or convert have engaging media like
videos videos always help because
they're interactive it keeps people
engaged longer or have some really good
images don't just go stock photography
you know compliment the video with some
images and then your landing pages
should have enough white space to draw
attention to specific elements on the
page and meaning don't cram the page
together because remember users are also
coming to these pages via mobile so you
gotta take that in consideration as well
so cramming your pages full of content
videos and images is probably not gonna
bode well so make sure there's breathing
room for people to read understand and
react and those are hallmarks of a good
ppc landing page some other factors here
adding trust indicators like
some statistical evidence meaning how
many people downloaded your app you can
always have testimonials you know
third-party sales of approval like
better business bureau you know privacy
policy links help okay so you want to
add some things in there that's gonna
you know give you credibility having a
properly designed lead capture form to
collect visitors information is always
helpful if you're trying to get that
conversion then have a lead form make it
simple don't have a lead form with 20
forms or fields you know have a simple
name
email address make the phone number
optional and have one feel that they can
type in specific information and then
last but certainly not least have a good
call to action so make sure that call to
action aligns with what you're trying to
do again selling those red adidas
running shoes if they're on sale then
you know make sure the call to action
aligns with that sale you can always say
you have 20 off for the next two days or
you know 10 off if you purchase today so
have some good strong call to action
okay let's turn our attention to email
marketing so email marketing's
traditional digital marketing channel
it's been around a while and you're
going to be asked some questions that
are going to encompass a lot of things
related to the delivery of emails uh we
all check emails on a daily basis we all
receive them sometimes we receive emails
unsolicited sometimes we sign up to
receive emails sometimes we receive
emails from friends sometimes we receive
emails where we're working or previously
worked so most people have an
understanding of email however as a
marketer there's a little bit of a
different twist to it so we have to
understand the intricacies of how email
marketing works so you're going to be
asked some questions and really the
first question here is what's the
difference between a hard and a soft
balanced email so if you're a digital
marketer you're in charge of sending out
lots of emails let's just say thousands
or i mean it could be in the hundreds of
thousands of emails you're going to get
some bounces and so you really want to
know the difference between a hard and a
soft bounce so a soft bounce just means
that the email message reached the
recipient's mail server but bounce back
is undelivered so think of it as
delivering actual mail to a post office
so it actually reached the post office
but it bounced back because
maybe the
you know person's email box was full
maybe their account was temporarily
disabled or maybe the email server
wasn't necessarily able to handle that
email now hard balance is an email that
that is rejected because it's an email
when it happens when the email has been
permanently rejected so for example
maybe the the the account is no longer
valid and so let's look at some reasons
again as to why a soft bounce would
happen so
for example the inbox is full or
the recipient server's down so reach the
post office but there was a problem
actually getting it into the hands of
the owner so to speak where the hard
balance a little bit different let's
just say that person is no longer
working their email has been deleted or
you the email has been blacklisted
somehow okay a spam or something to that
effect so the email server is going to
identify that and it's not even going to
reach the recipient so
a lot of different ways in which an
email may not make its recipient so now
the most important thing to know here i
just the important thing to know is
listen when you send out an email you
got to pay attention to how many get
bounced back and so
next question here what would you do to
improve the click-through rate of your
email so click-through rate is simply
how many people have seen your email and
how many people actually clicked on a
link in the email so if a hundred people
saw your email but only one person
clicked then it would be a one percent
click-through rate so we want to be able
to make sure we have a high
click-through rate so remember emails
are going to people who likely signed up
to receive your email and even if they
are expecting an email or they're not
expecting the email you still want to
follow some of these best practices here
one is to create a compelling subject
line so you want to make the subject
line something that people are going to
notice take note of or take an interest
in and say hey what's this all about
that's pretty interesting and open the
email so use preview text effectively
obviously you want to make your email
mobile friendly because most people look
at their emails on their mobile phones
you want to create engaging content okay
so the content that's in the email
obviously is going to have some links so
put some strong call to action in there
and that's one of the bullet points down
below place a cta where it's easily
visible so keep in mind mobile users
most people are going to check that
email on their phone so you want to make
sure you have compelling content with
good ctas in a visible location so
always check mobile as well as desktop
obviously in your emails you want to
make them as visual as possible don't
make them so text heavy you can always
segment your emails meaning if you're
sending out an email let's just say to
100 people okay maybe you want to divide
it up boys or girls maybe older or young
maybe you know living in one part of the
country versus another part of the
country i mean those are examples of
segments so break up the email don't
send it to
one mass email to everyone that way you
can personalize the email if an email is
personalized the chances of somebody
clicking on it are going to be greater
and then maybe test your emails and when
we say a b test you know you can send
out the same email twice
except one segment's going to say get
one version of the email the other
segment is going to get another version
of the email and what are the different
versions maybe the subject line so the
subject line is different on version a
versus version b or maybe the call to
action is different so you always want
to
send out different versions of the same
email to a different segmented audience
that way you can actually see which
segment or which version got the most
clicks okay so next question here is how
to inform your customers about company
news and establish a relationship with
your target audience okay so again how
do you inform your customers about
what's going on in the company and how
are you going to establish a
relationship with that audience who's
receiving that email well newsletters
are always the best answer here so
somebody signs up for your email let's
just say they actually purchase a
product from you newsletters are great
way to reach out to that audience to get
them to stay up to date with the latest
product or an improved version of the
product they purchased and then that way
they can come back and continue to
purchase the product so newsletters are
great way to reach out to
your audience and actually talk to your
audience and you're not talking verbally
you're talking to them via email so you
send out that email campaign maybe it's
once a month hey we noticed you bought
this product we have similar products
just like the one you bought or hey
you know if it's a software maybe hey
we've got upcoming updates to our
software make sure you go to the website
and get the updates or we have a new and
improved version so all these things you
want to communicate to your audience via
email that's going to get them to get to
the website and that's going to get them
to you know purchase more update upgrade
whatever so newsletters the way to go so
again some basic tips here you want to
create your newsletter with 90
educational and 10 percent promotional
so remember you're sending out a
newsletter to people who likely signed
up so you're educating them about your
products always create interesting
subject lines you want whether they know
you or not you want to create the
subject line so somebody's going to
click on it so
make sure you design your emails
appropriately okay so if you know you're
sending let's just say baby products to
mothers or expected mothers in fact this
is a real life example because i used to
work at a gap and
baby gap was you know one of the emails
groups i was responsible for so we
created an email template with softer
colors your yellows your your light blue
you know it wasn't black or dark red or
anything that's going to be you know
heavy we knew who our audience was and
we designed the template accordingly and
of course using compelling images so for
selling baby products you're gonna put
baby product images in there i mean it's
common sense but you'd be surprised you
gotta pick and choose your images
carefully especially if you're sending
to an international audience because
images can be misconstrued
and just like we mentioned with the
click-through rate you always want to
have a clear cta always make sure you
have a cta in a visible position because
most people are going to look at that
email in a mobile phone okay and then
always make sure you include your
contact information in the newsletter so
somebody knows where to find you how to
contact you where to go maybe they have
a product they want to return okay so
you always want to put that contact
information normally it's at the bottom
of the email but these are all best
practices so
here's some examples okay we got you
know check out the latest cosmetics from
our new collections notice the image and
notice the call to action so you can see
trendy collections you know we got some
other products you may want to buy okay
five important skin care products that
everyone should have view more so you
always want to have that call to action
in a very visible place so define
following metrics open rate
click-through rate and response rate and
forward rate so these are metrics
related to email marketing so you're
going to have to know what these are so
we already mentioned click-through rate
before when we talked about best
practices for improving the
click-through rate so for those of you
that remember what that is go ahead and
put that in the comment section below
just a little pop quiz for you if
anybody remembers click-through rate but
let's take a look at open rate so open
rate is the percentage of the total
number of recipients who actually open
the email so if you send it to
x amount of people how many people
opened it that would be the open rate so
how many people open it but you're gonna
take out the people who balanced it
whether it's a soft bounce a hard bounce
okay you're not going to count those
people so
if you had let's just say
20 people open the email and you sent it
to a hundred people then and you had
nobody balanced then it would be a 20
open rate okay click through rate again
pop quiz it's just how many people
actually clicked on any of the links in
your email and that's just divided by
the number of of the emails you've sent
out response rate okay so response rate
is the percentage of the total
recipients who clicked on the link of
your email campaign and actually
completed an action so what is that
action well it could be downloading
something watching something purchasing
something so that's the response rate
similar to conversion rate if you're
working in a digital marketing channel
and you're driving traffic to the site
you want that traffic to do something
well it's no different in email
marketing we want people to take action
we're just going to divide that by the
number of emails delivered and that
gives you your response rate so let's
just say you did send in 100 emails you
did get 20
open it and of this 20 let's just say
one person went on a purchase well you'd
have a one percent response rate and
then a forward rate is simply the
forward rate refers to the rate at which
your subscribers share your email uh
with others friends family etc and you
may have that as a call to action in
your email in fact that's a best
practice so it's just the number of
clicks on a share divided by the total
number of delivered emails and you're
going to multiply that by 100 to get the
percentage and so most email marketing
platforms do measure forward rate okay
let's take a look at question 25 here
how do we capture inactive customers
what you want to do here is re-engage
subscribers with gamification opt for
subject lines like we have been missing
you or did we do something wrong you
want to run a poll or a competition and
re-engage with your subscribers again
trying to get people involved these
first three are all about getting people
involved so personalize your emails talk
to that person as if hey look i haven't
heard from you in a while how about
coming back and taking a look at our new
products just as you would a friend so
design always matters especially knowing
that you're talking to customers who
haven't been active okay this is a
segmented audience somebody who's
inactive so you want to have the right
design the right message the right
subject line that fits with that
customer's inactivity so you want to try
and do everything you can to get that
customer back and then you want to
follow a consistent schedule okay so
ideally when you schedule an email you
want to schedule the best time so you
have to know your audience obviously and
then you can always ask for feedback why
are they inactive why haven't they
purchased in a while so the whole idea
here from gamification like trying to
you know make a game out of it so make
it competitive to
adding polls to really personalizing it
these are all things that you can do to
get your customers back so 26 so what
are the different ways to segment buyer
personas so again when we talk about
segmentation we're talking about taking
a smaller piece the entire pie so what's
one way to break up that pie if you will
by geography okay so with geography you
could target your audience based on that
area and it could not necessarily have
to be by a part of the country it could
be all the way down to the province the
state the actual city the county okay if
you live in a small village okay all the
way up to the continent okay so think
about how you would break out the
segment by geography now obviously if
you break it out let's just say the
united states to the southern part well
the southern part you know in the winter
in the united states the southern part
is not going to be as cold to say the
northern part so that should tell you
hey if we're going to send an
email in the winter we're not going to
use snow and and blizzards as our theme
we're going to use probably a little bit
of sun so breaking it out by geography
helps you understand where your audience
lives you also have demographic
segmentation and this is simply just age
education income gender you know where
people work okay nationality anything
that's going to identify that user so
this is the best way to segment if you
know who your audience is by income or
gender i mean you're talking to a group
of like-minded people if they're all the
same age from the same generation then
you could talk to them appropriately and
you're not going to talk to
an older person the same way you would a
younger person so think about dagman
demographic segmentation because it
really helps you hone in on your
messaging then you have behavioral
segmentation so behavioral is based on
your audience's behavior have they
purchased before have they never
purchased were they searching for
something how long did they stay on the
site what products were they looking at
are they a lifetime customer so you can
look at behavior and decide how you want
to break out your emails by behavior and
this is a really good way if you're not
even sure who your audience is or where
they live and how old they are you could
certainly break out your audience by
behavior because you know who these
people are based on what they've done
previously because you're going to track
that information with analytics so you
know one way is obviously if somebody's
purchased that's a good way to segment
because you know these people believe in
you believe in your business believe in
your product so the way you can message
to somebody who's purchased before is
going to be different than somebody you
don't even know who they are if they
purchased or not okay so behavioral
segmentation to me is one of the the
easiest things the easiest ways to
segment your email list 27 how would you
drive repeat customers through email
marketing for the below scenario okay so
this is a pop quiz if you will again for
those of you that got click-through rate
correctly kudos let's see if you can go
two for two here okay so if you know the
answer to this go ahead and comment
below but let's just say give a few
examples of subject lines to drive
engagement for audiences based on the
following if i had an audience between
20 and 30 years old that were female and
the product were sandals okay what were
some of your subject lines be so i'm
gonna give you a minute to think about
that and put it in the comment section
below now remember this is an interview
based question so you're gonna have to
think on the spot i'm gonna give you a
minute but if somebody presented that to
you in an interview you need to be able
to you know react fairly quickly and
come up with some really attractive
subject lines here okay so here you go
here's another one uh so give a few
examples of subject lines to drive
engagement for 20 to 30 females for
footwear so you got friday sale coming
up buy branded sandals at the lowest
price okay so i like this one because
it's got a strong call to action buy
here you go this is even better because
50 off on branded sandals and free
shipping i mean who can't beat free
anything including shipping and if it's
50 off i mean these are key things so
you're putting the promotion and
percentage off all in the subject line
so that's really going to grab
somebody's attention weekend sale for
women starts now okay with a little
emoji that never hurts so those are all
good subject lines they all tend to work
because they all have an element of a
best practice in there so
here you got you know the friday sale
coming up is just giving people notice
okay the stronger call to action on the
buy you're putting the promotion in the
subject line and you know using an emoji
to really just drive home the point so
all these subject lines will work and
hey at the end of the day remember you
want to test your subject lines okay
moving on to the next question speaking
of testing what does a be tested and
give some examples of a b testing okay
so we talked a little bit about a b
testing with subject lines so simply a b
testing when it comes to email marketing
it's just a method to analyze which of
the two email campaign strategies is
most effective right now you're going to
do it based on open rate you can do it
by saying click rate you can do it based
on response rate and remember you're
putting one version of the email against
another version whether that be the
subject line whether it be the content
call to action whatever so that's
ideally what you're trying to do you're
trying to figure out what works for your
audience that's the end goal for email
for a b testing and email marketing
what's going to work and i would highly
suggest you should always do a b testing
for subject lines always so some of the
variables that you can test again
subject lines okay you always want to
try if you got a
promotion hey will the percentage off
work likely it will but let's test it up
against something else like you know a
generic word like discounts you can
always test the design you can always
test the personalization the preview
text you can try out images call to
actions exclusive offers what particular
offer is to work okay so if you're
testing offers then obviously that's
going to be response rate if you're
testing ctas and that's going to be
click-through rate if you're testing
subject lines that's going to be open
rate so you want to be able to test
different elements of the email to
figure out what works and what doesn't
work okay so how to prevent email from
getting into spam so if you're an email
marketer this is your worst nightmare
you don't want your emails to get
spammed so that doesn't bode well for
you so most email marketing platforms
like mailchimp or constant contact
measure spam so some of the important
ways to prevent this is hey improve your
open rate remember going back to the
first question second question you want
to have really good subject lines here
okay and you want to segment your
audience so if you're if you know who
you're talking to and you have a cool
subject line that's going to get
somebody to react and open then that's
going to prevent somebody from spamming
your email okay you can always customize
your from to make it look like it's
coming from in this case rob sanders
check if you have included an
unsubscribe link okay so get people the
option to unsubscribe they don't have
the option to unsubscribe they could
just report you as spam make sure your
emails work on different devices okay
you want to optimize your images for
email make sure they're not big and they
don't fit on a mobile device okay prefer
more text and fewer images and then
avoid grammatical issues you want to
come across as professional you don't
want somebody looking at your email like
who sent this why you sent it to me i
don't want to hear from you again i'm
going to spam you you want to prevent
that and that means a professional
looking email professional content with
a really good subject line and some
imagery to go along with that hey you
may just get somebody to open that email
and get them to convert that's the idea
behind it so these are ways to prevent
somebody from actually spamming you and
then what are the best practices for
email subject lines so the subject line
is the most probably the most important
element in email marketing so we talked
about that little pop quiz with the
sandals targeting 20 to 30 year old
women you know to me i like the subject
line with the 50 off so that was a
number in the subject line so people can
actually see hey wow i get a whole 50
that works better than just a discount
okay remember one of those other subject
lines had an emoji so don't be afraid
and include emojis in there for example
when i send out emails using you know
during the spring you might want to use
flowers perhaps to signify hey it's
spring winter's over so personalize the
subject lines remember that goes with
segmenting so if you know who your
audience is your your subject lines can
be a little bit more personal okay so
off for title case subject lines okay so
instead of making it grammatical for
example okay you want to keep your
subject lines short and to the point
remember you want to say something
that's going to draw somebody's
attention if you make it long and drawn
out and boring then people aren't going
to open it develop a sense of urgency
like hey we got 50 off through friday so
that's a little sense of urgency so
people know hey if it's thursday i
better open this email and check it out
and again grammatical mistakes that goes
without saying you always want to
preview your emails before you send them
out so if you preview your emails before
you send them out have somebody else
obviously receive the preview they can
be another set of eyes for you to
prevent any mistakes but also give you
feedback on the imagery the design etc
okay so these are all best practices for
good subject lines okay so subject line
is a most important element for email
marketing so just keep these in mind
subject lines and having good subject
lines is the way to get people to open
it and from there that's half the battle
somebody can open the email then you've
just
set yourself up for better performance
okay let's turn our attention from email
marketing to social media marketing one
of the interesting channels hot trend
channel a lot of people want to get into
social media marketing a lot of jobs
available but you have to know what
you're doing so let's get into it uh and
here's some questions you might be
asked in an interview related to
social media marketing social media
marketing is very interactive
a lot of people posting information
whether it be a tweet a post
sharing liking engaging commenting i
mean a lot of things going on in social
media so some of it is going to probably
be good most of it's probably going to
be good but every once in a while you're
going to get a negative comment so
you're probably going to be asked this
question how do you respond to negative
comments well very simple you got to be
quick to acknowledge okay don't sit on
it you know don't waste time
him and hot how you're gonna respond you
really have to acknowledge the comment
and start the process of constructive
engagement to turn the negative
experience into a positive one so let me
just expand on that for just a second we
know you like your brand we know you
like your product we know you're very
proud we get that i'm proud i like to
defend sometimes my beliefs however you
gotta put that aside when it comes to
social media why because everybody is
watching you and everybody can read what
you write so you the spotlight is on you
not necessarily the consumer the
customer who wrote the negative comment
so you really have to be cognizant here
and conscientious of what you post in
response so be quick but be constructive
because you want to turn that negative
into a positive that's really what it's
starting with so how do you do that well
how do you be constructive well see it
from the customer's point of view take
off your ownership hat if you will your
manager hat and put on the customer's
hat always look at something from
somebody else's perspective try to
understand
why that person wrote that negative
comment and ask yourself how you can
make it right so if you're the customer
and you are your customer when you go to
the store and buy food you're the
customer when you go to store and buy
clothes when you buy a car you're the
customer so ask yourself what you can do
to make it right why you're thinking in
the customer's perspective or looking
through their eyes if you will to me
it's it's not an easy thing to do but
it's something you have to do okay so
always look at it from a customer's
point of view and then take it out of
the spotlight so
really because everybody's looking at
you waiting to see how you respond and
remember this customer that wrote the
negative comment can certainly share
your comments to the world so you got to
be really really careful i mean how many
times have we seen on youtube you know
poor customer experience going viral on
on via video so you just gotta really be
careful here so take it out of the
spotlight so offer to resolve the
customer's problems in an appropriate
forum offer up your phone number an
email give them a link to a feedback
form or get their email or phone number
and call them these are the best ways to
really bend this into a more positive
experience for the customer i mean at
the end of the day could become
something really small and silly but
don't make a mountain out of a mall hill
if it is something small and silly how
you respond could make it and see more
than what it really is so be quick be
constructive look at it from the
customer's point of view and offer as
much support as you possibly can okay
that's how you want to respond if
somebody asks that question in an
interview some other comments here so
keep track although the issue might be
solved it doesn't necessarily mean the
commenter has gone away so follow up
with them if you resolved it follow up
with them a month later hey surprise
them two months later give them a a
discount okay you'd be surprised
positivity goes a long way and it's
always nice when somebody actually
follows up with you after the fact just
to make sure they want to know that
you're taken care of and then don't feed
the social media trolls okay so ignoring
trolls across social media will make
sure they don't enjoy the notoriety it
brings so don't even allow the
negativity to feed itself so that's why
you really have to stay quick
constructive you know look at it from a
customer's point of view and just turn
this whole experience into a positive
experience it's an opportunity for you
to hone your skills let's move on to
another question so somebody may ask you
to give an example of a successful
social media campaign okay so if you're
going in to interview for social media
manager job you probably want to do your
homework in advance look at what other
people have done
so here's a good example spotify you can
see this spotify ad here with ed sharon
spotify mind the search and playlist
data of its user base to develop a
thematic branded ad experience on
billboards in 18 markets around the
world first of all let's just take this
and break it down ed sharon's popular
you can see here be as loving as the
person who put 48 ed sheeran songs on
their i love gingers playlist so
messaging is everything okay and then
you can see what spotify did they mine
the search and playlist data of its user
base okay so they try to understand
their audience going back to email you
gotta understand your audience okay then
they used that to develop a branded
experience on different markets around
the world so they took an audience and
they really marketed this around the
world okay to something that was really
hot and trendy i'd love to see how this
thing actually performed my guess is it
did perform fairly well because when
you're spotify you're gonna pick
something hot and trendy to get people
to react and so to me this seems like
just on the surface a very successful
social media campaign here's some other
things uh you can see these ads were
featured on the sides of buildings
subway platforms a long busy streets so
it wasn't just digital per se i mean
they really went full bore on the
billboards and those billboards were
everywhere on the sides of buildings
again in 18 different markets so you can
see it wasn't just necessarily edge
sharing per se but you know they had
some good messaging and gr enjoy green
light at every red light that's pretty
cool i guess if you're stuck in traffic
in the middle of a city less fake news
more fake magic so they really took and
honed in the type of music put some good
messaging behind it and really put it
out there so it doesn't always
necessarily have to you know necessarily
be digital per se but they what they did
was they did post this on the sides of
buildings and subway platforms and
throughout different city streets for
maximum visibility for their fans to
upload to their social media okay so do
your homework okay and on this next
question you certainly want to do your
homework so if you're a social media
manager you're probably going to be
involved in some facebook advertising
okay so this is a basic straight up
question what are some of the different
types of ads you can run on facebook you
know you can do single image ads most of
us have probably seen that you can do
multi-product lead ads slideshows
collection ads video ads i mean you got
all sorts of a variety of different ad
formats here okay so let's take a look
at these ad formats single image again
most of us have seen it okay it's just
simply a single image that you know how
allows you to put some text at the top a
link at the bottom or link to your
website or your facebook page and a
strong call to action okay so facebook
has that built into their ad platform
okay so the ad images need to be 1200 by
628 pixels that's a pretty nice size
image multi-product ads so multi-product
ads are
represented in carousel form so
basically it allows you the end user to
view the range of products just by
scrolling and notice each one of these
products has a call to action so here
you can see simply learn offering up all
the different courses they have to offer
so if you have a customer that has
multiple products this is probably the
way you want to go so video ads are very
popular on facebook so video ads usually
range from a few seconds all the way up
to 120 minutes and again video is very
engaging if you have video use the video
okay because they receive about 10 to 30
more views than other forms of ads okay
who doesn't like engaging with video
pretty simple you have lead ads so lead
ads allow you to obtain user details
like name phone number email right in
facebook's environment so it allows you
to collect information right then and
there so lead ads can be effective if
you're trying to get people to sign up
for something slideshow so we looked at
those multi-product ads where you had
the carousel slideshow simply just
allows you to rotate different creative
with nice imagery so the key here is
nice imagery okay you want to put your
best foot forward choose the right
imagery just like going back to the
email marketing you know going back to
pay-per-click you want to use some
effective ads here and images in the ads
okay you also have collection ads that's
another option on facebook so collection
x ads combine video slideshow or product
images taken from your product catalog
so i would recommend this for users who
want to advertise several of their
products at once okay again simply learn
has a lot of different courses a lot of
different thousands of courses so you
know collection ads works for them you
can see here you got social media
certification you got ppc certification
seo certification okay these are all
different certification courses you
could take it simply learn and they want
to go ahead and promote all those
courses together so lo and behold
collection ads offers the best option
here so pay attention those different ad
formats on facebook okay next question
how can you use the holiday season for
social media marketing well this is a
nice segue from the previous question
because you know you have on facebook
all these different ad types so you
could change your ad placements to ones
lesser used by other advertisements you
can also set up clear simple and
compelling offers for your users the
holiday season you're likely going to
have some sales and again make sure your
images have under 20
of text okay that's a standard across
the board but again you want to have
nice imagery so think about all those
different ad formats on facebook think
about the holiday season and how you can
accentuate your ads here okay i'm
thinking video here i'm thinking a
promotion in the video i'm thinking a
collection ad where you can run
different products maybe with a
promotion with some nice imagery during
the holiday season so you definitely
have
a plethora of options not just on
facebook but across social media for the
holidays because normally you're going
to have promotions some other things you
can do to
really maximize the holiday season for
social media and that's make
advertisements emotionally resonate with
your audience the holiday season is a
time really where you reflect on the air
you get together with friends and family
and it's religious and you know it's a
feel good in some parts of the world the
weather changes so you want to resonate
on that okay you want to resonate on
that emotion okay you always holiday
season or not you want to monitor
reports to scale successful ad campaigns
and obviously the ones that aren't
performing you want to pause okay so
with the holiday season you're likely
going to have an uptick in traffic an
uptick in eyeballs so pay attention you
don't want to spend money for money's
sake so on facebook it's a cost per
click model so you don't want to be
generating clicks without seeing any
results so go ahead and pay attention
maximize those ads that are performing
and get rid of the ones that aren't okay
and then connect the holiday with your
products or services so again think
about which ones you're going to
accentuate which ones you're going to
make more prominent during the holiday
season again thinking back to the
facebook ad types i'm thinking
carouseller collection ads if you can
really pump up some of your products and
have a nice promotion with them you can
run some nice collection ads on facebook
okay moving on to the next question so
somebody may ask you hey how do you make
content go viral okay i always wondered
that myself how does content go viral
it's a great question so really you're
not in necessarily in control but you
can certainly do some things to make it
more appealing for the end user to go
ahead and share it i mean that's what
going viral is right a lot of people
sharing it because the more people that
share the more people are gonna look and
find it just as enticing and they're
gonna turn around and share it so how do
you start that process really is what it
comes down to well create short form
content short form content is more
likely to go viral in other words a 10
minute video is probably not going to
resonate with somebody something cute
funny interesting unique out of this
world in 15 30 seconds is probably gonna
go viral so what does that mean make the
visual content like images and video it
works better than bodies of text so make
sure those images and video are really
compelling and then run giveaways to
draw attention and generate brand
awareness and engagement so you can
always
incentivize your users with a giveaway
or some type of promotion that's going
to maybe pique somebody's interest you
know share it with a hundred friends and
get 10 off as an example so these are
some of the things you can do to make it
go viral of course if you're trying to
get something to go viral you definitely
want to monitor behavior and then tweak
once you figure out how it's performing
okay you may have chosen the wrong
images you may have the wrong promotion
you may find that the content is a
little bit longer than you probably like
and you may want to cut it down some
other things you could do here is use
some trending hashtags and topics on
your post so ride that wave if you will
for any surfers in the audience hey two
people can ride the same wave so if you
got a trending hashtag use that hashtag
with that video or post you can always
ask users to interact okay so you can
always ask them to like or share
especially if they're your audience
because when somebody actually shares it
that means they're sharing it with
somebody else who also has an audience
so that's a quick way to get the ball
going so to speak the ball bouncing okay
so next question which industries
perform better with different platforms
great question there's a lot of
different social media platforms you got
your most popular ones all the way down
to your least popular ones i mean let's
face it social media platforms are also
geographic so some social media
platforms are more popular in say the
united states than say india russia and
vice versa we know china has a lot of
different social media platforms that
most americans in the united states
don't even use so you got to keep that
in mind but we're not talking about
geography we're talking about industry
so you got to also think about industry
here so generally in facebook it's
usually food and beverage news and media
e-commerce those are the types of
industries that you might tend to see on
facebook when we talk about e-commerce
you know it could be clothing it could
be you restaurant okay selling or it
could be a a food company selling you
know foods and beverages you also have
instagram so instagram tends to be more
beauty food and beverage e-commerce so
when we talk about beauty we're talking
about clothes we're talking about makeup
you know maybe shoes dresses unique
styles i see a lot of that on instagram
and then linkedin for example generally
works with you know for me i look at
linkedin as b2b okay so anything you
know interesting in a specific industry
you're probably going to see some news
items and updates on that tips and best
practices and of course jobs a lot of
recruiters on linkedin so linkedin's a
good place for you to really put
yourself out there to find that job you
seek that social media manager job okay
so here's a breakdown if you will of the
top five again in the united states you
know for those users who are watching
this from another country you know you
may find i'll be interested if you could
get some feedback here you know in the
comment section of the video go ahead
and put you know the social media
platform you use in your country and
generally what do you see on that
platform do you see food and beverage do
you see gaming or entertainment do you
see e-commerce so share your thoughts
and knowledge with the rest of us so
next question how would you measure
social media marketing success of an
organization and this is a likely
question a question you're likely going
to get okay how do you measure success
and that's across the board not just
social but ppc email marketing display
affiliate so really you're always going
to have the right answer if you talk and
think about conversion so with
conversions about tracking content
downloads or sales or registrations or
legion or form submissions anything
where you're going to get something in
return okay so to me that's the general
answer here you know how do we measure
success well it always depends on
strategy but if you're trying to get a
sale from instagram based on your beauty
product or you got a promotion you're
running on facebook and you're running a
lead form type ad okay are you getting
people to enter in that enter in details
on the form submission do you always
want to track conversions from that
perspective okay you also have
engagement okay so your strategy may not
be conversion maybe your strategy is
simply brand awareness and engagement
you want to know how many people
participate in the conversation for
example you may post something that's
really you know hot trends it's trending
it's it's political it could be business
it could be a world of fair you want to
be able to measure how many people react
how many people comment reply repost
retweet share like etc so
engagement metrics vary across different
social media platforms but basically
when it comes to engagement you can
measure it just has to align with the
right strategy you also have awareness
again if you're just simply in it for
brand awareness okay it's all about how
many people are actually looking at it
the total volume of people okay and how
widely your message is spreading okay
what's the reach it could also be just
simply traffic to your website so you
can certainly track traffic to your
websites by clicks or shares so it
doesn't always have to be about
conversion or engagement it can simply
hey we want to drive traffic to the
website it's at 37. what are some things
to focus on when advertising on twitter
okay you can advertise on twitter
whether you knew that or not now you
know twitter is a platform where you can
pay for advertising so
what do you want to focus on when you do
advertise on twitter well you want to
emphasize urgency to make sure users
take immediate action you want to
express discounts and percentages why
well because you're limited in what you
can say on twitter you want to avoid
using hashtags that don't pertain to
your brand and product i know that may
sound like common sense but remember
you're advertising in here so you got to
be really really really careful because
you're paying you're paying for somebody
to either look at that ad or click on
that ad so some other things you want to
keep focus on is your ad copy it's got
to be short and to the point and then
make sure your ads are mobile friendly
again just like most social media
platforms twitter is no different people
are looking at twitter on their mobile
phones so video ads should have
subtitles images in the proper ratio so
you always want to think mobile mobile
mobile mobile because most people are
using mobile on their mobile phones
whether that be in the browser or via an
app okay next question how can you use
social media to promote your event okay
so you got an event coming up i want to
promote it so you're going to turn to
social media and the first thing you do
is have affiliates fans and attendees
share resources about the event okay use
leverage your community in other words
okay you can remarket the event to
potential attendees using facebook ads
so you can do remarketing and
remarketing is basically hey somebody
who's seen it or been there or done that
you're retargeting those people you can
use photos of attendees and social
updates so depending on the event you
can have some really high profile
attendees speaking at the event or just
attending the event so use photos to
drive excitement about the event okay
you can create a uniform hashtag that
can be shared across multiple channels
you can mention the event all social
media bios so don't just limit it to one
you know cross promote it on twitter
linkedin etc and what you could do is if
you've run other events in the past
create a highlight rail from prior
events you know show people hey your
events are the events you must attend
they're the go-to events because they're
popular they're successful good
attendees usually good attendance and
then some other things you could do here
share behind the screens visual content
and again you could share pictures of
guest speakers along with your quotes
okay so you want to do everything
possible at your at your disposal
especially on social media to really
pump up the event next question how can
you perform a b testing on your ads so
for those of you that listen intently on
the email marketing part remember a b
testing is key with email marketing what
are we testing in email we're testing
subject lines we're testing layout we're
testing call to action so the same thing
here on social media you want to do
continuous a b testing to figure out
what works and doesn't work it's very
simple the great thing about facebook is
they got an a b test feature built in so
you can certainly test different ads
great thing about facebook i like is
that you can simply start out with an
app by running an a b test you could
simply test the imagery it could be a
male versus a female you could test the
call to action a lot of things you could
test so things you can change are again
color of the elements you could change
the positioning you could change the
audience you're targeting the call to
action i mean everything everything
because the whole point is you want to
see which one works which one doesn't
work so testing can be done initially on
broader elements and then smaller finer
details like statements in your ad copy
so you could start out big just by
testing the imagery and so the female
tends to work better than male then you
know what works in terms of imagery well
take the next step and start honing it
on say the message and then once you
figure out what message works then you
can move to the next element like cta
some interesting questions you may get
include what are some things to focus on
when setting up your ad creative this
goes back almost to the a b testing you
want to use ad creative that's attention
grabbing and relevant for your business
so use a primary but bold color scheme
so you also want to you stay away from
clip art okay so again align your
imagery really is important on social
media don't use some basic cheap clipart
you don't necessarily always have to use
stock imagery either i mean it could be
imagery you took that's very relevant
and unique to your product but if you do
that don't use low resolution pixelated
images use images that are well lit so
decide on the aesthetic you want for
your creative clean and minimal or
colorful and vibrant it really depends
on you know the advertisement what it is
you're trying to promote so some other
things to focus on here to create
attention-grabbing ads show images of
people benefiting from your product and
coca-cola has done this forever when
have you never seen a coca-cola
commercial with somebody with a smile on
your face drinking a bottle of coke i
don't think i've ever seen an
advertisement so when it comes to food
you should always have somebody in there
enjoying the food if it comes to clothes
should have somebody looking like they
really enjoy wearing these clothes and
they look great in them you want to
accentuate that with you know some nice
coloring sticking with your brand
guidelines okay so imagery really is
important here so you do need to make
sure the ad works for your brand without
requiring explanatory copy the image
should basically speak for itself okay
so let's finish up with content
marketing content marketing another big
digital marketing channel a lot of work
out there so if you're going in for an
interview let's review some of the
questions you may get asked okay so
starting out what are the essential
components of a good web content okay so
essential components okay so what do we
want our content to do well we want it
to be useful so web content should be
written in a way which caters to what
the reader wants okay so somebody's not
going to read your content if it's not
useful for them okay this because it
affects reader engagement okay so if
it's not interesting it's not useful
somebody's just not going to read it
plain and simple it also has to be
engaging so listen even if it is
relevant to a user you still have to
write the content so it's engaging so
you want to add elements like imagery
videos hey you can even turn your
content into an infographic okay you
want to do something that's going to be
engaging for the user if it's engaging
they're going to read it and engage with
the content okay and then good content
should have some call to action so
content must be written in a way that
can drive call to action okay so if
you're writing a blog post you know i've
seen a lot of blog posts just simply
start and with good content but it
doesn't leave the user with anywhere to
go so have that call to action put some
internal links in that content give
somebody a place to go after done
engaging with the good content that you
write okay so some other things to think
about some other components for good
content well credibility so you know
anybody can write but are you writing
about something you know what you're
writing about are you a good talking
point a good expert or have experience
about this content so you also want to
use you know information from a
legitimate source okay so you don't want
to grab something in your and use it in
your content that's just not legitimate
because it does hurt your credibility
and the organization's credibility and
then also originality i mean write
something
that nobody else has written so
obviously you don't want to plagiarize
because if you plagiarize and there are
tools out there where people can easily
just put their content in there to see
what else is out there see if somebody
else has plagiarized it so it's very
easy to find people who plagiarize so
don't be that person what i would
recommend create a good content calendar
and come up with some ideas before you
write them next question related to
content marketing so what are the types
of content you can create well there are
a lot of things you can create start
with the blog blog to me is always a
great place to start it's a blank canvas
for your ideas your thoughts your
opinions okay that's a great thing about
a blog it accentuates personality you
can create a video videos are always
engaging you can create an infographic
infographics to me are you know hidden
gem instead of somebody reading the same
old same old you're laying this out in a
very visual way that's easy to
understand create a case study okay so
if you're a digital marketing expert
you've done social media for another
client you know write about it you know
show the successes show that you are an
expert show that you've created
successful campaigns and social and in
the form of case study you can create a
white paper white papers are good
educational pieces you can also create
an ebook okay ebook hey if you have a
lot of content you want to lay it out
and ebook's a good way to go and you
have a lot of choices here when it comes
to content a lot of choices okay so what
are the advantages of having a content
counter so i alluded to that just a
couple of seconds ago so let's really
break this down here because content
counters to me are so important well
first of all calendar part of content
calendar allows you to think about dates
so
if you're planning something you're
going to have important dates in mind
okay so content calendar it almost
ensures you don't miss anything you know
that's a good opportunity for you to
leverage like you know black friday
cyber monday you know it's probably
important you know when those days are
if you're in e-commerce so that's why
having a content calendar helps it helps
you plan out your content based on
important dates or based on dates that
work for what you're trying to do they
also help because you could stick to a
consistent schedule okay so if you don't
have a content calendar you're probably
just arbitrarily writing content here
and there well what if your users crave
and really engage with the content
they're going to want more sticking to
something consistent is going to really
get people come back for more they know
when you're going to post they're going
to be waiting for it and if it's every
tuesday morning eight o'clock hey post
it tuesday morning eight o'clock your
users will get used to that schedule and
it does help build up your following it
does help help build up your community
and in the end cultivates a long-lasting
relationship and then having a content
calendar also allows you to mix up your
content okay so you can see and plan
ahead different types of content in
different formats that way it allows you
to mix it up whether it be a blog post
uh an infographic a video about
different topics okay some other
advantages here saving time it just
allows you to prepare for the future
when you can prepare you're efficient
and when you're efficient you're not
wasting time and so to me having a
content calendar is a must because a lot
of us are busy who has time especially
if you're going to work in a new company
so let's say writing content you
definitely want to have a content
counter because you're going to want to
use that time to efficiently plan this
is a new company you're going to start
working at you want to understand who
this company is what they've done in the
past what you haven't done and what you
want to do okay so all of that helps you
plan and prepare and it saves you the
time and effort and hassle down the road
and then at the end of the day you want
to be able to figure out what works so
planning your post puts less strain on
you and your team members as well as
company resources because when you plan
and you post you're going to get data
and then when you get data it's either
going to work or not work and if it
doesn't work then you know in the future
you're not going to put that piece of
content or the topic in the content
calendar again it's that simple okay
some other advantages fresh content okay
so having a con content calendar allows
you to always keep content fresh can
you're gonna be on a consistent schedule
and you're not gonna be writing about
the same things over and over again so
it could be just simply twitter if
you're putting a content calendar in
it together for twitter well you don't
want to have the same tweets every other
day so it does ensure that you're
getting tweets out there that are fresh
that are new that are different and
again figure out what works a content
counter makes it easier to measure
results and optimize performance so you
always want to you know maybe put some
metrics in with your content calendar so
you can see side by side content
historically that is performed content
that is not performed okay so next
question you may get what type of
content works in each stage of the
customer life cycle so you have
awareness engagement purchase
post-purchase advocacy okay so let's
break these down here so awareness okay
so you want people to understand who you
are okay that could be a guest blog an
influencer helping yell it could be a
cold email a v a video that can
potentially go viral a social media post
introducing a product you have
engagement so you want people to engage
with your content what are you going to
do to get people to engage well you
could certainly write an email and have
people open that email and go to your
website you can have an ebook where
people can actually download and read it
or you can have a blog where people can
comment or landing page where they can
fill out a form submission you have
evaluation so with social media we know
there's a lot of engagement going on but
when you're putting content out there
you can certainly open it up to
testimonials okay you can generate white
papers okay or you can generate case
studies case studies a good way for
companies to evaluate what you've done
in the past if you've worked in it for a
specific product in the past and it's
worked you certainly want to put that
out there for potential clients in that
same industry purchase trying to get
people to purchase what are you gonna do
well you can certainly have landing
pages a nice you know website a nice
shopping cart with some nice content
okay onboarding emails get those emails
out there and get people to go back to
the website and purchase of course you
can have product and service details as
well meaning you know one one page
downloadable pdfs that describe the
product okay a post purchase okay so
people who've already purchased you
could certainly send out follow-up
emails and you can do blog roundups you
know give people an opportunity to see
what features or updates are happening
to the product okay of course case
studies of repeat customers or content
types that detail a new feature or
service okay so if somebody's already
purchased and you may want to send them
some content of another product that
complements the product they bought so a
lot of things you can do to engage with
your user who's already purchased and
then advocacy you want people to help
you out here so have the user generate
the content you can have exclusive
discounts for your community they're
going to be your advocates so give them
exclusive discounts and then pictures of
customers engaging with your products
okay who's not gonna share that so
you're gonna have people share that
information in other words you can
generate content where hey people can
help you out here and be your advocate
okay so how do you decide what topic and
subject to write on okay well going back
to the content counter that always helps
you to see what you put in that content
calendar but there are some other
methods you can use and you could
certainly identify your target audience
and not only identify your target
audience but what their needs are okay
so you can write content based on
audience you could certainly do some
research with keywords okay what's
trending what keywords are not trending
okay and right around what's trending
for example okay you could certainly
take a look at social media for example
cora i always look at korra core is
interesting entertaining informational
hey people are certainly having
conversations on core and you can
certainly analyze those conversations
because they certainly get in depth and
you can decide hey do i want to write a
topic around something that really just
won't go away in terms of conversing
core is a good example of analyzing
conversations they tend to be a little
bit more in depth so some other things
you could do you can look at your
competitors and what kind of
conversations are happening on your
competitors blogs or or your competitors
social media platforms and pages you can
keep track of blogs and articles from
subject matter experts commentators
critics and so on okay so you can get
ideas from them another question you may
get which is very important if you're
going to start working for a company you
need to understand the tone the tone of
your content because that is going to
fit and be in line with the company
you're working for okay so you're always
going to have a brand personality so the
characteristics of a brand are the
guidelines based on which the content
strategy is developed the tone of the
content must align itself to the content
strategy your audience profile so you
got you need to determine who your
audience is okay and how the brand wants
to be seen by that audience so you know
if you have an older audience you're not
going to use younger audience ie street
lingo or today's lingo and and the
younger generation uh you're going to
use you know language that's going to
fit the audience you're talking to and
then of course the channel itself so the
content you create must be irrespective
of the channel and consistent with brand
attributes okay so you gotta pick and
choose the channel if it's linkedin for
example hey you know linkedin's more
business oriented okay so you're not
gonna be
you know as humorous as you would be say
on instagram or facebook all of these
have one thing in common again that's
brand guidelines you have to stay within
the brand what is the brand's
personality how do we want to talk to
our audience and what platform are we
using to talk to our audience how do you
promote your content once it's live well
that's always a good question hey you
doing the the work the putting in the
hard work to create this you know it
could be a video and videos take a long
time it could be an infographic an ebook
okay so send it out via email okay if
you haven't an email list send it out
and let people know this content's there
put a link in the email or or even a
piece or snippet or preview of the
content in the email so you're using the
email to broadcast and encourage people
to you know if it's an ebook get the
rest of the ebook okay you could
certainly leverage social media to
engage with your community that's the
best you know just as good as email get
out there and let people know hey i got
i got my book published come and
download it you know you can give a
discount to the first 100 people that
download it okay you can always promote
your content via ads so whether that be
google or facebook you always have an
opportunity to meet more prominent by
advertising the content that you have to
offer so you can always reach out on
social media again targeting interesting
people directly so you can always
interact with people on social or you
can write for others attract people from
the web to important pages of your
website by guest posting so you can
always go on to a popular blog post and
write something and you know link it up
or or have it be relevant to the content
you've written so next question how can
you determine how well your content is
doing okay very important again you've
done all the work you put the content
calendar together you got the content
ready to go it's published you're
promoting it social email guest blogging
but you want to determine how it's doing
well depends on the channel really is
what it comes down to so if it's organic
search you want to be able to see if
it's ranking for the keywords you
optimize that content for if it's social
you want to be able to see if you have
engagement shares comments etc of course
you can always look at analytics and see
how much traffic that blog post is
getting or that page with the white
paper is getting okay so you can always
look at your analytics and look at the
traffic okay and again you can always
look to see if there are conversions in
the form of an inquiry or lead or sale
so at the end of the day you want to
align the content with the channel and
you want to align the kpi with the
content and channel okay so if it's
social you're not likely going to get
conversions unless you're doing paid ads
if you're posting organically on social
then you're probably going to get some
engagement so you have to align the
right metric with the right channel what
are the steps involved in the content
marketing process okay so
you really need to decide what goal you
want to achieve with the content
marketing campaign so that goes back to
what i was just saying a minute ago if
you have content you post it on social
then what's the goal what are you trying
to achieve well you're probably going to
get engagement and likes
you need to define buyer personas to
determine the audience best suited for
your content okay so you're always
writing for an audience and you're going
to market that content for that audience
so you always got to keep that in mind
okay run content audits audits to
determine the best type of content that
can be used in other words how did it
perform what kind of engagement did you
get with the infographic or did that
video really really perform well or do
we want to use you know a blog post next
time around or an image next time around
so continuing on here you want to choose
an appropriate content management system
okay so how are we managing all this
content okay is it wordpress or is it
another platform okay you could start
brainstorming for ideas for new content
so again that goes back to the content
calendar you leverage your content
counter to always create ideas for new
content okay then you want to settle on
a particular type of content that you
want to create okay so once you come up
and you're managing your content you you
come up with some ideas then you
obviously want to
choose the format and then of course you
want to publish and manage your content
after it's all said and done so these
are the steps involved again just
quickly decide on the goal the kpi
deciding your audience look at what's
worked and not worked in the past get
your content set up in the platform okay
or get the platform ready to go i should
say okay generate ideas with that
content counter i ideally go to the
content calendar for the ideas choose
that type and then publish and manage
and when i say manage i mean again going
back to analytics or going back to the
kpi that you align with that content to
see if it's performing or not okay so
next question here how do you target the
right audience for your content it's a
very good question you're not writing
content for everyone let's be honest
here so you have to collect demographics
of your target audience based on who's
coming to your website based on who
subscribed to your emails based on who's
following you on social media so in
other words you have people interacting
with you okay in different channels and
you need to understand who these people
are so are they fit a certain age range
your generation are they skewed more
female to male education level what's
their affinity or interest okay do they
have a certain income so you need to
really break down your audience here and
you could do that in analytics you could
do that on social you can do that just
by looking at your email list okay the
all those will paint a picture as to who
your audience is i hope this helps you
in your next interview with that we've
reached the end of this digital
marketing full course video by simply
learn i hope you enjoyed this video do
like and share it thank you for watching
and stay tuned for more from simply
learn
[Music]